hello everyone welcome to simply learn's
youtube channel if you are here to learn
the data science algorithms then you are
at the right place this data science
algorithms video will cover the most
important algorithms that would help you
in real life scenarios also if you are a
tech geek in a continuous hunt for
latest technological trends then
consider getting subscribed to our
youtube channel
we have daily updates on multiple
technologies and don't forget to hit
that bell icon so that you can never
miss an update from us
so without further ado let's dive into
the agenda for today's discussion so we
will be learning the data science
algorithms today by going through the
following docket at first we will learn
the logistic regression in r then we
will move ahead and know what is a
decision tree followed by that we will
understand what is clustering next we
will learn divisive clustering later the
support vector machine advancing ahead
we will have the k-means clustering and
lastly we will wind up the session by
learning time series analysis i hope i
made myself clear with the agenda
now escalating over to our training
experts hello and welcome to logistic
regression in r my name is pete ferrari
and i am with the simply learn team and
today we're going to cover logistic
regression in the r programming language
logistic regression is kind of a
misnomer in that when most people think
of regression they think of linear
regression which is a machine learning
algorithm for continuous variables
however logistic regression is a
classification algorithm not a
continuous variable prediction algorithm
logistic regression is also sometimes
called logit regression in this video we
are going to learn why we would use
regression as a predictive algorithm
what is regression the different types
of regression as i've already mentioned
some regression algorithms are
classification algorithms and some are
continuous variable algorithms why use
logistic regression what is logistic
regression and then we'll look at a use
case a college admission
using logistic regression so why would
we use regression well let's say we had
a website and our revenue was based on
the traffic that we could drive to that
website whether through r d or marketing
and we wanted to predict the revenue
based on site traffic and the website
traffic would be related to the revenue
we could generate the more traffic
driven to our website than the higher
our revenue or at least that's what we
would intuitively assume and so we need
to predict the revenue based on our
website traffic here we have the plot of
revenue versus website traffic traffic
would be considered the independent
variable and revenue would be the
dependent variable often the independent
variable or variables if we had more
than one could be called the explanatory
variables and the dependent variable
would be called the response variable
however we typically refer to them as
independent and dependent variables so
our intuition tells us that the
independent variable drives the
dependent variable and if there is some
relationship between the two variables
then we would say that there is a
correlation between the two variables
and then we may be able to use the
independent variable to make predictions
about the dependent variable if you look
at the chart on the right you'll see
there is a clear trend between website
traffic and revenue as website traffic
increases the revenue increases and we
could draw a line to show that
relationship and then we could use that
line as a predictor line so for example
what will revenue be if our traffic is
4.5 k and we see that when the traffic
is around 4 500 the revenue is around 13
000 and if we could draw a perpendicular
line from 4.5 k on the axis on the
x-axis the traffic axis up to the orange
regression line sometimes called the
line of best fit then we could draw
another line over to the y-axis the
revenue axis and we could see where it
lands and that would be the prediction
so in this example when the traffic is
around 45 000
hits the predicted revenue is around 13
000. normally we wouldn't actually draw
those lines we would generate an
equation and we would call that equation
a model and we could plug the
independent variable into the equation
to generate the dependent variable
output which we would call our
prediction so what is regression
regression is a statistical relationship
between two or more variables where a
change in the independent variable is
associated with a change in the
dependent variable it's important to
note that all variables are related to
each other for example a person's
favorite color may not be related to
revenue from a website here the change
in one variable height is closely
associated with the change in the other
variable age this makes intuitive sense
as you get older from when you're born
you get taller and it seems to make
sense if we plot that data we would see
those green points on the graph up to
some certain age where growth would
taper off in the plot in the middle of
the screen we see the clear linear
relationship between age and height
which is indicated by the solid red line
we sometimes call that line a trend line
or a regression line or the line of best
fit and we see that the height is the
dependent variable and age is the
independent variable of course you might
ask doesn't height depend on other
factors of course it does but here we're
looking at the relationship between two
variables one independent and one
dependent age and height there are
various types of regression linear
regression logistic regression multiple
linear regression polynomial regression
and there are others decision tree
regression random forest regression but
linear regression is probably the most
well known by definition when there is a
linear relationship between a dependent
variable which is continuous and an
independent variable which is continuous
or discrete we would use linear
regression when the y value in the graph
is categorical such as yes or no two or
false they voted they did not vote they
purchased something they did not
purchase something it depends on the x
variable logistic regression is when the
y value in the graph is categorical in
nature for example yes no purchased
don't purchase voted did not vote and it
depends on the x variable notice the
trend line for linear regression and the
line for logistic regression they're
different more on that later and there's
polynomial regression as well when the
relation between the dependent variable
y and the independent variable x is in
the nth degree of x sometimes we say an
nth degree polynomial of x in this
picture you can see that the
relationship is not linear there's a
curve to that best fit trend line so why
would we use logistic regression and we
need to understand why we would use
logistic regression and that linear
regression picking the machine learning
algorithm for your problem is no small
task and it really behooves us to
understand the difference between these
machine learning algorithms linear
regression answers the question how much
so in our earlier example if website
traffic grows then how much would
revenue grow whereas logistic regression
would answer what will happen or not
happen linear regression in general is
used to predict a continuous variable
like height and weight logistic
regression is used when a response
variable only has two outcomes yes or no
two or faults often we refer to logistic
regression as a binary classifier since
there are only two outcomes so let's try
to understand this with an example let's
say we have a startup company and we are
trying to figure out whether the startup
will be profitable or not that's binary
with two possible outcomes profitable or
not profitable and let's use initial
funding to be the independent variable
here we have a graph that shows funding
versus profit and it appears linear once
again our intuition tells us that the
more funding a startup has the more
profitable it will be but of course data
science doesn't depend on intuition it
depends on data but this graph does not
tell whether the startup will be
profitable yes or no it only states that
with an increase in funding the profit
also increases that's not binary if we
wanted to predict how much profit then
linear regression would be useful but
that's not what we are being asked hence
we need to make use of logistic
regression which has two outcomes in our
case profitable and not profitable so
let's draw a graph again the x-axis will
be our independent variable funding and
the y-axis will no longer be the
dependent variable profit but it will be
the probability of profit for example if
you look at a company with a funding of
say 40 then the probability that that
company will be profitable is around
point eight or eighty percent based on
the best fit line called a sigmoid curve
in the example we plotted several
companies some with 10 15 20 some with
50 60 or 70 or 65 and we indicated
whether they were zero not profitable or
a one profitable on the graph and this
is how we should think of logistic
regression in this example given the
amount of funding we calculate the
probability that a company will be
profitable or not profitable and if we
use the threshold line of fifty percent
then we have our classifier if the
probability is fifty percent or higher
the company is profitable if the
probability is lower than fifty percent
it's not profitable so what is logistic
regression this is a linear regression
graph so let's compare linear regression
to logistic regression and take a look
at the trendline that describes the
model it's a straight line which is why
we call it linear regression but using
linear regression we can't really divide
the output into two distinct categories
yes or no to divide our results into two
categories we would have to clip the
line between zero and one if you recall
probabilities can only be between zero
and one and if we're going to use
probability on the y-axis then we can't
have anything that is below zero or
above one thus we would have to clip the
line and once we clip the line we see
that the resulting curve cannot be
represented in a linear equation so for
logistic regression we will make use of
a sigmoid function and the sigmoid curve
is the line of best fit notice that it's
not linear but it does satisfy our
requirement of using a single line that
does not need to be clipped for linear
regression we would use an equation of a
straight line y equals b sub 0 plus b
sub 1 times x x being the independent
variable y being the dependent variable
but as we've said we cannot use a linear
equation for binary predictions so we
need to use the sigmoid function which
is represented by the equation p equals
1 divided by the quantity 1 plus e to
the minus y e being the base of the
natural logs then taking the log of both
sides and solving we get our sigmoid
function and graphing it we get our
logistic regression line of best fit the
applications for logistic regression are
endless here we might have a couple of
gardeners or farmers and one farmer says
i am planning to grow plants in my
backyard and i want to know whether my
trees will get infested with bugs which
i'm sure is a huge problem and these
days the fewer pesticides we use the
better off we are for health reasons the
young lady says i can use logistic
regression in a model to predict it for
you and the other farmer says well how
is logistic regression going to help but
we know that healthy versus not healthy
is a binary classification and we can
use a binary classifier like logistic
regression to solve this problem which
is what the young lady has in mind if we
have the data we can model the data and
generate a sigmoid function that best
fits our data and then use the
probability of a healthy tree versus a
not healthy tree or an infested tree
once again we see our sigmoid line of
best fit and some points that represent
healthy trees and not healthy trees once
again we plot our sigmoid curve scratch
that and once again once our sigmoid
curve is plotted and our threshold is
set almost always at 50 percent we can
use the sigmoid curve and calculate the
probabilities and hear the independent
variable of width which i assume is an
application of pesticides or no
pesticides to determine whether or not
the probability of healthy is greater
than 50 the threshold or less than 50
the threshold and now let's take a use
case of a college admission problem of
course we can't solve anything using
data science if we don't know what the
problem is so we need a problem
statement and here the problem statement
is simple we are given a data set and we
need to predict whether a candidate will
get admission in a desired college or
not based on their gpa and college rank
so the very first thing we need to do is
import the data set and if it's a small
enough data set and it can fit into our
computer memory then we are golden
otherwise we have some work to do the
data set that we were given is in csv
format comma separated values csv files
are easily imported into our environment
once we import the data we next need to
select and import the libraries that we
will need although r is a great
programming language with a lot of
built-in functions it is easily and
powerfully extended by the use of
libraries and packages then we need to
split the data set into a training set
and a test set it's important to note
that the data set that we've imported
that we were given has the gpas and
college ranks for several students but
it also has a column that indicates
whether those students were admitted or
not so what we're saying is that the
data set has the answers and if you
think about it it must how could we
possibly train a model have a model
learn if we didn't know the answers
already that's why it's called machine
learning so we train the model and then
we test the model once we split the data
into training and test sets we will
apply our regression on the two
independent variables gpa and rank
generate the model and then run the test
set through the model once that is
complete we will validate the model to
see how well it performed so now it's
demo time so here we have our studio my
favorite ide or integrated development
environment and i have a script already
composed to run our logistic regression
on the problem at hand which is our
college admissions problem so let's just
walk down the script before i run it and
talk about the various points in the
script so first define the problem well
the problem was defined and you really
can't do anything in data science
without a clear problem definition once
the problem is defined you can load your
libraries acquire your data set the
working directory in my case i'm on
windows explore the data munch the data
if necessary and then prepare the data
scale the data if necessary split the
data into train and test data sets then
train the model using the training data
and run the test data through the model
and then validate the model for accuracy
and precision etc so here we are going
to load our libraries i'm going to use a
package called ca tools and now that the
library is loaded i'm going to set my
working directory and if i come over
here to the files tab you'll see that
there is my working directory in that
working directory there's a file called
binary.csv and that's the csv the comma
separated value file that the college
gave me i'm going to ingest and then
look at that data and as you can see it
has four columns gre gpa rank and then
the answer column admit whether or not
someone was admitted which would be a
one or not admitted which would be a
zero and if we come over to the right we
can look and see some of the first few
values of each of those four columns now
let's split the data we're going to take
this my data frame and split it into two
a training set and a test set and the
ratio we're going to use is 80 20. so 80
of the data will go into the training
set and 20 will go into the test set now
that ratio could be 60 40 it could be 70
30. typically it really depends on the
size of your data how much data you have
but this is for our example and for our
purposes 80 20 is perfect next we'll do
a little data munging in general you
munge the data early on after ingestion
and you really have to be careful in
this case we don't have any missing
values we don't have any real outliers
our data was pretty clean when we got it
and ingested it but in general that's
not the case and a lot of work and a lot
of attention needs to be paid to the
munging process here we're just going to
take our data the admission column and
the rank column and convert them to
categorical variables right now they're
integers as you can see on the right
hand side and once i run these two lines
they will be converted to factors and
all the fun stuff we're going to use the
glm function the general linear model
function to train our logistic
regression model and the dependent
variable is admit and the independent
variables are gpa and rank and the
little tilde sign here says the
dependent variable will be a function of
gpa and rank the two independent
variables the data will be the training
set and the family will be binomial and
binomial indicates that it's a binary
classifier it's a logistic regression
problem there it is we ran our model and
there's a summary of our model you can
see that there is some statistical
significance in gpa and in rank by the
coefficients and output of the model so
next let's run the test data through the
model
and once we have done all that we can
now set up a confusion matrix and look
at our predictions versus the actual
values again this is important we had
the answers and now we took and we
predicted some answers so hopefully our
predicted answers match up with the
actual answers we'll run a confusion
matrix as you can see the predicted
values versus the actual values and it's
important here to note that if it was
predicted false and it was actually
false and we see 189 or if it was
predicted true and it was actually true
which is 27 we did well on those but
there are a few that were predicted
incorrectly some were predicted true but
were actually false some were predicted
false that were actually true and now
we'll confirm what our percentage
accuracy is 72
not bad but we could probably do better
how we'll leave that to another video
what is a decision tree and here we have
kind of a new looking front panel of a
car driving down the street and we have
uh left or right so you're coming to an
intersection you gotta decide which way
to go you're gonna go left or you're
gonna go right wait or go so do you go
right away we have a green light so
probably want to go right away after you
check for cross traffic make sure no one
is asleep at the wheel or talking on
their cell phone decision tree is a tree
shaped algorithm used to determine a
course of action each branch of the tree
represents a possible decision
occurrence or reaction so another
example is we have a shopkeeper very
non-descript shopkeeper
kind of a little spooky without the eyes
so we have a shopkeeper and he wants to
organize his stall so i must organize my
stall and just looking around trying to
figure out what the best way to stack
all his goods are and he has some
broccoli some oranges and some carrots
this is kind of a nice example because
we can see where some of the colors and
shapes overlap where others don't and so
you can create a tree out of this very
easily and say is it colored orange if
it's not well it goes into one stack
well that happens to be all their
broccoli and if it is colored orange
then it goes into another stack and
you're like well that's still kind of
chaotic you know people are looking at
carrots and oranges a very strange
combination to put in a box so the next
question might be is it round and if it
is then yes you put the oranges into one
box and no that means it's carrots we
put in the other box and you can see
that a lot of stuff we do in life easily
can fall into like a decision tree how
do you decide something you know does it
go left does it go right yes or no and
even with this we even have a number of
different end choices broccoli carrots
and oranges so what kind of problems
does this solve what problems can be
solved by using a decision tree
classification we're dealing with a
classification identifying to which set
an object belongs and from our example
we just looked at a carrot is orange
while broccoli is green i guess it's
nondescript day
without the faces i love it because a
lot of times you're looking at data you
really don't want to know what exactly
the data is but you're sorting it so you
know like this kind of represents data
that you really don't know exactly where
it's coming from just kind of a fun
thing regression regression is another
problem the biggest can be solved
regression problems have continuous or
numerical valued output variables
example predicting the profits of a
company so we have two different primary
problems we solve for we solve for
classification is it green or is it
orange and we solve for regression which
is a continual number so you know if
you're doing stocks this would be a
dollar value that ranges anywhere from
zero to thousands of dollars
how does a decision tree work terms you
must know first so before we dive into
the decision tree let's look at some of
the terminology for the decision tree we
have notes each internal node in a
decision tree is a test which splits the
objects into different categories and
continuing with our vegetable stand
example we have broccoli no it's not
orange and
oranges and carrots are and so on so you
can see right there where it splits
that's a note where the orange is split
in the carrot split into each of their
own groups and each one of the splits is
a node the very top node of the decision
tree is called the root node so the very
first one we started off where we split
it is a colored orange and you can see
that pointed out nice and neatly there
this is a root note at the top each
external node in a decision tree is
called the leaf node the leaf node is
the output and you can see down here we
have our broccoli and we have our
carrots and our oranges each one of
those is a leaf node so to quickly
rehash our terms we have anywhere there
is a split that's a node and if it's at
the very top of the tree that's the root
node and if you're at the very bottom of
the tree where you have a final answer
that is the leaf node so you have a root
node a leaf node and then everything
else is just a generic node so one of
the most important terms or concepts
that powers a decision tree is entropy
entropy is a measure of the messiness of
your data collection the messier or more
random your data higher will be the
entropy so we can see here we have
broccoli oranges and carrots are all
mixed together and it's very chaotic and
you could say this collection has high
entropy
and if we sort out the carrots out of
here in i guess just one of the broccoli
i don't know where the other broccoli
went you could say if you have just the
oranges and the broccoli this is a lower
entropy they say this collection has low
entropy but really it's higher and lower
one is higher or lower than the other
one and from entropy we get information
gain information is the decrease
obtained in entropy by splitting the
data set you based on some conditioning
so we have our information one which we
can actually there's actual computations
and so we have our e1 which is put in
there for our entropy value at the base
node or root node and we have two a2
which is a leaf node and so we can
actually calculate just calculations for
entropy and we actually look at those
two values the entropy and we take that
we have e1 is greater than e2 therefore
the information gain equals e1 minus e2
so here we have another example and
we're actually going to attach some
values to this one in just a moment so
we're going to move away from the fruit
and we're going to go to everybody's
favorite thing organizing a child's
closet and here we have a young lady
waving at us hi my cupboard is a mess i
must organize my stuff and we're going
to classify the objects based on their
attribute set using a decision tree we
can look at it we have a shape a size
and a label and a number and i'm going
to go ahead and look at the labels
because that's really what's key on this
one is we have a couple balls in here
some books cards and blocks and if you
look at that when you have something
that's a ball it's round so it's a very
different shape the book card and blocks
are all rectangular but the books are a
different size so the books have like a
size six i guess you think of them as
very large cards are size four so
they're not quite as big and the blocks
are little lego blocks it looks like
kind of fun to stack on there and then
we can actually quantify this and we can
actually say hey we got we have
different numbers we have two balls two
books one card four blocks and we split
at each level based on certain
conditions on the attributes so
splitting aims at reducing the entropy
and we have a formula our first actual
formula you'll see it happens in the
background when we're running these
different modules in r it looks a little
complicated but we can break that up and
simplify that for you so we see this
formula the negative sum of i of x
equals the probability of one
value of x times the log of 2
probability value of x the term
probability value of x it's probably
easiest to understand if we go ahead and
put the numbers in there so you can
actually see what we're looking at and
so we plug the numbers in there we look
at the probability of the value of x
well if we do the number of balls
there's two balls and the total number
of items is nine so we have a
probability of any one object being two
out of nine so it's pretty
straightforward math when you look at
the numbers you can actually see that
very easily and so we can calculate our
entropy of 2 over 9 times the squared
log of 2 over 9 plus
1 9 the log squared of 1 over 9 plus 4
over 9 times the log squared of four
over nine so our whole group is the sum
of all the entropies and so when we look
at that we have the entropy of the balls
which is the two over nine rectangles
two over nine i mean books two over nine
cards one over nine and the blocks four
over nine and we just plug those numbers
in there and we get an actual value of
1.8282 so what the heck does a module do
with that number well now we must find
the conditions for our split every spit
must give us the maximum achievable
information gain and so we have our
first entropy value 1.8282
and it turns out when you compare all
the different individual entropy values
for the balls for the books for the
cards for the blocks rectangles
you find out that the biggest split is
going to be in the shape and it's going
to be our first split will be on the
shape it will directly segregate the
balls out so they'll split up a huge
group from one from the other and so we
compute that we end up with e2 which is
all of our rectangles and then we have a
leaf node which is the balls and so with
our e2 we see that
1.3784 is much less than the 1.8282
and so our second split will be on the
size as that will directly segregate the
books and so we do that we can see that
if the size is greater than 5 all the
books go to one side while the cards and
the blocks go to the other and again we
have our e3 which equals 0.716 which is
considerably less than 1.3784 so our
entropy is dropping each time we do a
split and of course our third split we
look at and we'll see that we're left
with size again and we'd split it with
four and two in this case if it's
greater than three it's going to be a
block if it's less than three it's going
to be a card and at this point each of
our objects is looped into similarities
so they all look the same and we end up
with an entropy of zero and so you can
see as we go down the entropy continues
to get less and because it hits zero we
can say all our objects are now
classified with a hundred percent
accuracy if it was only that easy to
clean the kids closets and you can see
we have a nice drawing that shows you
where all the leaf nodes are on this in
which case we have the balls the books
the blocks and the cars are part of the
leaf note and the root node is our first
split and we have all the objects and
we're splitting them by rectangle by
shape so we're going to dive into the
use case and in this case we're going to
get a little morbid there i am behind my
desk that's definitely not me i don't
have that big of a chin but
i do usually have a cup of coffee and it
looks kind of like that it's sitting
next to me on my desk so the use case is
going to be survival prediction in r and
let's implement a classification of data
set based on information gain
this is going to use the id3 algorithm
don't let that scare you that's the most
common algorithm they use to calculate
the decision tree there's a couple
different ways they can calculate the
entropy but the formula is all the same
behind it so id3 is most common in r and
then we'll be using the rstudio for our
interface for our ide so rstudio is free
to download there's the free version of
course there's an enterprise version and
there's all kinds of different choices
in there but one of the wonderful things
about r is that it's been an open source
for a very long time and is very well
developed it's also very quick and easy
to use on a lot of things so this is
going to be in the r studio ide there's
some other interfaces but this is i
would suggest using the r studio it's
the most common one and if you remember
i said this is going to be a little
morbid because we're talking about how
many people survived and died on these
ships so in this case we have a nice
vacation cruise ship going on there or
i'm not sure what that is with the
tugboat so we have a ship and it had 20
lifeboats the lifeboats were distributed
based on the class gender and age of the
passengers we will develop a model that
recognizes the relationship between
these factors and predicts the survival
of a passenger accordingly so we want to
predict whether the person is going to
survive or die in a shipwreck and we'll
be using a data set which specifies if a
passenger on a ship survived its wreck
or not
so we're going to look at this data and
if you open it up into a spreadsheet and
don't forget you can always put a note
on the youtube video down below and we
will be monitoring that and you can
request the data set sent to you or more
correspondence you can also go to
www.simplylearn.com and request this
data set too it's just a simple csv file
we'll send out and you can see right
here we have survived so one indicates a
person survived the wreck
zero they didn't make it they were under
the water and the luxury class of the
cabin so if they were in you know what
would value is like one two three
depending on what luxury class they were
and then we have this is kind of
interesting how many siblings they had
so it's kind of an interesting added
statistic in there number of parents on
board and disembark location so where
the destination is
so here we've opened up rstudio and if
this is your first time in our studio
you'll notice that it opens up
standardly in three panes uh the upper
left is for text documents you're
bringing in and then the bottom left is
the actual commands as they're processed
and then on the right hand side you have
your environment set up on there now
i've zoomed in with my font a little
oversized in fact we can even take that
up one more size and see if we can get a
larger setup view here we go so i've set
the font for 18 probably a lot larger
than you need to work on a project and
the first thing i'm going to do is on
the right hand panel we're going to be
working with plots so i'm going to click
on the little plot tab up there and i'm
just going to collapse that over to the
side for right now and then i'm going to
open up the bottom one and you'll see on
the top i actually have
two different tabs team in the back was
really nice to set up the whole package
for what we're working on here and we'll
go through this line by line and then
you'll see as we execute the different
lines are going to appear down below so
i'll be flipping between these two left
panels and let me go backwards just for
a second here we're going to do
this part so let's take a look at the
installs
and if you look at the installs and when
i'm not going to actually run the
installs because i've already run them
on my computer so these are already
installed in my r packages and i don't
have to re-run them
we have a number of packages we're
bringing into our because that's how r
functions and the first number of
packages are all part of our decision
tree so our f selector our r part our
carrot with the dependencies equal true
and our dp lyr and our r part plot oh
that's a mouthful you'll need to import
all of these in your setup
and the first one which is your f
selector compute your chi squared your
information gain your entropy all of
those formulas are a part of the f
selectors when you bring it in that's
what that package is the r part is your
partitioning of your decision tree so
these are your primary two decision tree
modules that we're bringing in
the carrot is a part for actually
splitting apart the data because we
always want to do a test set a train set
so they built a package carrot to kind
of handle all those you'll see carrot
used a lot of other machine learning
packages when you're doing the r
the dplyr
is for mutating your data so you can sum
it you can classify it you can filter it
that's all part of the
dplyr and then our part has another
piece called plot and that's for helping
us plot the data as we sort out the tree
because the r part creates a tree but
you still want to be able to plot it and
then we come down here and we have some
additional tools we're going to work
with a spreadsheet this is a microsoft
access spreadsheet so we're going to use
the xlsx package to import it and you
might think it's a little outdated
because i know when i'm doing any new
projects i try to save my data into a
comma separate variable file or
something more standardized but a lot of
times you'll end up with these old
databases where they're exporting data
and their export comes in an excel
spreadsheet and guess what this is a
time saver instead of opening up the
spreadsheet re-saving it as a comma
separated variable file you can just
open it right up in r which is really
nice and then we have our data tree
which goes right along with uh
displaying the data so we have our
rpart.plot and we're going to put that
into the data trees have a nice visual
and finally you need to install the
package ca tools
and ca tools is another package used for
general manipulation of your data and
your vectors so it also has a split
function for training data i know we
have another package for that but both
those packages fit in there as far as
the working with the data so a lot of
times you'll see these loaded in there
together and you'll see in a moment
we'll import the elementary stat learn
package also which is very generic
working with data set up as far as
statistics and data processing now
because my java setup is a little
different because i use a developer
package well the latest update of the
developer package and the r are
struggling to see each other so i need
to go ahead and add this in chances are
you don't need to worry about this but
if you do get an r java error you'll
need to go ahead and add an align to set
your environment and i'm just going to
set the java home i went ahead and
looked up the last solid jre folder and
you'll see under program files java you
can look them all up to make sure it's
the jre and not the jdk the difference
between those is one is a standard
executable that's a jre folder it is a
folder not an actual file and the jdk
deals more with developer side on things
and i'm going to go ahead and run this
and if you're in r you can run these
lines individually by holding your
control key down and hitting the enter
button so i've now loaded my workspace
and set my environment here and we can
actually look and just make sure a
system dot
get environment is the opposite one
and i can just look real quick and say
hey what's my java
home set to
and if i run that
whoops i forgot to put brackets around
it
there we go
and if i do that you'll see that it's
set to the jdk18025
and again we're looking at the split
screen and let me just move this up here
a little bit and let me hit the enter
key a bunch of times it comes up on the
screen
when i run it and i'm running it line by
line the run text then appears down here
and this is what's actually being
executed so i could just as easily type
it in down here as putting it up here on
the top part
that's just a little bit of r rstudio
and working with our studio
so i've shown you the installs and again
i've already installed it on my computer
so it takes a minute or two to install
it
we need to go ahead and then bring those
libraries in to work with so
basically we're going through all the
different libraries we're using
elements.learn is a standard r library
so it should already be installed you
don't have to install that one and i can
just go right down them and you'll see
as i install them if they show up on the
bottom and every time you go to run a
new setup
you need to go ahead and install these
pull the libraries in you got to tell
your r studio these are the libraries
you're using
and you can see right down here that
as it executes them
it has all the different things one of
them had like couple different parts to
it so loaded the lattice and the gg plot
to
really nothing to worry too much unless
you see errors down here
so if you start getting error codes
then you might have to go troubleshoot
and find out why it's not installing
correctly or did it install correctly
but it's pretty straightforward we've
covered all the libraries
and again if you want a copy of this
code simply let a comment down below on
the youtube video or visit
www.simplylearn.com
and they'll be happy to send you a copy
of the base code
the next step is we want to go ahead and
load the excel file
after setting the working directory
so let's go ahead and set the working
directory scwd is a command for that in
r
and then this is wherever you have
downloaded your data to and your files
to a lot of times if you get the zipped
framework sent to you it will unzip all
into one location
and then you gotta look that location up
and put that in here a lot of times it
automatically sets up for you if you're
if you're working in the same directory
in this case you can see i pasted in
a very lengthy
path because i have this as part of my
documents my business docs and simply
learn and marketing videos and so on
and i'll go ahead and do the control
enter and run that so now my working
directory is set
and you can see down below it's executed
this on the
console down here
and if i open up that working directory
you can see i have a ship xls file
that's the data we're going to look at
and we looked at that on the slide
you could also open this up and i want
to go ahead and open it up with a
notepad
by default it'll open up as a
spreadsheet oh it is an excel file so
i'd have to open it up as an actual
spreadsheet wasn't thinking that one
through this is one of the problems with
saving stuff as a proprietary ship soft
file even something as widely used as
microsoft
excel spreadsheet
but when we open up the spreadsheet you
can see here the same data we looked at
before
that's what's coming up in this file
and so i take this file we can go ahead
and let's um
create a variable we'll call it add
and we're going to assign it
that's what the lesser than dash means
if you've never used r before and we're
just going to assign it a ship xlsx
and then i'll do my control enter and
you'll see it run down here ship
add is assign shipped.xls
our excel spreadsheet on there
and then let's have a another variable
we'll call it df for data frame and
we're going to assign this
read
xlsx
and that's from the library slx that we
just
it
and we want to read the file add
because we just created that variable
with the ship.xls
and i didn't catch this right away but
you'll see when we open it up in a
spreadsheet
it might be hard to see in your video
screen it has a the first sheet is
called ship one so this data is on the
page ship one in the excel spreadsheet
and we gotta make sure that we tell the
reader to look for that
and so we can simply do that in our
command line
sheet name
equals
and it was ship one on there
so we go ahead and hit the control enter
and run this line and it brings it down
below and executes it
it's now reading in that data from that
spreadsheet that's what's going on and
it takes just a moment to go ahead and
read it in
and then with any
data processing we need to select the
meaningful columns for the prediction so
this is important that we sort through
our data and set it correctly so that
whatever we're feeding it into can read
it correctly
we can do this with df
we're going to reassign it and we're
going to select
and from there we're going to select df
as our our main data frame going in
and then list the columns that we want
and if we look at the
data we have survived we have a class we
have a name
sex and age
and then there's siblings and parents
we really don't want to know the name
because we don't need the name to run
this on here
and then we gotta decide which one of
these we want to work with
and the guys in the back played with the
data a little bit and they came up with
the following columns
survived which we need definitely
because that's what we're actually
trying to figure out is whether we're
going to survive or not
what class they're which which class of
the boat they're writing in their first
class second class
six and eight we went ahead and dropped
the rest of them at least for this
example
and so i can go ahead and do my control
enter and you'll see it execute down
below
and now df
equals
these three columns or
four columns
plus our answer is one of those so i
always think of it as three columns plus
one but it is four columns
and then for the next step we want to
make sure the data is in the right
format so again i'm going to resign the
df
and we're going to mutate the data
and that means we're going to take each
one of these columns and we're going to
let it know what kind of data that is
so our first one is let me put the
database in or the data frame in there
df
and then we want to go ahead and do
survived equals a factor of survived so
this is a yes no it's letting us know
that this is a zero or a one on here
and then for the class and the
age those are as numeric
there's other ways to process class
since it is a very restricted number on
there but for this we're just going to
do it as a numeric value same thing with
age and you see we didn't do anything
with sex we're just going to leave that
as male or female and that's fine for
this because it'll pick up on that when
we run the decision tree
and we'll do our control enter so now
i've assigned the new df and you can see
it comes down below
as we run it on there so this is now
loaded and df now is a mutated data
frame that we started with and we've set
it up with our specific columns we want
to work with in this case survived class
sex and age and we've formatted three of
those columns to a new setup so one of
them is factor that's what we use for
survive so it knows it's a zero and one
and then we switched class and age to
make sure that it knows that those are
numeric values
now that we have our data formatted we
need to go ahead and split the data into
a training and testing data set and by
now if you've done any of our other
machine learning tutorials you know this
is standard you need to have your data
that we train it with and then you got
to make sure it works on data that it
hasn't trained on
so we'll go ahead and do the splitting
let's take a look and see what that
looks like
and when you're dealing with splitting
the data we're doing a little randomness
so we'll just go ahead and set the seed
to one two three you can set that to
whatever number you want that's just
setting the random variable seed
and we'll go ahead and hit enter on
there
and to do this we're going to create
sample and we're going to go equals
sample dot
split
so we're splitting up the data
this is actually creating a whole new
column trues and falses
it's all stored in sample and we want
our data frame and we use a dollar sign
to denote that we're going to be working
with
one of the different columns a nice
thing you can do an r
and it actually shows my survived so df
survived
and then our split
ratio
split ratio i want to add a period in
there which it doesn't have our split
ratio is going to be equal to
and we'll do 0.70 so we're going to take
70 percent of the data
of those that have survived and we're
going to just randomly select which one
of those we're going to use for training
and which one we're going to use for
testing it out later
we'll hit our enter and load that sample
in there
and then we'll go ahead and create our
train and our test data set so i'm going
to set train equal to
and this is where kind of gets
interesting because we're going to do
subset
and then we're going to do a subset of
our df
where sample
and then we're going to use equals since
this is a logic gate so wherever it sets
sample equal to true we're going to use
that line in df
and this is of course
r so it's all capitalized for true
so here's our trained data frame we're
creating so when i execute this and it
shows up down below
it goes up and says hey this sample
created a whole bunch of trues and false
and we're going to take those trues and
falses and wherever we've created a true
which is 70 of the data randomly
selected that's we're going to train the
data with and then we need our test set
and that's a subset just the same thing
we just did
and we need our data frame and this is
where the sample
equals false and again when i hit
control enter it goes down this line of
code and it runs it down here in our
terminal window
so now we've nicely split our data up we
have our training data set and our test
data set
and this is of course we get to the
point of what we're actually trying to
do which is create our decision tree
and we're going to do that by training
the decision tree as a classifier
this always gets me you spend all this
work sorting through the data
reformatting it in this case mutating it
and filtering it and creating a train
set and a test set
so we're going to go ahead and create
our tree and we're going to assign to it
the r part that's the module we imported
and for the our part we need to go ahead
and
do what's called the survived and this
is kind of a little complicated to look
at so let's just take a quick look at
this i'm going to go backward on it the
first part is we're importing the data
so data equals train
and then we want to know is who survived
so
the first part we put in here is the
column we're looking for is survived
and you'll see that we have out of the
squiggly mark in the period because
we're looking just for this prediction
we just want to know who survived on
these boats
for programming our decision tree and
i'll go ahead and hit ctrl enter
and we've now created the tree that tree
with all those values is now in there
and if you remember from before we've
taken from when we did the closet full
of clutter we've done the same thing
where we have our entropy and that one
line computes the entropy and the
increase in information and it brings
entropy down to zero so it's the same
thing but instead of applying it here as
we did visually to the closet it's now
applied it to the data on the ship it's
now looked at the survival of zero or
one based on female male what age they
are where the best split of the age is
and what class they were in you can see
we have first class if we go down there
i think there's
third yeah third second so i guess it's
class one two and three but you can see
that's how i split it up so it's use
these different variables to minimize
the entropy and maximize the information
gain and that's all done in that one
line of code
boy we worked on all that theory and uh
computer doesn't fear in one line of
code it's important to understand the
theory behind it so you know what's
happening because as they make changes
to these or if you had special settings
on it you have to know what they're
doing
but in this case you can see that we
once we get it formatted the computer
does all the heavy lifting for us
and it never ceases to amaze me just how
advanced machine learning has become
these days and how easy it is for people
to get into it and learn the basic
setups and be able to compute your
different machine learning models
once we've computed our decision tree
and we built it on there we want to go
ahead and start doing predictions with
it
and what are we going to predict well
you remember that we created our data
with the train and test so we have our
training data which we programmed the
tree for
now we want to see what it does with the
test data so let's see what that looks
like and we can wrap that into tree dot
survived dot predicted
we'll assign that to our prediction
this is nice because we have the command
predict from one of the modules the r
part module that we brought in
i can simply put in here that we're
going to use the tree
we have our test data
and type
this happens to be classification or
class
and this would also be if you were to
distribute this tree you could save the
tree and send it someplace else to be
used on new data this would be the
command line you would use to predict on
here predict you have your tree saved
you have whatever data you're putting
through and you let it know it's doing a
classification on the tree
and we'll go ahead and run that so now
that's loaded up
and now that we've gone through we've
trained our tree we've run a prediction
on our test data remember the tree had
never seen the test data till now so
we've already built the tree we're just
testing it out
and to do that we're going to use a
confusion matrix for evaluating the
model and let's see what that looks like
and that is simply confusion
matrix so once we have the confusion
matrix
which came in from our carrot we need to
compare the two different pieces of data
and the first one is going to be the
value we generated up here we have tree
dot survived dot predicted
so i'm just going to copy that and paste
it down here
and then the second one is the tree
we're comparing that to
survived
it's not the tree it's easy to get
confused sometimes when you're moving
these things around
we're going to compare it to test
the test group of data specifically
the survived column
and let's go ahead and run this and see
what that looks like
so let's go ahead and scroll up a little
bit here to where it first executed the
confusion matrix
and the most important part of this is
that we have our prediction
and our reference and so zero means they
didn't survive one means they survived
we had our prediction on here
versus the actual and that's what these
two columns mean and so when you read
this little chart we have 0 0
so both the prediction and the actual
reference said agreed on 218 values for
people who did not survive a little grim
there for data remember i'm talking this
is morbid data talking about death rates
of people on boats it says that they
both agreed on 93 so 93 of them where we
predicted the value that they would
survive and the reference came up the
same
likewise
the predicted were predicted one
and the reference said no these people
didn't survive well our prediction got
25 wrong
and where it says they didn't survive
and they actually did and got 57 wrong
and we can come on down with the
confusion matrix and we can look at the
accuracy comes up with the 0.7913
or 95 percent ci
so you're looking at pretty high
accuracy
information ratio p-value when you're in
statistics the p-value is one of the
things we look at remember that there
are certain values if it's over 0.95
it's considered highly valuable variable
0.5 means maybe anything less than that
means it's probably not connected
you have to look up the p-value a little
bit more on that
then they just have more information
down here
which you can go through and
which you can go through but the
important part is that we have a very
high accuracy
that's what we're looking at this is a
very accurate model and again always
remember the domain you're working with
certainly this is an example and this is
a good little piece of data you can play
with but if i was say betting money and
my accuracy came up as 79 or over 95 ci
i'd be like yes let's bet on that that's
a good bet but if i was betting on a
life or death situation i might kind of
rethink that a little bit if that is if
it's gonna affect my life that way you
can also look at this as if you're
trying to figure out where the boats go
in this particular example and where to
put the lifeboats that's actually pretty
good be able to say hey we can increase
the chances of people surviving this
accident by putting the lifeboats in the
appropriate places
and then this is always fun let's
visualize the decision tree
one of the cool things you can do inside
of r real easily
and if you remember one of the modules
we brought in has a rpart.plot
we're going to take that and we're going
to dump that into the prp for the tree
and let's go ahead and hit enter
and this is fine let me move this over
so you can get a nice view you can see
how it actually split it up and let me
just rerun that again now they expanded
the right you'll see right here where
one of the biggest splits was whether
the person was male or female
didn't know that was probably one of the
biggest breaks as far as lowering the
entropy and increasing the information
gain
and then once you know sex is male it
came down here and it said you're not
going to survive i guess the men were
throwing themselves overboard on the
boat i don't know maybe they're being
very gallant and letting the women and
children survive which is what i hope
that means
so once you know that it's not a male
and it's a female passenger if were in
class 3 or above you had a high chance
of surviving if you were less in class 3
class 1 or 2 then it was based on age
and so you can see where age was greater
than 19
so anybody over 19 had a high chance of
surviving and then if they were or less
than 19 i'm sorry if the age was a
little confusing on that one but if the
age was one sided 19 they probably
survived if not then i said hey if your
age is less than 60 you probably
survived and if not
people who are older probably didn't
make it out of the boat in time so
elderly have a much higher risk which
you would expect you'd expect that to be
the case that elderly would have a hard
time getting off into the lifeboats and
they would probably step aside for the
younger generation i know i would you
know so that might be more of a social
norm statistic as opposed to survival
rate let's go and put this back on over
here
and see what else we can do with this
data
you know if you're working with the
shareholders it's good to have a lot of
tools as far as how to display you know
they'll want to see this number here
where you say hey this is what the
confusion matrix looks like and we got a
0.79 accuracy that would be like the
number one thing you would talk to the
shareholders about other data scientists
care about the p-value and the
information rate and information like
that but this is really the core right
here this is how much data and this also
shows them how much data was looked at
so you have a you can actually just add
these numbers together and you can see
how many different people were in the
this particular data set i mean lines in
the data set but we go ahead and
visualize the 2d decision boundary so
let's take a look at that that's kind of
fun
it's a little bit more complicated so
i'm not going to go into it in too much
detail today now the guys in the back
put this code together for me which is
great so i'm just going to paste that in
because like i said we're not going to
go into it into too much detail i want
to show you that there's some other ways
to display the data that is not just
this nice little tree over here which
gives us a little bit more maybe view of
what's going on as you dig deeper into
data that becomes very important it
might not be something so simple where
you can look at in this case
one two three four nodes so they have
four major nodes that they split the
data in
so we're looking at this we're going to
go ahead and create a set test
equal to test comma c241
we're just assigning color column to go
with the data
okay that's what that is
and then we're going to take set and
have it equal to test
and we'll do x1
and we're going to set that equal to
minimum set of one minus one max set of
one plus one
by equals point zero one
they had to play with these numbers a
little bit to get this to look right so
we're creating a sequence on here from
our the set we created so our test set
and then x2 is also creating a sequence
based on different values
and then we're going to put that all
into a grid so let's go ahead and run
that through all the way down to the
grid
and they'll make a little more sense
when we add the column names to the grid
okay
so we'll set our test we'll create our
x1 sequence and our x2 sequence
remember a sequence is just like in this
case starting with 0.1 it's like 0.01
0.02 0.03 0.04
so we're going to create a grid with all
these values separated by 0.01 so that's
all we're doing right now
let's go ahead and set that up there's
our grid and then we want to go ahead
and create some column names and for our
grid set we're going to have our c class
and age
so we're just doing the class and the
age on here remember we did sex also
before so it's just class and age on
this chart that we're pulling out
and we're going to create a y grid and
the y grid is going to equal tree
survived predicted
okay so here's our y grid and our
predicted values on there
now we're actually going to do something
we're going to plot and we're going to
plot the y grid oops hold on let me see
what's in here
and let me go ahead and just run the
plot it's got to be the
there we go so let's take a look at this
and see if we can make a little sense of
this code and what's going on here
because there's a couple of things going
on what we've done is we've plotted a
decision tree classification data set
we've done our plot and we have our set
so our sets equal to our test data
and then we have our main we went ahead
and give it a name decision tree
and then we have our x lab
and our x limit and we've set those up
as class with our y lab equals age and
our x limit equals range x1 comma y
limit equals range of x2
and when you look over here you can see
that we have age on the left and class
on the bottom
and so based on age and class
and so once we put in this nice graph
here we want to go ahead and add our
contours and our points
so let's go ahead and run that and i'm
going to run all three of these so we
can see
all the colors come in on the graph and
this is actually going to take a little
bit
because remember you can make it go a
little faster by changing a couple of
the notes up here well we did 0.01 from
the min to max
by changing that to 0.1 or other values
you can actually will run a little
quicker and we're going to create a nice
little decision tree classification test
set just to see what that looks like and
how that data displays
now that was taking so long to run with
0.01 i went ahead and just did a 0.1 so
instead of filling the whole page with
different colors for a really pretty
view now i just have these different
colored lines coming across it gives us
another model that we can show for
whoever you're working with in this case
your shareholders of the company or the
individuals who you're posting to the
web for and you can see where we have
the green and the red and we've set
those up to identify from the decision
who's going to make it who's not based
on age and class
now my favorite one on this and i'm
going to go back and just highlight this
really quick was let me just rerun that
go back to prp tree where we display the
tree
and that's where we split it in part
because this information
gives us some keys that we can then use
in other models so it's good to know
that sometimes what you're taking comes
out and maybe you create a bucket for
people under 19 between 19 and 60 and
over 60 and different things like that
so you can actually put people in
buckets in a class age split just a
quick note on there again you know lots
of different things from which you can
display the data and you can see how we
use the decision tree to figure out
chances of somebody surviving based on
their class and their age what is a
random forest and welcome to raphael's
vineyard and i don't even know how to
pronounce that in alsace france the
largest wine production region in the
world so they have
centuries of wine production and data
they've collected on how to make the
best how to make their grapes and grow
them and how to properly get the right
grapes and ferment them like raphael
wine makers around the world are facing
a grave problem so let's meet the man
himself and try helping him out what is
a random forest we're going to come back
to the vineyard but we're going to look
at some other examples along the way too
open up the door and of course here
comes raphael
i'd probably look closer to raphael than
i do to the young lad with the beard hey
raphael so tell us how it's going not as
good as before not many people work in
this profession anymore so every stage
of production has gone slower if only we
could somehow speed up the process well
lucky for you i'm a machine learning
engineer how about we automate the
quality prediction process for wine let
me begin by telling you what machine
learning in random forest is machine
learning is the science of applying
algorithms that allow a computer to
predict the outcome without being
explicitly programmed random force is an
ensemble machine learning algorithm so
we're bringing in different pieces and
then putting those pieces together it
operates by building multiple decision
trees remember i told you we don't want
just a lone tree out there in the we
want a forest they work for both
classification if you remember from part
one we had our vendor with his broccoli
and oranges i think he also had carrots
and it also the output given by the
majority of its decision trees is the
forest final output so if you have a
number of decision trees you have five
decision trees and four of them say it's
broccoli then it's probably broccoli and
you can also use it as a regression
model the output given by the majority
of decision trees is a forced final
output just like you do in
classification you can also come up with
actual values and numbers as a
regression model could you explain how a
random force works in layman terms it's
always a good thing to explore the
information on something a little bit
easier to understand and see
sure let's consider the case of sam a
high school student this so reminds me
of my own high school student who's just
started his first year in college asking
all his friends so sam is confused on
which course to take up so he's trying
to figure out what his next class is
going to be at school should he take
music lessons dance lessons math science
maybe social studies so he decides to
ask a couple of his friends for
suggestions and sam approaches jane
first so he comes up to jane and says
hey which of these classes should i take
and jane asked sam a few questions based
on which she can suggest
theoretical do you like theory no he
doesn't like the theory part calculative
do you like calculative he goes yes i
like doing calculations and so jane
based on a couple question goes she has
a little decision tree there going she
goes mathematics sounds good so james
forms a decision tree based on sam's
response and gives her suggestion and of
course this is based on jane's views and
her history and the data that she's
collected over her years in high school
next sam approach is bella bella asked
him hey do you like the field of science
and sam goes yes and then bella goes do
you like
new in industry he like new things
coming up in industry and sam goes yes
and bella goes you know you should
similar to jade bella also forms a
decision tree based on sam's response
and gives her suggestion and says hey
how about artificial intelligence sounds
like oh artificial intelligence so sam
next asks terry for his suggestion and
sam goes do you like scoring things
and he goes yes
and he goes do you like theoretical and
he goes no and he comes up and says
mathematics so you have two people
saying mathematics and once a person
suggesting artificial intelligence
since two out of three friends suggested
math sam decides to take mathematics and
there's a lot of subtleties in this
example it's actually a really good
example some of the things we run into
in data science is when we collect data
and we collect from different sources we
might have data from one source that
measures one thing or one set of
instruments and we might have data from
another source that measures something
else we saw that with each of his
friends are measuring different things
and asking different questions that's a
little bit beyond the scope of this
particular tutorial so let's go back to
our wine cellar so you see more the
number of decision trees more accurate
will be the prediction random forests
have a number of applications in market
already if you've been watching any of
our other tutorials you'll see that
these are very common we have in banking
it can be used to predict fraudulent
customers is used to analyze symptoms of
patients detecting the disease
in e-commerce the recommendations are
predicted based on customers activity
stock market trends can be analyzed to
predict profit or loss
most recently i was watching a review on
weather here in the united states and
the data they pull in for that and one
of the top weather places actually uses
five different models random forest was
one of them i believe they use five
different models to predict the weather
and depending on what the models come up
with and what's going on some of the
models do better than others i thought
that was really interesting it's
important to note so when you see us
repeat the same things over and over and
you're looking at the different machine
learning tools you realize that we use
multiple tools to solve the same problem
and we can find the best one that fits
for that particular situation so let's
see how that fits back in our wine
production to help speed up the process
of wine production we will automate the
prediction of wine quality suppose our
random forest builds three decision
trees we have the first decision tree
which is going to divide everything by
chlorides less than 0.08 and it's either
yes or no and then it's going to look at
alcohol greater than six yes or no
quality equals high quality not so good
and if the chlorides were greater than
0.08 quality equals low so there's our
first tree and then our second tree is
going to split it on sulfates less than
0.6 and ph ph less than 3.5 and again we
have it coming down here that if the ph
is low and the sulfites are low the
quality equals high if the ph is a
little higher but the sulfides are low
it's not so good and if the sulfides are
greater than 0.6 we have a quality
equals low and then we'll do a third
decision tree we'll split it based on ph
and we can see below how that tree looks
like with our sugar less than 2.5 if not
it's a quad equals low it's real low
quality and if it is less than 2.5 then
the ph decide whether it's going to be a
quality 5 or not so good and if we track
one of our wines down the list we'll
look at it we'll say oh two out of three
decision trees indicate the quality of
our wine to be five the forest predicts
the same so this sounds promising so
let's go ahead and dive in and see what
that actually looks like so this is the
data set that holds all the attribute
values required to predict the wine's
quality and i'll pull this up in a
spreadsheet in just a moment but you can
see here we have fixed acidity volatile
acidity citric acid all the way to
quality and then quality is like a four
five six or seven i believe and this
will be done in r so let's go ahead and
get started in our coding we'll be using
rstudio before we dive into our studio i
always like to open up the data in the
spreadsheet and look at the actual data
that i have
and they've called it wine quality dash
red.xls
so it's a spreadsheet a microsoft
spreadsheet
and when we open it up we'll see that it
matches what we had before as far as the
slide was showing us with the we have 12
different columns the first 11 are our
features our fixed acidity volatile acid
citric acid things you always want to
look at when you're looking at your data
and we've done this before in the part
one but just a reminder we want to note
that we have decimal places here float
values
and a lot of these things especially the
first number of columns
our free sulfur dioxide looks to be
an integer but it varies a lot so we
have you know i see some values all the
way up to 51
7 4.
so we'd probably keep this as it's a
linear model kind of thing same thing
with the sulfur dioxides densities again
decimal places sulfides alcohol
quality i want you to note in the
quality
that we only have a few qualities here
this isn't
like a spread between zero and a hundred
it looks to be three four five six and
seven
and so when we start looking at the
process we can have the option of either
doing this as a
series of integers or float values going
from three to seven or we can convert
that to a categorical three four five
six and seven being the categories but
we'll look at that in the coding here in
just a minute and finally you'd wanna go
ahead and scroll down through the data
and just look for missing data or
anything weird
obviously you're working with big data
you wouldn't be able to do that if this
was spread across numerous computers and
you had millions of
rows we have what 1 687 rows here so
it's a nice size spreadsheet still
considered a small data set
let's go ahead and switch over and let's
take a look at this in the r
so here we are in our r studio
and if you remember it's uh comes up
automatically in three panels i have my
font on fairly large to help out
the upper left panel is a
file that's open you can have multiple
files and tabs open as you can see on
mine right now i'll probably close most
of those in just a minute
and this is where you can put in your
commands
then you can execute these commands by
either clicking on the run box or
control enter is the hotkeys for that
and all that does is then puts it down
in the console and executes that line of
command you could just paste these
directly in the console i've certainly
been known to do that if i'm loading up
some data and i just want to take a
quick look at it in r because i'm doing
the coding in something else or if i
just want to do a quick explore before i
dive in and figure out what needs to be
done that's one of the tricks you can do
and then on the right hand side we have
our environment history connections
we mainly are going to just be sitting
on plots and i'm just going to minimize
this for right now out of the way while
we dive in if you haven't yet you do
need to go ahead and install the package
random forest i'm not actually going to
do that because i've already run that we
don't need to rerun that but i am going
to go ahead and import it into our
project with the library and then random
forest and we'll do the control enter
you can always hit the run button up
there too
and then now the library has been
uploaded in there and you can see down
below it takes us and just copies it and
pastes it down below and runs it in our
console
and then just a quick troubleshooting
thing my java happens to be the
developer's job the latest release of
the developers java from last week is
clashing with my r and rerouting my
java files so chances are you don't need
to to look this up or find out where
your java is but there's a jre folder if
you do have an error that comes up next
in the next library you look that up
it's usually under program files java
and you'll see jdk depending on what
version you have on there and then find
that jre folder and i'm just going to
set the environment on there you have to
do that every time you run the script so
with r there is a place in r where you
can set it permanently but generally
it's set to whatever your system
variables are set too so you don't want
to mess with that so you just want to
put this in your code if you're having
problems you can always take it out then
we need to go ahead and bring in another
library
and we're going to be importing a the
spreadsheet so it's an x the
xlsx since it's a microsoft spreadsheet
and i'll go ahead and run that
let's go ahead and create a variable
path we're going to assign to variable
path the location of our folder so this
is a very lengthy one you'll have to
copy and paste it off your computer my
name is richard and you can see under
it's under c column users richer's
documents docs business simply learn
marketing
random forest and then the actual file
which is wine quality dash red.xls
so i put in the whole path in here you
could also set the computer path to
whatever folder you have it in and then
just use just the name of the file but i
went ahead and did this because it a lot
of times it's good to be aware where
your paths are going where you're
pulling your data from
and again i went the control enter so i
could you'll see that that pushed the
line down below and ran that line so our
path is now set
and then let's create a variable called
data
and we'll assign that to a read
and we're going to be reading let's see
where is it there it is and spreadsheet
and before i put in we need the path
but we also need one more thing on the
spreadsheet because it is an excel
spreadsheet we need to know
which
page we're on so let's go look that up
and in the spreadsheets this might be a
little hard to see because it's a very
tiny font down there but you'll see the
page tabs on the bottom this actually
has two different pages and we want page
one for this project so let's flip back
over and put that in our code
and the term they use is sheet index i
always have to look that stuff up
and it was sheet index of one we'll go
ahead and execute this
so at this point we've now loaded the
data into the variable data
and it's reading those and i think there
was like a couple thousand rows of data
in there so it takes it just a moment to
pull it in
once i have my data in there i always
like to do something like this
data
and in um i always forget in r it's head
and we can run that
and you'll see it prints out that what
we looked at in the spreadsheet so we
have our fixed
acidity
volatile acidity citric acid residual
sugar chlorides free sulfur all the
different things
we're actually looking for quality so
you want to keep that in mind that
quality is the final setting is it a
three four five six what is the quality
on there
and the first thing we need to do is
we're actually going to take the data
quality
and let me see quality there it is
in r the dollar sign means that you're
looking at one of the columns in here or
features as it is so we see data dollar
sign quality and r that means that's
what we're going to be editing
and what we want to do is we want to
change the quality just a little bit
and so we're going to set it equal to
now we're not assigning a variable we're
altering it so data
dollar sign quality equals
and we want to do as is one of the
functions in r and we're going to do as
a factor
and then data
quality because that's what we're
actually editing on there and this stop
just for a second to look at this
factor takes this
and looks at the data
as a
categorically so instead of it being on
a continual scale of you know
zero to a hundred or something like that
it actually looks at it as category of
five category of six category of a
category of cat category of dog
there are yes or no categories versus a
continual now there's a lot of different
things in here that we could do the same
thing with
but all of these really are
linear numbers 7.4 0.70
sulfur dioxide 34
so we really don't need to mess with any
of the other
variables in there but we do want to go
ahead and set this up and we'll come up
here and do our control enter and it'll
run it down below
and you'll see data quality equals as
factor data quality so we've now turned
that into a factor or into a categorical
data
and so let me just bring this down a
little bit the guys in the back did the
rest of this next piece of code
there are so many different ways and if
you have been
looking at any of our tutorials
this should look kind of familiar this
is one way to do it you'll see we have
our training data and our testing data
and so we've done here is we've got it
we have a data set size equals
and we're just going to do by the row
and so we want point eight or eighty
percent of the data is going to be our
training set to train our forest and if
you train it forest or any
machine learning model of course want to
test it so we're going to save 20 of the
data for testing
and when you look at this we have the
index
which we set at 80 percent comma and
then a negative index so that's the
remaining setup so it goes from that
index on this is our notation for
sorting out that data and then we create
the index
and we use the term sample
and this is just going to go in there
and set our different samples for in row
size data set size and everything so we
have an index now so the data is indexed
and we're just going to pull off the
first set of index and the end of the
index for our data
and we can run all of this in one shot
we'll go under code
and we'll run
selected lines and so now we have our
data in here we have our training set
and our testing set that's what we
wanted to get to
so once we've formatted all the data
then we get to the next real easy step
which is a single line to bring in our
random forest
so let's go ahead and we'll use a
variable rf standing for random forest
and we're going to assign
if you remember correctly we brought in
our library random
if you wonder why i go up here all the
time it's because i'll forget which
letters are capitalized in some of these
because i switch between packages so
much but it's random with a capital f
for forest random forest so the rf is
going to equal random forest
and of course the
we start by telling it which column
we're trying to predict
and of course you can always go down
here and double check we're running this
on the
quality there we go quality and we're
using just that column all the way to
the end
and then we've added our team in the
back has gone in and played with this a
little bit and we'll go a little bit
over what they did but i'm going to put
in the values that they have set for the
different options in the random forest
before i do that it would help if i tell
it what data to use data is going to
equal
our training set
and then we have the variables that they
put together and let's just talk a
little bit about what these different
variables mean
so
m try and entry these are some of the
variables you play with with the random
forest the m try not so much
when they first put it out i think m try
was very common four is a good value i
can't remember what the default is but
it's probably three four or five or
something like that depending i think it
depends on how many features you have
going in there so you could even just
leave this as a default without too much
troubles
the entry this is where it gets
important and i'm going to make this
one of the suggestions is to always make
this odd like a tiebreaker just in case
the default is like 500 or 501
and then finally we have importance
equals true i can't remember what it
defaults to but generally you want to
set the importance equals to true it
actually looks at the correlation
between the different features to make
sure that there is some kind of
correlation as it's doing its
calculations so our one line of code is
going to assign our random forest and go
ahead and train our random for us all in
one execution so this whole thing has
been centered around getting to rf set
to the random forest and let's go ahead
and execute this variable or this line
of code and you'll see it takes a little
bit down here to execute as it goes
through and sets it up
and you'll see it probably takes a
minute or so to execute the code
depending on the size of the data and
how good your machine is
and then with all of our data we can
start looking at the answers we'll just
do rf we'll execute that
and you'll see that the random forest
does a nice job you can see right here
it has our date equals training it
basically goes over everything we talked
about
and you come down here and it has a
confusion matrix which is nice we always
like our confusion matrix when we're
talking to our shareholders and
explaining
what the data comes out with and how it
trains
and we can go ahead and plot our rf
let's see what that looks like and
as the number of force grows you
remember we set it to 2001 forest you
can also see how the error comes in how
the different error on the different
variables
this kind of a nice graph that gives you
an idea might help you adjust whether
you really want to do 2000 different
forests
you might actually truncate this off at
around maybe 800 because you notice the
lines kind of continue on
again this is just still on the plot
and of course the next step is we need
to go ahead and predict remember we
split our data into two groups
so let's go ahead and get a result we'll
call it result and we'll assign this one
there we go
we'll set this to a data frame
there we go there's our data frame
and then oh let's call this we have our
test our test
quality because that's what we're we're
setting up on our test group with the
quality on there
then we wanted to have a predict
nice little keyword there to go and run
our random for us
and then we tell it that we're going to
predict using our rf our random forest
our testing group
1 to 11 is what we're using type equals
response
so let's go ahead and execute it that's
a mouthful on there
somewhere i left out a comma in there so
it gave me an error but you can see
right here we've set in there now we
have a result and just real quick we
could do the head of the result
result comma five and just take a look
at the first five lines
and you'll see we have the actual value
and what we predicted over here
and we could also just do all of the
results and just see what that looks
like oops
and print that out
and so it has all the different data
we're going through on there
and finally let's just go ahead and plot
there we go we'll put plot up here plot
and let's plot the result
and just see what that looks like
maybe not the best one to show to the
shareholders but it does give you an
idea on the left on the y-axis you'll
see that it predicted eight
and this tells you that it a lot of the
eight and the eight scale was pretty
probably gave us
about fifty percent came up there at
eight
really maybe fifty percent it didn't
guess right but it did come up there and
say that it was at least a four five or
six even where it was considered an
eight and so on you can see these
different blocks coming in so that if
you line up the three with the three
four with the four and you kind of cross
index them a heat map would probably do
better but for this example we'll just
do a quick plot of the data
as far as how it works and you can again
see the results that we predicted over
here and you can look those over
of course back in the wine cellar we're
talking to our vineyard owner and if you
remember from before we looked at this
chart right here the error rate is 29.05
percent therefore our accuracy is
70.95 percent
if you're doing a vineyard is probably
pretty good accuracy and always check
your domain when you're sharing this
stuff because if you're doing something
that's life or death
maybe 70 accuracy might not be so good
but if you're looking at where you're
going to distribute the bottles to for
the wine and who's going to drink it you
know 70 percent accuracy is pretty good
for that that's probably a lot better
than having no accuracy whatsoever and
not even knowing what wine is going out
to who so we have automated the process
of predicting the quality of wine i
myself prefer to predict it by sampling
it that's great thank you i'd like to
visit this guy and sample his wine and
find out just how good his different
vineyards are what is clustering so
we'll have a group of people here
hanging out at a table or local coffee
shop i'm guessing coffee shops since
they all have the same mugs and one of
them is uh trying to figure out what
they're going to do i have 20 places to
cover in four days i guess he's going
traveling that sounds fun one of those
breeze through costa rica or visiting
the us or going to to europe to go visit
all the highlights so he's got 20 places
he wants to go and he wants to hit him
in four days very ambitious
and how will i manage to cover all of
them that's the question that he's
coming up how am i going to get to all
these different places in the short time
i have maybe he's a sales team so he has
20 places he's got to do demos for you
can make use of clustering by grouping
the places into four clusters
each of these clusters will have places
which are close by so we're going to
cluster them together by what is closest
to the other one then each day you can
visit one cluster and cover all the
places in the cluster great that's a
great idea you know if you're going to
hit four different places maybe you're
going to cluster whatever streets are
closest together so you don't have to
travel spend all your time traveling the
method of dividing the objects into
clusters which are similar between them
and are dissimilar to the objects
belonging to another cluster so this is
a formal definition of clustering and we
have here what we call hierarchical
clustering and partial clustering and
we're going to go more into detail on
hierarchical clustering and you'll see
the difference between the two where
partial clustering doesn't have the
descending graph it just has groups of
things
and under hierarchical clustering we're
going to go over agglomerative and
divisive and you can think of
agglomerative of bringing things
together and divisive as dividing them
apart and then partial clustering the
two most common ones are k-means that's
probably the most common use for partial
clustering and there's also fuzzy c
means and there's other ways of
clustering in other algorithms out there
but these are the two big ones k-means
really being the most common one used
but we're not going to dig too deep into
partial clustering because we're
studying hierarchical clustering today
so what is clustering well the
applications of clustering are pretty
numerous we have things like customer
segmentation what people kind of belong
together how do we group them together
we have a social network analysis
so social networks we might look at
sentiments what group of people like
something what group of people don't
like something and then we can use that
sentiments to suggest new cells for them
you know this whole group is into
harley-davidson motorcycles so we cater
to them to sell them harley-davidson
motorcycle parts and we find out that
people in that group also like leather
jackets they also like motorcycle boots
and they like bandanas my brother's into
harley-davidson so
that's why i picked that kind of funny
example but you can kind of see we look
for similarities between these people
and then we group them together
accordingly and that's a good
sentimental clustering is very common in
so many things today we want to know the
sentiments on stocks who is interested
in stocks who's not sentimental analysis
we talked about customer segmentation in
cells well we want to know what kind of
sentimental view people have on
different restaurants if we're going to
open up a new restaurant or a new
putting stores in and of course city
planning a lot of this i just kind of
aimed at the city planning side sitting
planning is big with clustering we want
to cluster things together so that they
work we don't want to put a industrial
zone in the middle of somebody's
neighborhood where they're not going to
enjoy it or have a commercial zone right
in the middle of the industrial zone
where no one's going to want to go next
to a factory to go eat a high-end meal
or dinner so it's very big in city
planning but it's also very big in just
pre-processing data into other models so
when we're exploring data being able to
cluster things together reveal things in
the data we never thought about and then
once we have it clustered we can put
that into another model to help us
figure out what it is we want for our
solution so let's go a little deeper
into hierarchical clustering let's
consider we have a set of cars and we
have a group similar we want to group
similar ones together so below we have
you'll see four different cars down
there and we get two clusters of card
types sedan and suv so if you're just
looking at it you can probably think oh
yeah we'll put the sedans together and
the suvs together and then at last we
can group everything into one cluster so
we just have just cars so you can see as
we have this we make a nice little tree
this is very common when you see anybody
talks about hierarchical clustering this
is usually what you see and what comes
out of it we terminate when we are left
with only one cluster so we have as you
can see we bring them all together we
have one cluster we can't bring it
together anymore because they're all
together hierarchical clustering is
separating data into different groups
based on some measure of similarity so
we have to find a way to measure what
makes them alike and what makes them
different agglomerative clustering is
known as a bottom up approach remember i
said think of that as bringing things
together you see i think the latin term
aglow is together because you have your
conglomerate rocks where all the
different pieces of rocks are in there
so we want to bring everything together
that's a bottom up
and then divisive is we're going to go
from the top down so we take one huge
cluster and we start dividing it up into
two clusters into three four five and so
on digging even deeper into how
hierarchical clustering works
let's consider we have a few points on a
plane so this plane is 2d so we have an
xy coordinates kind of makes it easy
we're going to start with measure the
distance so we want to figure a way to
compute the distance between each point
each data point is a cluster of its own
remember if we're going from the bottom
up agglomerative then we have each point
being its own cluster we try to find the
least distance between two data points
to form a cluster and then once we find
those with the least distance between
them we start grouping them together so
we start forming clusters of multiple
points this is represented in a
tree-like structure called dendogram so
this is another key word dendogram and
you can see it is it's just a branch
we've looked at before and we do the
second group the same so it gets its own
dendogram and the third gets its own
dendogram and then we might group two
groups together so now those two groups
are all under one dendogram because
they're closer together than the p1 and
p2 and then we terminate when we are
left with one cluster so we finally
bring it all together you can see on the
right how we've come up all the way up
to the top whoops and we have the gray
hierarchical box coming in there and
connecting them so we have just one
cluster and that's a good place to
terminate because there is no way we can
bring them together any further so how
do we measure the distance between the
data points i mean this is really where
it starts getting interesting up until
now you can kind of eyeball and say hey
these look together but when you have
thousands of data points how are we
going to measure those distances and
there is a lot of ways to get the
distance measure so let's go and take a
look at that distance measures will
determine the similarity between two
elements and it will influence the shape
of the clusters and we have euclidean
distance measure we have squared
euclidean distance measure which is
almost the same thing but with less
computations and we have the manhattan
distance measure which will give you
slightly different results and we have
the cosine distance measure which again
is very similar to the euclidean playing
with triangles and sometimes it can
compute faster depending on what kind of
data you're looking at so let's start
with the clition distance measure the
most common is we want to know the
distance between the two points so if we
have point p and point q the euclidean
distance is the ordinary straight line
it is the distance between the two
points in euclidean space and you should
recognize d equals in this case we're
going to sum all the points so if there
was more than one point we could figure
out the distance to the not more than
one points this is the sum of more than
two dimensions
so we can have the distance between each
of the different dimensions squared and
that will give us and then take the
square root of that and that gives us
the actual distance between them and
they should look familiar from euclidean
geometry maybe you haven't played too
much with multiple dimensions so the
summation symbol might not look familiar
to you but it's pretty straightforward
is you add the distance between each of
the two different points squared so if
your y difference was 2 minus 1 squared
would be 2 and then you take the
difference between the x again squared
and if there was a z coordinates it
would be you know z1 minus z2 squared
and then take the square root of that
and sum it all or sum it all together
and then take the square root of it so
to make it compute faster since the
difference in distances whether one is
farther apart or closer together than
the other we can do what's called the
squared euclidean distance measurement
this is identical to the euclidean
measurement but we don't take the square
root at the end there's no reason to it
certainly gives us the exact distance
but as far as doing calculations as to
which one's bigger or smaller than the
other one it won't make a difference so
we'll just go with the so we just get
rid of that that final square root
computes faster and it gives us the
pretty much the euclidean squared
distance on there now the manhattan
distance measurement is a simple sum of
horizontal and vertical components or
the distance between two points measured
along axes at right angles now this is
different because you're not looking at
the direct line between them and in
certain cases the individual distances
measured will give you a better result
now generally that's not true most times
you go with the euclidean squared method
because that's very fast and easy to see
but the manhattan distance is you
measure just the y value and you take
the absolute value of it and you measure
just the x difference you take the
absolute value of it and just the z and
if you had more you know different
dimensions in there a b c d e f however
many dimensions you would just take the
absolute value of the difference of
those dimensions
and then we have the cosine distance
similarity measures the angle between
the two vectors and as you can see as
the two vectors get further and further
apart the cosine distance gets larger so
it's another way to measure the distance
very similar to the euclidean so you're
still looking at the same kind of
measurement so should have a similar
result as the first two but keep in mind
the manhattan will have a very different
result and you can end up with a bias
with the manhattan if your data is very
skewed if one set of values is very
large and another set of values is very
small but that's a little bit beyond the
scope of this it's just important to
know that about the manhattan distance
so let's dig into the agglomerative
clustering an agglometric clustering
begins with each element as a separate
cluster and then we merge them into a
larger cluster how do we represent a
cluster of more than one point so we're
going to kind of mix the distance
together with the actual agglomerative
and see what that looks like and we're
actually going to have three key
questions that are going to be answered
here so how do we represent a cluster of
more than one point so we want to look
at the math what it looks like
mathematically and geometrically how do
we determine the nearness of clusters
when to stop combining clusters always
important to have your computer script
or your whatever you're working on have
a termination point so it's not going on
eternally
we've all done that if you do any kind
of computer programming or writing of
script let's assume that we have six
data points in a euclidean space so
again we're dealing with x y and z in
this case just x and y
so how do we represent a cluster more
than one point let's take a look at that
and first we're going to make use of
centroids very common terminology in a
lot of machine learning languages when
we're grouping things together so we're
going to make use of centroids which is
the average of its points
and you can see here we're going to take
the 1 2 and the 2 1 and we're going to
group them together because they're
close and if we were looking at all the
points we look for those that are
closest and start with those and we're
going to take those two we're going to
compute a point in the middle and we'll
give that point 1 5 1.5 1.5 and that's
going to be the centroid of those two
points and next we start measuring like
another group of points we got 4 1 5
zero when they're pretty close together
so we'll go ahead and set up a centroid
of those two points in this case it
would be the 4.5 and
0.5 would be the measurements on those
two points and once we have the centroid
of the two groups we find out that the
next closest point to a centroid is over
on the left and so we're going to take
this and say oh 0 0 is closest to the
1.5 1.5 centroid so let's go ahead and
group that together and we compute a new
centroid based on those three points so
now we have a centroid of one point one
or one comma one and then we also do
this again with the last point the five
three and it computes into the first
group and you can see our dendrogram on
the right is growing so we have each of
these points are become connected and we
start grouping them together and finally
we get a centroid of that group two and
then finally the last thing we want to
do is combine the two groups by their
centroids and you can see here we end up
with one large group and it'll have its
own centroid although usually they don't
compute the last centroid we just put
them all together
so when do we stop combining clusters
well hopefully it's pretty obvious to
you in this case when they all got to be
one but there are actually many
approaches to it so first pick a number
of clusters k up front and this is done
in the fact that we don't want to look
at 200 in clusters we only want to look
at the top five clusters or something
like that so we decide the number of
clusters required in the beginning and
we terminate when we reach the value k
so if you look back on our clustering
let me just go back a couple screens
you'll see how we clustered these all
together and we might want just the two
clusters and so we look at just the top
two or maybe we only want three clusters
and so we would compute which one of
these has a wider spread to it or
something like that there's other
computations to know how to connect them
and we'll look at that in just a minute
but to note that when we pick the k
value we want to limit the information
that's coming in so that can be very
important especially if you're fitting
it into another algorithm that requires
three values or you set it to four
values and you need to know that value
coming in so we might take the
clustering and say okay only three
clusters that's all we want for k so the
possible challenges this only makes
sense when we know the data well so when
you're clustering with k clusters you
might already know that domain and know
that that makes sense but if you're
exploring brand new data you might have
no idea how many clusters you really
need to explore that data with let's
consider the value of k to be two so in
this case in our previous example we
stop and we are left with two clusters
and you can see here that this is where
they came together the best while still
keeping separate the data the second
approach is stop when the next merge
would create a cluster with low cohesion
so we keep clustering until the next
merge of clusters creates a bad cluster
low cohesion set up on there that means
the point is so close to being between
two clusters it doesn't make sense to
bring them together but how is cohesion
defined oh let's dig a little deeper
into cohesion the diameter of a cluster
so we're looking at the actual diameter
of our cluster and the diameter is the
maximum distance between any pair of
points in the cluster we terminate when
the diameter of a new cluster exceeds
the threshold so as that diameter gets
bigger and bigger we don't want the two
circles or clusters to overlap and we
have radius of a cluster radius is the
maximum distance of a point from
centroid we terminate when the radius of
a new cluster exceeds the threshold
again we're not we don't want things to
overlap so when it crosses that
threshold and is overlapping with other
data we stop
so let's look at divisive clustering
remember we went from the bottom up now
we want to go from the top down device
of clustering approach begins with a
whole set and proceeds to divide it into
smaller clusters so we start with a
single cluster composed of all the data
points we split it into different
clusters this can be done using
monothetic divisive methods
what is monothetic divisive method and
we'll go backwards and let's consider
the example we took in the agglomerative
clustering to understand this
so we consider a space with six points
in it just like we did before same
points we had before and we name each
point in the cluster so we have in this
case we just gave it a letter value a b
c d e f
since we follow top down approach and
divisive clustering obtain all possible
splits into two columns so we want to
know where you could split it here and
we could do like a a b split and a c d e
f split we could do b c e a d f and you
can see this starts generating a huge
amount of data a b c d e f
and so for each split we can compute
cluster sum of squares
and we can see here the actually have
the formula out for us bj12 equals n1 of
absolute value of x minus absolute value
of x squared so again we're computing
all the different distances in there
squared back to your kind of euclidean
distances on that and so we can actually
compute b and j between clusters one and
two and we have the mean of the cluster
and the grand mean depending on the
number of members in the cluster and we
select the cluster with the largest sum
of squares
let's assume that the sum of squared
distance is largest for the third split
we had up above and that's where we
split the abc out and if we split the
abc out we're left with the def on the
other side
we again find the sum of square
distances and split it into clusters so
we go from abc we might find that the a
splits into bc
and d into ef and again you start to see
that hierarchical dendrogram coming down
as we start splitting everything apart
and finally we might have a splits in b
and c and then each one gets their own
def
and it continues to divide until we get
little nodes at the end and every data
has its own point or until we get to k
if we have set a k value so we've kind
of learned a little bit about the
background and some of the math and
hierarchical clustering let's go ahead
and dive into a demo and our demo today
is going to be
for the problem statement we're going to
look at u.s oil so a u.s oil
organization needs to know it cells in
various states in u.s and cluster the
states based on the sales
so what are the steps involved into
setting this problem up so the steps
we're going to look at and this is
really useful for just about any
processing of data although i believe
we're going to be doing this in r today
we're going to import the data set so
we'll explore our data a little bit
there create a scatter plot it's always
good to have a visual if you can once
you have a visual you can know if you're
really far off in the model you choose
to cluster the data in or how many
splits you need and then we're going to
normalize the data so we're going to fix
the data up so it processes correctly
we'll talk more detail about
normalization when we get there and then
calculate the euclidean distance and
finally we'll create our dendogram so it
looks nice and pretty and we have
something we can show to our
shareholders so that they have something
to go on and know why they gave us all
that money and salary for the year so we
go ahead and open up r and we're
actually using our studio which is the
really it has some nice features in it
it automatically sets up the three
windows
where we have our script file on the
upper left
and then we can execute that script and
it'll come down and put it into the
console bottom left and execute it and
then we have our plots off to the right
and i've got it zoomed in hopefully not
too large a font but large enough that
you can see it
and let's just go ahead and take a look
at some of the script going in here
it's clustering analysis and we're going
to work we'll call it my data
and we're going to assign it in r this
is a symbol for assigning and we're
going to go read csv
read csv file
and put that in brackets
and let's before we go any further let's
just look at the data outside of r it's
always nice to do if you can
and the file is going to be called
utilities.csv
this would also be the time to get the
full path so you have the right path to
your file
and remember that you can always post in
the comments down below
and when you post down there just let us
know you want to connect up with simply
learn so that they can get you this file
so you can get the same file we're
working on you can repeat it and see how
this works this is utilities.csv it's a
comma separated variable file so it's
pretty straightforward and you can see
here they have the city fixed charge and
a number of different features to the
data and so we have our ror cost load
demand cells
nuclear fuel cost on here and then going
down the other side we have u.s cities
arizona boston they have central u.s so
i guess they're grouping a number of
areas together the commonwealth area you
can see down here nevada new england
northern u.s oklahoma the pacific region
and so on so we have a nice little chart
of different data they brought in
and so i'm going to take that complete
path that ends in the utilities.csv
and we're going to import that file let
me just enlarge this all the way
upside an extra set of brackets here
somehow maybe i missed a set of brackets
this can happen if you're not careful
you can get brackets on one side and not
the other or in this case i got double
brackets on each side
there we go
and then the magic hot keys in this case
are your control enter
which will let me go ahead and run the
script
and so i've now loaded the data and as
you can see i went ahead and shrunk the
plot since we're going to be looking at
the window down below
and we can simply convert the data to a
string
now all of us do this automatically the
first time we say hey just put it all
out as a string and then we get this
huge mess of stuff
that doesn't make a whole lot of sense
so
when you can see here they have you can
probably kind of pull it together as
looking at it but let's go ahead and
just do the head
i will do the head of my data
there we go and ctrl enter on that and
the head shows the first five rows
you'll see this in a lot of different
scripts in r it's you type in head and
then in brackets you put your data and
it comes through unless the first five
rows as you can see below
and it shows arizona boston central and
it has the same columns we just looked
at so we have the fixed charge the ror
the cost the load the
d demand i'm not an expert in oil so i'm
not even sure what d demand is
cells i'm guessing nuclear how much of
it's supplied by nuclear
and the actual fuel cost
and then the different states that it's
in are different areas
and one of the wonders of r is all these
cool easy to use tools that are so quick
so we'll do pairs
and pairs creates a nice graph let me go
ahead and run this
whoops the reason it gave me an error is
because i forgot to resize it so let me
bring my plot way out so we can see it
and let's run that again
and
you'll see here that we have a nice
graph of the different data and how it
plots together how the different points
kind of come together
this is neat because if you look at this
i would look at this and say hey this is
a great
candidate for
some kind of clustering and the reason
is is when i look at any two pairs let's
go down to say cells and fuel costs
towards the bottom right
and when you look at them where they
cross over you sort of see things how
they group together but it's a little
confusing you can't really pinpoint how
they group together you could probably
look at these two and say yeah there's
pretty good commonalities there and if
you look at any of the other pairs
you'll start seeing some patterns there
also and so we really want to know what
are the patterns on all of them put
together not just any two of them but
the whole setup
let me go ahead and shrink my um this
down for just a second just a notch here
and let's create a
scatter plot
oops and this is simply just use the
term plot in brackets
and then which values do we want to plot
and if we remember when we looked at the
data earlier let me just go back this
way
in this case let's go ahead and compare
two just two values to see how they look
and we'll do field cost in cells
and it's in my data
so we'll let it know which two columns
we're looking at next to each other
and it will open up our plot thing and
then go ahead and execute that
and we can see on those
close up of what we were just looking at
in the pairs
and if i was eyeballing this i would say
oh look there's a kind of a cluster up
here of five items and
this one it's hard to tell which cluster
to be with but maybe it's six you go in
the top one and you have a middle
cluster and a bottom cluster maybe two
different clusters so you can sort of
group them together fuel cost and the
cells and see how they connect with each
other
and again that's only two different
values we're looking at so in the long
run we want to look at all of them
and then the people in the back
they sent me the script so we can go
ahead and add labels so with my data
text fuel cost cells the labels equal
city
position four
these are numbers you can kind of play
with till they look nice
and oops again i forgot to resize my
plot it doesn't like having it too small
and we'll run that
i must type something in here
oh i did it lowercase d and they did a
capital d there we go
so now we can go in here and do this
with my data and you can see a little
hard to see on my screen with all the
different things in there it plots the
actual cities so we can now see where
all the cities are in connection with in
this case fuel cost and cells
so you have a nice label to go with the
graph
and then we can also go ahead and plot
in this case let's do
oh the r o r oops
and we'll do that
also with the
cells
and do my data
remember to leave it lowercase this time
so we plot those two
we'll come over here and it's gonna i'm
surprised it didn't give me an error
and then we'll also add in the
with statement so we put some nice
labels in there
and it's going to be the same as before
except instead of doing the field cost
cells we want the r cells and we'll
execute that
oops and of course it gives me an error
because i shrunk it down
so let's redo those two again
there we go and we can see now we have
the ror with cells and we'd probably get
a slightly different clustering here if
i was looking at these cities they're
probably different than we had before
but you could probably look at this and
say these kind of go together and those
kind of go together but again we're
going to be looking at all of them
instead of just one or two
and so at this point we want to dive
into the next step we're going to start
looking at a little bit of coding or
scripting here
this is very important because we're
going to be looking at normalization
we put that in there normalization and
if you've done any of the other machine
learning
skills and setup this should start to
look very normal in your pre-processing
of data whether you're in r or python
or any of these scripts we really want
to make sure you normalize your data so
it's not biased
remember we're dealing with distances
and if i have let's say the rors even
look at this graph here on the right
you can see where my ror varies between
eight and fourteen
that's a very small variable and our
cells varies between four thousand and
sixteen thousand
so you can imagine the distance between
four thousand and eight thousand which
is the distance of four thousand versus
eight to ten versus two
the cells is going to dominate so if we
do any kind of special work on this it's
going to look at cells and it's going to
cluster them just by the cells alone and
then ror might have a little tiny effect
of 2 versus 4 000
we want to level the playing field
turns out there's actually a number of
ways in script to normalize
so i'm just going to put in the code
that they put together in the back for
me and let's talk about it a little bit
so we have z we're going to assign it to
my data
and let's go ahead and
we're going to do a little reshaping
across all rows
or i mean across all columns so each of
the rows are going to have a little
reshaping there
and then we're going to get m which
stands for means and we're going to
apply it to
my data so again we want to go ahead and
create a
the most
common variable in there
and then s is going to be sd stands for
standard deviation
so instead of just doing a lot of times
what they do with normalization of data
is we just reshape the data everything
between zero and one
so that if the lower end is eight that
now becomes zero and the upper end is 14
that now becomes 1.
that doesn't help if it is not a linear
set of data
so with this we're going to look for the
means and the standard deviation for
reshaping the data
and that way the most common values now
become the kind of like the center point
and then the standard deviation is how
big the spread so we want the standard
deviation
to be equal amongst all of them and then
finally we go ahead and take z and with
the z we're going to reassign it and
we're going to scale the original my
data which we re-shaped
based on m and based on the standard
deviation
and the 2 in here that just means we're
looking at everything in
kind of a xy kind of plot
and we can quickly run these control
enter control enter control enter
control enter so now we have z which is
a scaled version of my data
and now we can go ahead and calculate
the euclidean distance
oops calcu
there we go
and in
r this is so easy once you've gotten to
here we've done all that pre data
processing
we'll call it distance
and we'll assign this to
dist so d-i-s-t
is
the computation for getting the
euclidean distance
and we can just put z in there because
we've already reformatted and scaled z
to fit what we want
let me go ahead and just hit enter on
that
and i'm going to widen my left hand side
again
i'm always curious what does this data
look like so let's just type in distance
which will print the variable down below
oops
you have to hit ctrl enter
and this prints out a huge amount of
information
as you can see just kind of streams down
there
and let's go ahead and large this
and i don't know about you but when i
look at something like this it doesn't
mean a whole lot to me other than i see
two three four five six
and then you kind of have the top part
17 18
so imagine this is like a huge chart
is what we're looking at
and we can go ahead and use print oh
distance
digits
[Applause]
equal three and let's run that
oops i keep forgetting that it
has to go through the graph on the right
and we see a different slightly
different output in here let me just
open this up so we can see we're looking
at
and by cutting down the distance you can
start to see the patterns here if it's
looking at the different distances
so if i go to the top we have the
distance between 1 and 2
1 and 3 one and four one and five one
and six and then two and three
and so on obviously the distance between
itself is zero and it doesn't repeat the
data so we don't care to see two versus
one again because we already know the
distance between one and two
and so we have a nice view all the
distances in the chart and that's what
we're looking at right here and it's a
little easier to read that's why we did
the print statement up here to do digits
equals three make it a little bit
smaller we could even just do digits
oh let's just do two see what that looks
like we might lose some data on this one
if it's uh if something's way off
but we have a nice setup and we can see
the different distances and that's what
we were computed here between each of
the points
and then the whole reason we're doing
this is to get ourselves a nice
dendogram going a nice clustering
dendogram we'll do a couple of these
looking at different things
we'll take a variable hc.l and we're
going to assign it
h cluster
and then distance
that easy we've already computed the
distances
so the age clustering does all the work
for us
and then we hit enter on there so now we
have our hcl which is assigned the h
clustering computation based on
distances and apart and then i'm going
to expand my graph because we would like
to go ahead and see what this looks like
and we can simply plot that
and hit the control enter so it runs
and look at that we have a really nice
clustering dendogram
except when i look at it the first thing
i notice is it really shows like numbers
down below
now if you were a shareholder and some
data scientist came up to you and said
look at this this is what it means you'd
be looking at that going what the heck
does 3 9 14 19 1 18 mean
so let's give it some words there
so let's do the same plot with our hcl
hc there we go
and let's add in labels and this is just
one of the commands and plots
so we have labels equals my data
and then under my data we want to know
the city
and we'll have it hang minus one that's
just the instructions to make it pretty
so we'll run that
oops i accidentally ran just hang my one
let me try that again
there we go okay so now you can see what
it's done and the hang my one turns it
sideways that way we can see uh central
which is central us and kentucky and we
start to actually get some information
off our clustering setup
and the information you start looking at
is that
we put all the information together
you probably want to look at central
american kentucky together
oklahoma and texas has a lot of
commonality as does arizona and southern
u.s
and you can even group all five of those
florida oklahoma texas arizona and
southern u.s
these regions for some reason share a
lot of similarities and so we want to
start asking what those similarities are
but this gives us a place to look it
says hey these things really go together
you should be grouping these together as
far as your cells and what's what you're
doing
and then one of the things you might
want to do is there's also we can do the
dendogram average
this changes how we do the clustering
so it looks very similar like we had
before and there's our hcl we're going
to assign it
we're going to do an h cluster
we're still doing it on distance oops
distance
and this time we're going to set the
method to average so we can change the
methodology in which it computes
the values
and before if you remember correctly we
did median median's a little bit
different than means we did the most
common one and then we want the average
of the median
and let's go ahead and run that
and then we can plot
and here's our hcl
oops there we go here's our hcl and i
can run that plot
and you can see this changed a little
bit
so our way it computes and groups things
looks a little different than it did
before and let's go ahead and put the
cities back in there and do the hang
control copy let me just real quickly
copy that down here
because we want the same labels
and again you can see nevada
idaho pujet i remember we were looking
at
southern us and arizona texas and
oklahoma florida so the grouping really
hasn't changed too much
so we still have a very similar grouping
it's almost kind of flipped it as far as
the distance based on average has but
this is something you could actually
take to the shareholders and say hey
look these things are connected and at
which point you want to explore a little
deeper as to why they're connected
because they're going to ask you okay
how are they connected and why do we
care
that's a little bit beyond the actual
scope of what we're working on today
but we are going to cover membership
what's called a clustering membership on
there
and let's create a member we'll just
call it number one
oops darin remember.1
and we're going to assign to this
we're going to do cut tree
and
cut tree
it limits it so what that means is i
take my
hc.l in here
oops there we go dot l
and so i'm taking the cluster i just
built and we want to take that cluster
and we want to limit it to just a depth
of three so we'll go ahead and do that
and run that one oops let me go run
there we go so now i've created my
member one
and then oops let me just move this out
of the way
we're going to do an aggregate and we're
going to use z remember z from above
and we're going to turn member 1 into a
list
and then we're going to aggregate that
together based on the mean let me go
ahead and enter run that
so i did member l it's actually number
one
there we go
and if we take a look at this we now
have our group one fixed charge and then
all your different
columns listed there and most of them
should come up kind of looking between
zero and one but you'll see a lot of
variation because we're varying it based
on the means so it's a means the
standard deviation not just forcing it
in between zero and one
which is a much better way usually to
normalize your data than just doing the
zero one setup
and finally we can actually look at the
actual values
and the same chart we just did
oops
i made a mistake on there with my data
there we go okay
and again we now have our actual data
instead of looking at just the if you
looked up here it's all between zero and
one and when we look down here
we now have some actual connections and
how far distance this different data is
again because more of a domain issue and
understanding the oil company and what
these different values means and you can
look at these as being the distances
between different items
so a little bit different view and you
have to really dig deep into this data
what we really want you to take away
from this is the dendogram
and the charts that we did earlier
and that is the cluster output and our
nice dendogram
so this would be stage one in data
analysis of the cells again you'd have
to have a lot more domain experience to
find out what all the individual numbers
we looked at mean and what the distance
is and what's difference between central
america and kentucky and why they're
similar and why it groups all of central
kentucky florida oklahoma texas arizona
and southern us together into one larger
group
so i'd be way beyond the scope of this
but you can see how we start to explore
data and we start to see things in here
where things are grouped together in
ways we might not have seen before and
this is a good start for understanding
and giving advice for cells and
marketing maybe logistics
city development there's all kinds of
things that kind of come together in the
hierarchical clustering as you begin to
explore data and we just want to point
out that we get three clusters of
regions with the highest cells region
with average cells region with the
lowest cells again those are some of the
things that they clustered it around and
you could actually see where things are
going on or lacking you know it's this
case if you're the lowest cells no one
wants to be in the region of the lowest
sales support vector machine is a binary
classifier a supervised machine learning
algorithm and in this video we will
learn what all that means machine
learning algorithms come in three major
flavors supervised learning algorithms
unsupervised learning algorithms and
reinforcement learning and today we'll
cover classification under supervised
learning supervised meaning the data set
has known outcomes if it were
unsupervised it would not have known
outcomes and we wouldn't have the
categories or classes necessary for the
machine to learn but under supervised
learning we do have the known outcomes
in the data set and under supervised
learning there are two major types of
machine learning algorithms
classification which we'll cover today
support vector machine and regression
classification you predict categories
and in regression you generally predict
values so while we look at supervised
learning keep in mind that
classification can really be considered
multi-dimensional in the sense that
sometimes you only have two classes yes
or no two or false and sometimes you
have more than two classes sometimes you
have say under risk management or risk
modeling low risk medium risk or high
risk and svm is a binary classifier it
is a classifier used for those true
false yes no types of classification
problems and in supervised learning
features are important if there are a
lot of features svm may be the better
classification algorithm choice as
opposed to say logistic regression so
for supervised learning the computer is
presented with example inputs and their
desired outputs those known outcomes and
the goal is to learn a general rule that
maps inputs to those outputs for example
bug detection or customer churn or stock
price prediction not the value of the
stock price but whether or not it will
rise or fall and weather prediction
sunny not sunny rain no rain the
classification algorithms generally take
past data data that we have those known
outcomes train the model take new data
once the model is trained ingest it into
the model and create predictions is it a
truck or is it a car and keep in mind
that i said features are important and
the number of features whether or not
those features are applicable to your
problem is a whole different discussion
but in some sense you know probably
intuitively that the color of a car
really isn't indicative of whether or
not it's a car or a truck but the length
of the vehicle or the number of axles or
the weight or the amount of seating may
be more applicable to the algorithm and
to
training the model so what is support
vector machine support vector machine or
svm is a type of classification
algorithm which classifies data based on
its features and svm will classify any
new element into one of those two
classes so we'll give it some inputs the
algorithm will segregate and classify
the data and then create the outputs and
next when we ingest new data an unknown
fruit variable in this example the
algorithm will correctly classify the
fruit apple versus orange so now let's
understand what an svm is and if you
want to understand support vector
machine
you really need a good example and i
know that cricut is a wonderful game i
don't know a lot about it but i know
it's very popular around the world and
we're going to use qriket as an example
of svm so we'll classify qriket players
into batsmen or bowlers using the runs
to wicket ratio so a player with more
runs would be considered a batsman and a
player with more wickets would be
considered a bowler and if we could take
a data set say of people cricket players
with runs and wickets in columns next to
their names we could create a plot a
two-dimensional plot in this example
clear separation between qriket players
considered bowlers and those cricket
players considered batsman and you don't
always have a data set this clean where
there is a clear segregation of data
bowlers versus batsman but for the sake
of understanding svm this example does
well so before we do any separation
before we apply any high-level
mathematics let's just take a look at an
unknown value a new data coming into our
data set and that datum we don't know
what class it belongs to that datum is a
bowler or a batsman we know that much
but we don't know should we consider
that cricket player a batsman or a
bowler and so we want to draw a decision
boundary some type of line separating
the two classes so that we can use that
decision boundary to classify the new
data point of course we could draw lines
there's a yellow line a green line a
blue line there's actually not just
three lines but an infinite number of
lines that we could draw between those
two classes so which one do we pick and
this is kind of reminiscent of simple
linear regression where we find the line
of best fit we want the line of best
separation we want a line that clearly
separates those two groups as much as
possible once we have the correct line
we would be able to classify the new
data point but in this example you can
see if we pick yellow the new data point
would be a bowler but if we picked green
or blue the new data point would be a
batsman so we need the one that best
separates the data what line best
separates the data we'll find the best
line
by computing the maximum margin from
equidistant support vectors now support
vectors in this context simply means the
two points
one from each class that are closest
together but that maximize the distance
between them or the margin so the word
vector here you may think well he really
means points data points well in
two-dimensional space yes and maybe even
in three-dimensional space but once you
get into higher dimensional spaces when
you get more and more features in your
data set you have to consider these as
vectors you can no longer really
describe them as points so we call them
vectors and the reason they're support
vectors is because the two
vectors that are closest together that
maximize the distance between the two
groups
support the algorithm so that's why we
call them support vectors so if you look
at our example there are a couple of
points at the top that are pretty close
to one another and a couple of points at
the bottom of that graph that are pretty
close to each other and i'm not really
sure looking at the graph which two are
closest but clearly those points are the
ones we need to consider the rest of the
other points are too far away from the
rest of the other points in other words
the bowler points are far to the right
and the batsman data points are far to
the left so we'll look at these four
points to begin with mathematically we
would calculate the distance among all
of these points and we would minimize
that distance once we pick the support
vectors we'll draw a dividing line and
then measure the distance from each
support vector to the line the best line
will always have the greatest margin or
distance between the support vectors if
we consider the yellow line as a
decision boundary the player with the
new data point would be considered a
bowler the margins don't appear to be
maximum though so maybe we can come up
with a better line so let's take two
other support vectors and we'll draw the
decision boundary between those and then
we will calculate the margin and notice
now that the unknown data point the new
value would be considered a batsman we
would continue doing this and obviously
a computer does it much quicker than a
human being over and over and over again
until we found the correct decision
boundary with the greatest margin and in
this case if you look at the green
decision boundary the green line appears
to have the maximum margin compared to
the other two and so let's consider this
the boundary of greatest margin and now
classify our unknown data value and now
clearly it belongs in the batsman's
class the green line divides the data
perfectly because it has the greatest
margin or the maximum margin between the
support vectors and now we can have
confidence in our classification that
the new data point is indeed a batsman
technically this dividing line is called
a hyperplane and the reason it's called
a hyperplane will become a little bit
more evident in a few minutes generally
in two-dimensional space we consider
those lines but in three dimensional
space and higher dimensional spaces
they're considered planes or hyperplanes
so we always tend to refer to them as
hyperplanes and the hyperplane that has
the maximum distance from the support
vectors is the one we want so sometimes
called the positive hyperplane d plus is
the shortest distance to the closest
positive point and d minus sometimes
called a negative hyperplane has the
closest shortest distance to the closest
negative point and the sum of d positive
and d negative is called the distance
margin so if you calculate those two
distances and add them up that's the
distance margin and we always want to
maximize that if we don't maximize it we
can have a misclassification and you can
see the yellow margin is much smaller
than the green margin so this problem
set is two dimensional because the
classification is only between two
classes and so we would call this a
linear svm now we're going to take a
look at kernel svm and if you notice in
this picture this is a great depiction
of a plane not a line this is
three-dimensional space so that's the
plane that separates those two classes
so what if our two-dimensional data
looks like this what if there's no clear
linear separation between the two
classes and machine learning parlance we
would say that these are not linearly
separable how could we get support
vector machine to work on data that
looks like this since we can't separate
it into two classes using a line what
we're going to do and clearly there's no
line i mean convince yourself there's no
line that goes and separates those two
classes so what we would do is we would
apply some type of transformation to a
higher dimension we would apply a
function called a kernel function to the
data set such that the data set would be
transformed into a higher dimension a
dimension high enough where we could
clearly separate the two groups the two
classes in this case with a plane much
the same way you saw the picture a few
slides ago where the plane was
separating the two classes here we
clearly could draw some planes between
the green dots and the red dots and of
course we could draw an infinite number
of planes separating those two classes
but we would draw the one that would
maximize the margin so if we let r be
the number of dimensions then the kernel
function would convert a given
two-dimensional space to a
three-dimensional space and as i said
once the data is separated in three
dimensions we can apply svm and separate
the two groups using a two-dimensional
plane and this is analogous in the
higher dimensions and that last picture
on the right-hand side would be some
type of depiction of a higher dimension
hyperplane and there are more than one
type of kernel function there's gaussian
rbf kernel sigmoid kernel polynomial
kernel depending on the dimension and
how you want to transform the data there
are more than one choice for kernel
functions so now let's go through a use
case let's take a look at horses and
mules and see if we can use svm to
classify some new data so the problem
statement is classifying horses and
mules and we're going to use height and
weight as the two features and obviously
horses and mules typically in general
tend to weigh differently and tend to
stand taller so we'll take a data set
we'll import the data set we'll make
sure we have our libraries the e1071
library has support vector machine
algorithms built in we'll compute the
support vectors using the library once
the data is used to train the algorithm
we'll plot the hyperplane get a visual
sense of how the data is separated and
if it's two-dimensional or
three-dimensional that's great remember
if it's higher-dimensional it's tough to
plot those and then we'll use the new
model the trained model to classify new
values in general we would have a
training set a test set and then ingest
the new data but for our example we're
just going to use the whole data set to
train the algorithm and then see how it
performs and once we see how it performs
we'll see did we get a horse did we
predict a horse when we had a horse did
we predict a mule when we had a mule so
here's the r code of course if you want
to run this r code you'll have to
install r and then our studio then
you'll have to ingest the data and then
you'll have to create an indicator
variable to help us with our plots we'll
install our libraries install the
package if you don't already have it
installed i do and then call the library
up into the r session that you're
working we'll create the data frame from
the data that was ingested we will then
view the data frame and of course we
have to explore the data frame hoping
that we don't have missing values or we
don't have outliers if we do have
missing values or outliers we'll have to
either impute those values or delete
those values but in this case let's hope
we don't have any and now for a quick
demo on support vector machines so we
have a working directory where my data
is stored and i'm going to set the
working directory to that data source
and read the data file into r and now
i'm going to create a vector that really
is just an indicator variable it's the
negative ones and the ones that indicate
whether it's a mule or a horse negative
one for a mule positive one for a horse
so i'll create that vector and svm
there's a great package e1071
great library that has the support
vector machine
functions that we're going to use and
now i'm going to create the data frame
i'm going to take my data and i'm going
to add to it the is horse vector
and now let's just take a peek and as
you can see there's the height weight
and whether or not the animal was a mule
or a horse so remember machine learning
we take a data source with known
outcomes and we apply our algorithm to
that data source in this case a data
frame of heights weights and the
indicator variable and then we use the
machine learning algorithm to learn from
that data with those known results so
now let's plot the data the height
versus weight and as you can see the
horses tend to be a lot taller and weigh
a lot more
than the mules so now let's run our
algorithm our svm model against the data
and the key here is that it's a linear
model and we've run it and great now we
have a model let's look at the summary
of the model and as you can see there's
the formula that it ran and some of the
information about the vectors and the
classes and there are two support
vectors so now let's find those two
support vectors on our graph and this
might be a little hard to see the
orange outline around this point and
this point indicate that those are the
two vectors that will support this model
and thus we call them the support
vectors now let's get the parameters of
the hyperplane from the model and let's
plot a line that will be our hyperplane
there's our hyperplane line and
therefore to the left and below our
mules and to the right and above our
horses above that line let's take a few
new observations and i've encoded these
so that it would be illustrative we'll
take these new
observations and we'll plot them
and i'm going to generate a new plot red
being the horses black dots being the
mules i'll create an x and y axis i'm
going to plot three
dots and you can see one of them the
green dot the first one kind of falls
near the mules the blue one kind of
falls near the horses and visually we
might conclude hey one's a mule one's a
horse but what about the orange dot well
for the orange dot we really need our
hyper plane we really need something to
clearly indicate which side it's on and
of course by looking at this data
visualization you can tell that the
orange dot is probably a mule and let's
verify those results by sticking those
observations into our model and predict
some outcomes and down below you can see
that for the three data points one two
and three the first one the green one
was negative one that's a mule the
second one was a positive one that's
blue that's the blue point which was a
horse and the third one which we weren't
sure about but clearly the svm model
correctly predicted that that third
point would be a negative one would be a
mule and we can visually see that by the
hyper plane on the graph so that's a
quick example of svm in general support
vector machines are binary classifiers
we don't use them for higher level
classification if you had three or more
classes you might want to use something
like random forest what applications you
can use it for face detection text
categorization image classification and
bioinformatics really anywhere that you
have the need to classify things into
two groups today we're going to cover
the k nearest neighbors referred to as k
n n and k n is really a fundamental
place to start in the machine learning
it's the basis of a lot of other things
and just the logic behind it is easy to
understand and incorporated in other
forms of machine learning so today
what's in it for you why do we need k n
n
what is k n
how do we choose the factor k
when do we use k n n
how does k n algorithm work and then
we'll dive in to my favorite part the
use case predict whether a person will
have diabetes or not that is a very
common and popular used data set as far
as testing out models and learning how
to use the different models in machine
learning by now we all know machine
learning models make predictions by
learning from the past data available so
we have our input values our machine
learning model builds on those inputs of
what we already know and then we use
that to create a predicted output
is that a dog little kid looking over
there
watching the black cat cross their path
no dear you can differentiate between a
cat and a dog based on their
characteristics cats
cats have sharp claws uses to climb
smaller length of ears meows and purrs
doesn't love to play around dogs they
have dull claws bigger length of ears
barks loves to run around you usually
don't see a cat running around people
although i do have a cat that does that
where dogs do and we can look at these
we can say we can evaluate the sharpness
of the claws how sharp brother claws
and we can evaluate the length of the
ears and we can usually sort out cats
from dogs based on even those two
characteristics
now tell me if it is a cat or a dog not
question usually little kids know cats
and dogs by now unless they live a place
where there's not many cats or dogs so
if we look at the sharpness of the claws
the length of the ears and we can see
that the cat has a smaller ears and
sharper claws than the other animals its
features are more like cats it must be a
cat
sharp claws length of ears and it goes
in the cat group because knn is based on
feature similarity we can do
classification using knn classifier so
we have our input value the picture of
the black cat it goes into our trained
model and it predicts that this is a cat
coming out so what is knn what is the k
n algorithm
k nearest neighbors is what that stands
for is one of the simplest supervised
machine learning algorithms mostly used
for classification so we want to know is
this a dog or is not a dog is it a cat
or not a cat it classifies a data point
based on how its neighbors are
classified knn stores all available
cases and classifies new cases based on
a similarity measure and here we gone
from cats and dogs right into wine
another favorite of mine k n stores all
available cases and classifies new cases
based on a similarity measure and here
you see we have a measurement of sulfur
dioxide versus the chloride level and
then the different wines they've tested
and where they fall on that graph based
on how much sulfur dioxide and how much
chloride k and k n is a perimeter that
refers to the number of nearest
neighbors to include in the majority of
the voting process and so if we add a
new glass of wine there red or white we
want to know what the neighbors are in
this case we're going to put k equals 5.
we'll talk about k in just a minute a
data point is classified by the majority
of votes from its five nearest neighbors
here the unknown point would be
classified as red since four out of five
neighbors are red so how do we choose k
how do we know k equals five i mean
that's what's the value we put in there
so we're going to talk about it how do
we choose a factor k k n algorithm is
based on feature similarity choosing the
right value of k
is a process called parameter tuning and
is important for better accuracy so at k
equals three we can classify we have a
question mark in the middle as either a
as a square or not is it a square or is
it in this case a triangle and so if we
set k equals to 3 we're going to look at
the three nearest neighbors we're going
to say this is a square and if we put k
equals a 7 we classify as a triangle
depending on what the other data is
around and you can see as the k changes
depending on where that point is that
drastically changes your answer and we
jump here we go how do we choose the
factor of k you'll find this in all
machine learning choosing these factors
that's the face you get he's like oh my
gosh did i choose the right k did i set
it right my values in whatever machine
learning tool you're looking at so that
you don't have a huge bias in one
direction or the other and in terms of k
n n the number of k if you choose it too
low the bias is based on it's just two
noises it's it's right next to a couple
things and it's going to pick those
things and you might get a skewed answer
and if your k is too big then it's going
to take forever to process so you're
going to run into processing issues and
resource issues so what we do the most
common use and there's other options for
choosing k is to use the square root of
n so it is a total number of values you
have you take the square root of it in
most cases you also if it's an even
number so if you're using like this case
squares and triangles if it's even you
want to make your k value odd that helps
it select better so in other words
you're not going to have a balance
between two different factors that are
equal so usually take the square root of
n and if it's even you add one to it or
subtract one from it and that's where
you get the k value from that is the
most common use and it's pretty solid it
works very well when do we use k n n we
can use k and n when data is labeled so
you need a label on it we know we have a
group of pictures with dogs dogs cats
cats data is noise free and so you can
see here when we have a class and we
have like underweight 140 23 hello kitty
normal that's pretty confusing we have a
high variety of data coming in so it's
very noisy and that would cause an issue
data set is small so we're usually
working with smaller data sets where you
might get into a gig of data if it's
really clean doesn't have a lot of noise
because k n is a lazy learner i.e it
doesn't learn a discriminative function
from the training set so it's very lazy
so if you have very complicated data and
you have a large amount of it you're not
going to use the knn but it's really
great to get a place to start even with
large data you can sort out a small
sample and get an idea of what that
looks like using the knn and also just
using for smaller data sets k n works
really good how does a k n algorithm
work consider a data set having two
variables height in centimeters and
weight in kilograms and each point is
classified as normal or underweight so
we see right here we have two variables
you know true false they're either
normal or they're not they're
underweight on the basis of the given
data we have to classify the below set
as normal or underweight using knn so if
we have new data coming in that says 57
kilograms and 177 centimeters is that
going to be normal or underweight to
find the nearest neighbors we'll
calculate the euclidean distance
according to the euclidean distance
formula the distance between two points
in the plane with the coordinates x y
and a b is given by distance d equals
the square root of x minus a squared
plus y minus b squared and you can
remember that from the two edges of a
triangle we're computing the third edge
since we know
the x side and the y side let's
calculate it to understand clearly so we
have our unknown point and we placed it
there in red and we have our other
points where the data is scattered
around the distance d1 is the square
root of 170 minus 167 squared plus 57
minus 51 squared which is about 6.7 and
distance 2 is about 13. and distance 3
is about 13.4 similarly we will
calculate the euclidean distance of
unknown data point from all the points
in the data set and because we're
dealing with small amount of data that's
not that hard to do it's actually pretty
quick for a computer and it's not a
really complicated mass you can just see
how close is the data based on the
euclidean distance hence we have
calculated the euclidean distance of
unknown data point from all the points
as shown where x1 and y1 equal 57 and
170 whose class we have to classify so
now we're looking at that we're saying
well here's the euclidean distance who's
going to be their closest neighbors
now let's calculate the nearest neighbor
at k equals three and we can see the
three closest neighbors puts them at
normal and that's pretty self-evident
when you look at this graph it's pretty
easy to say okay what we're just voting
normal normal normal three votes for
normal this is going to be a normal
weight so majority of neighbors are
pointing towards normal hence as per k n
algorithm the class of 57 170 should be
normal so recap of knn positive integer
k is specified along with a new sample
we select the k entries in our database
which are closest to the new sample we
find the most common classification of
these entries this is the classification
we give to the new sample so as you can
see it's pretty straightforward we're
just looking for the closest things that
match what we got so let's take a look
and see what that looks like in a use
case in python so let's dive into the
predict diabetes use case so use case
predict diabetes
the objective predict whether a person
will be diagnosed with diabetes or not
we have a data set of 768 people who
were or were not diagnosed with diabetes
and let's go ahead and open that file
and just take a look at that data and
this is in a simple spreadsheet format
the data itself is comma separated very
common set of data and it's also a very
common way to get the data and you can
see here we have columns a through i
that's what one two three four five six
seven eight
eight columns with a particular
attribute and then the ninth column
which is the outcome is whether they
have diabetes as a data scientist the
first thing you should be looking at is
insulin well you know if someone has
insulin they have diabetes because
that's why they're taking it and that
could cause issue in some of the machine
learning packages but for a very basic
setup this works fine for doing the knn
and the next thing you notice is it
didn't take very much to open it up i
can scroll down to the bottom of the
data there's 768
it's pretty much a small data set you
know at 769 i can easily fit this into
my ram on my computer i can look at it i
can manipulate it and it's not going to
really tax just a regular desktop
computer you don't even need an
enterprise version to run a lot of this
so let's start with importing all the
tools we need and before that of course
we need to discuss what ide i'm using
certainly can use any particular editor
for python but i like to use for doing
uh very basic visual stuff the anaconda
which is great for doing demos with the
jupiter notebook and just a quick view
of the anaconda navigator which is the
new release out there which is really
nice you can see under home i can choose
my application we're going to be using
python36 i have a couple different uh
versions on this particular machine if i
go under environments i can create a
unique environment for each one which is
nice and there's even a little button
there where i can install different
packages so if i click on that button
and open the terminal i can then use a
simple pip install to install different
packages i'm working with let's go ahead
and go back under home and we're going
to launch our notebook and i've already
you know kind of like
the old cooking shows i've already
prepared a lot of my stuff so we don't
have to wait for it to launch because it
takes a few minutes for it to open up a
browser window in this case i'm going to
it's going to open up chrome because
that's my default that i use and since
the script is pre-done you'll see i have
a number of windows open up at the top
the one we're working in and since we're
working on the k n predict whether a
person will have diabetes or not let's
go and put that title in there and i'm
also going to go up here and click on
cell actually we want to go ahead and
first insert a cell below and then i'm
going to go back up to the top cell and
i'm going to change the cell type to
markdown that means this is not going to
run as python it's a markdown language
so if i run this first one it comes up
in nice big letters which is kind of
nice remind us what we're working on and
by now you should be familiar with doing
all of our imports we're going to import
the pandas as pd import numpy is np
pandas is the pandas data frame and
numpy is a number array very powerful
tools to use in here so we have our
imports so we've brought in our pandas
our numpy our two general python tools
and then you can see over here we have
our train test split by now you should
be familiar with splitting the data we
want to split part of it for training
our thing and then training our
particular model and then we want to go
ahead and test the remaining data to see
how good it is pre-processing a standard
scalar preprocessor so we don't have a
bias of really large numbers remember in
the data we had like number of
pregnancies isn't going to get very
large where the amount of insulin they
take and get up to 256 so 256 versus 6
that will skew results so we want to go
ahead and change that so that they're
all uniform between minus 1 and 1. and
then the actual tool this is the k
neighbors classifier we're going to use
and finally the last three are three
tools to test all about testing our
model how good is it we just put down
test on there and we have our confusion
matrix our f1 score and our accuracy so
we have our two general python modules
we're importing and then we have our six
modules specific from the sk learn setup
and then we do need to go ahead and run
this so these are actually imported
there we go and then move on to the next
step and so in this set we're going to
go ahead and load the database we're
going to use pandas remember pandas is
pd and we'll take a look at the data in
python we looked at it in a simple
spreadsheet but usually i like to also
pull it up so we can see what we're
doing so here's our data set equals
pd.read csv that's a pandas command and
the diabetes folder i just put in the
same folder where my ipython script is
if you put in a different folder you
need the full length on there we can
also do a quick length of the data set
that is a simple python command len for
length we might even let's go ahead and
print that we'll go print and if you do
it on its own line link that data set
the jupyter notebook it'll automatically
print it but when you're in most of your
different setups you want to do the
print in front of there and then we want
to take a look at the actual data set
and since we're in pandas we can simply
do data set head and again let's go
ahead and add the print in there
if you put a bunch of these in a row you
know the data set one head data set two
head it only prints out the last one so
i usually always like to keep the print
statement in there but because most
projects only use one data frame panda's
data frame doing it this way doesn't
really matter the other way works just
fine and you can see when we hit the run
button we have the 768 lines which we
knew and we have our pregnancies it's
automatically given a label on the left
remember the head only shows the first
five lines so we have zero through four
and just a quick look at the data you
can see it matches what we looked at
before we have pregnancy glucose blood
pressure all the way to age and then the
outcome on the end and we're going to do
a couple things in this next step we're
going to create a list of columns where
we can't have zero there's no such thing
as zero skin thickness or zero blood
pressure zero glucose
any of those you'd be dead so not a
really good factor if they don't if they
have a zero in there because they didn't
have the data and we'll take a look at
that because we're going to start
replacing that information with a couple
of different things let's see what that
looks like so first we create a nice
list as you can see we have the values
talked about glucose blood pressure skin
thickness
and this is a nice way when you're
working with columns is to list the
columns you need to do some kind of
transformation on a very common thing to
do and then for this particular setup we
certainly could use the there's some
panda tools that will do a lot of this
where we can replace the n a but we're
going to go ahead and do it as a data
set column equals data set column dot
replace this is this is still pandas you
can do it direct there's also one that's
that you look for your nan a lot of
different options in here but the nan
numpy nan is what that stands for is
none it doesn't exist so the first thing
we're doing here is we're replacing
the zero with a numpy none there's no
data there that's what that says that's
what this is saying right here so put
the zero in and we're going to play
zeros with no data so if it's a zero
that means the person's well hopefully
not dead hope they just didn't get the
data the next thing we want to do is
we're going to create the mean which is
the integer from the data set from the
column dot mean where we skip n a's we
can do that that is a pandas command
there the skip n a so we're going to
figure out the mean of that data set and
then we're going to take that data set
column and we're going to replace all
the npn
with the means why did we do that we
could have actually just taken this step
and gone right down here and just
replace zero and skip anything were
except you could actually there's a way
to skip zeros and then just replace all
the zeros but in this case we want to go
ahead and do it this way so you could
see that we're switching this to a
non-existent value then we're going to
create the mean well this is the average
person so if we don't know what it is if
they did not get the data and the data
is missing one of the tricks is you
replace it with the average what is the
most common data for that this way you
can still use the rest of those values
to do your computation and it kind of
just brings that particular value of
those missing values out of the equation
let's go ahead and take this and we'll
go ahead and run it doesn't actually do
anything so we're still preparing our
data if you want to see what that looks
like we don't have anything in the first
few lines just not going to show up but
we certainly could look at a row let's
do that let's go into our data set with
printed data set
and let's pick in this case let's just
do
glucose
and if i run this this is going to print
all the different glucose levels going
down and we thankfully don't see
anything in here that looks like missing
data at least on the ones it shows you
can see it skipped a bunch in the middle
that's what it does if you have too many
lines in jupiter notebook it'll skip a
few and go on to the next in a data set
let me go and remove this
and we'll just zero out that and of
course before we do any processing
before proceeding any further we need to
split the data set into our train and
testing data that way we have something
to train it with and something to test
it on and you're going to notice we did
a little something here with the pandas
database code there we go my drawing
tool we've added in this right here
of the data set and what this says is
that the first one in pandas this is
from the pd pandas it's going to say
within the data set we want to look at
the eye location and it is all rows
that's what that says so we're going to
keep all the rows but we're only looking
at 0 column zero to eight remember
column nine here it is right up here we
put it in here is outcome well that's
not part of the training data that's
part of the answer yes column nine but
it's listed as eight number eight so
zero to eight is nine columns so uh
eight is the value and when you see it
in here 0 this is actually 0 to 7 it
doesn't include the last one and then we
go down here to y which is our answer
and we want just the last one just
column 8 and you can do it this way with
this particular notation and then if you
remember we imported the train test
split that's part of the sk learn right
there and we simply put in our x and our
y
we're going to do random state equals
zero you don't have to necessarily seat
it that's a seed number i think the
default is one when you see it i have to
look that up and then the test size test
size is 0.2 that simply means we're
going to take 20 of the data and put it
aside so that we can test it later
that's all that is and again we're going
to run it not very exciting so far we
haven't had any print out other than to
look at the data but that is a lot of
this is prepping this data once you prep
it the actual lines of code are quick
and easy and we're almost there with the
actual writing of our knn we need to go
ahead and do a scale the data if you
remember correctly we're fitting the
data in a standard scalar which means
instead of the data being from you know
5 to 303 in one column and the next
column is 1 to 6 we're going to set that
all so that all the data is between -1
and 1. that's what that standard scalar
does keeps it standardized and we only
want to fit the scalar with the training
set but we want to make sure the testing
set is the x test going in is also
transformed so it's processing it the
same so here we go with our standard
scalar we're going to call it sc
underscore x for the scalar and we're
going to import the standard scalar into
this variable and then our x train
equals sc underscore x dot fit transform
so we're creating the scalar on the x
train variable and then our x test we're
also going to transform it so
we've trained and transformed the x
train and then the x test
isn't part of that training it isn't
part of that of training the transformer
it just gets transformed that's all it
does and again we're going to run this
if you look at this we've now gone
through these steps all three of them
we've taken care of replacing our zeros
for key columns it shouldn't be zero and
we replace that with the means
of those columns that way that they fit
right in with our data models we've come
down here we split the data so now we
have our test data
and our training data and then we've
taken and we've scaled the data so all
of our data going in no no we don't tr
we don't train the y part the y train
and y test that never has to be trained
it's only the data going in that's what
we want to train in there then define
the model using k neighbors classifier
and fit the train data in the model so
we do all that data prep and you can see
down here we're only going to have a
couple lines of code where we're
actually building our model and training
it that's one of the cool things about
python and how far we've come it's such
an exciting time to be in machine
learning because there's so many
automated tools let's see before we do
this let's do a quick length of and
let's do y we want let's just do length
of y
and we get 768 and if we import math we
do math dot square root let's do y
train there we go it's actually supposed
to be x train
before we do this let's go ahead and do
import math and do math square root
length of y test and when i run that we
get 12.409
i want to show you where this number
comes from we're about to use 12 is an
even number so if you know if you're
ever voting on things remember the
neighbors all vote don't want to have an
even number of neighbors voting so we
want to do something odd and let's just
take one away and we'll make it 11. let
me delete this out of here this one the
reasons i love jupiter notebook is you
can flip around and do all kinds of
things on the fly so we'll go ahead and
put in our classifier we're creating our
classifier now and it's going to be the
k neighbors classifier n neighbors equal
11. remember we did 12 minus 1 for 11.
we have an odd number of neighbors p
equals 2 because we're looking for is it
are they diabetic or not and we're using
the euclidean metric there are other
means of measuring the distance you
could do like square square means values
all kinds of measure this but the
euclidean's the most common one and it
works quite well it's important to
evaluate the model let's use the
confusion matrix to do that and we're
going to use the confusion matrix
wonderful tool and then we'll jump into
the f1 score
and finally accuracy score which is
probably the most commonly used quoted
number when you go into a meeting or
something like that so let's go ahead
and paste that in there and we'll set
the cm equal to confusion matrix y test
y predict so those are the two values
we're going to put in there and let me
go ahead and run that and print it out
and the way you interpret this is you
have the y predicted which would be your
title up here you could do let's just do
pred
predicted across the top and actual
going down actual
it's always hard to to write in here
actual that means that this column here
down the middle that's the important
column and it means that our prediction
said 94 and prediction in the actual
agreed on 94 and 32. this number here
the 13 and the 15 those are what was
wrong so you could have like three
different if you're looking at this
across three different variables instead
of just two you'd end up with the third
row down here in the column going down
the middle so in the first case we have
the the and i believe the zero is a 94
people who don't have diabetes the
prediction said that 13 of those people
did have diabetes and were at high risk
and the 32 that had diabetes it had
correct but our prediction said another
15 out of that 15 it classified as
incorrect so you can see where that
classification comes in and how that
works on the confusion matrix then we're
going to go ahead and print the f1 score
let me just run that and you see we get
a 0.69 in our f1 score the f1
takes into account both sides of the
balance of false positives
where if we go ahead and just do the
accuracy account and that's what most
people think of is it looks at just how
many we got right out of how many we got
wrong so a lot of people when you're a
data scientist and you're talking to
other data scientists they're going to
ask you what the f1 score the f score is
if you're talking to the general public
or the decision makers in the business
they're going to ask what the accuracy
is and the accuracy is always better
than the f1 score but the f1 score is
more telling it lets us know that
there's more false positives than we
would like on here but 82 percent not
too bad for a quick flash look at
people's different statistics and
running an sk learn and running the knn
the k nearest neighbor on it so we have
created a model using knn which can
predict whether a person will have
diabetes or not or at the very least
whether they should go get a checkup and
have their glucose checked regularly or
not the print accuracy score we got the
0.818 was pretty close to what we got
and we can pretty much round that off
and just say we have an accuracy of 80
tells us it is a pretty fair fit in the
model introducing naive bayes classifier
have you ever wondered how your mail
provider implements spam filtering or
how online news channels perform news
text classification or how companies
perform sentimental analysis of their
audience on social media all of this and
more is done through a machine learning
algorithm called naive bayes classifier
we'll start with what is naive bayes a
basic overview of how it works we'll get
into naive bayes and machine learning
where it fits in with our other machine
learning tools why do we need naive
bayes and understanding naive bayes
classifier a much more in depth of how
the math works in the background finally
we'll get into the advantages of the
nave bays classifier in the machine
learning setup and then we'll roll up
our sleeves and do my favorite part
we'll actually do some python coding and
do some text classification using the
naive bayes what is naive bayes let's
start with a basic introduction to the
bayes theorem named after thomas bayes
from the 1700s who first coined this in
the western literature naive bayes
classifier works on the principle of
conditional probability as given by the
bayes theorem before we move ahead let
us go through some of the simple
concepts in the probability that we will
be using let us consider the following
example of tossing two coins here we
have two quarters and if we look at all
the different possibilities of what they
can come up as we get that they could
come up as head heads they come up as
head tail tail head and tell tell when
doing the math on probability we usually
denote probability as a p a capital p so
the probability of getting two heads
equals one fourth you can see on our
data set we have two heads and this
occurs once out of the four
possibilities and then the probability
of at least one tail occurs three
quarters of the time you'll see in three
of the coin tosses we have tails in them
and out of four that's three fourths and
then the probability of the second coin
being head given the first coin is tail
is one half and the probability of
getting two heads given the first coin
is a head is one half we'll demonstrate
that in just a minute and show you how
that math works now when we're doing it
with two coins it's easy to see but when
you have something more complex you can
see where these pro these formulas
really come in and work so the bayes
theorem gives us the conditional
probability of an event a given another
event b has occurred in this case the
first coin toss will be b and the second
coin toss a this could be confusing
because we've actually reversed the
order of them and go from b to a instead
of a to b you'll see this a lot when you
work in probabilities the reason is
we're looking for event a we want to
know what that is so we're going to
label that a since that's our focus and
then given another event b has occurred
in the bayes theorem as you can see on
the left the probability of a occurring
given b has occurred equals the
probability of b occurring given a has
occurred times a probability of a over
the probability of b this simple formula
can be moved around just like any
algebra formula and we could do the
probability of a after a given b times
probability of b equals the probability
of b given a times probability of a you
can easily move that around and multiply
it and divide it out let us apply bayes
theorem to our example here we have our
two quarters and we'll notice that the
first two probabilities of getting two
heads and at least one tail we compute
directly off the data so you can easily
see that we have
one example h out of four one fourth and
we have three with tails in them giving
us three quarters or three four
seventy-five percent
the second condition the second uh set
three and four we're gonna explore a
little bit more in detail now we stick
to a simple example with two coins
because you can easily understand the
math the probability of throwing a tail
doesn't matter what comes before it and
the same with the head so still going to
be 50 percent or one half but when that
come when that probability gets more
complicated let's say you have a d6 dice
or some other instance then this formula
really comes in handy but let's stick to
the simple example for now in this
sample space let a be the event that the
second coin is head and b be the event
that the first coin is tails again we
reversed it because we want to know what
the second event is going to be so we're
going to be focusing on a and we write
that out as a probability of a given b
and we know this from our formula that
that equals the probability of b given a
times the probability of a over the
probability of b and when we plug that
in we plug in the probability of the
first coin being tails given the second
coin is heads and the probability of the
second coin being heads given the first
coin being over the probability of the
first coin being tails when we plug that
data in and we have the probability of
the first coin being tails given the
second coin is heads times the
probability of the second coin being
heads over the probability of the first
coin being tails you can see it's a
simple formula to calculate we have one
half times one-half over one-half or
one-half equals point five or one-fourth
so the bayes theorem basically
calculates the conditional probability
of the occurrence of an event based on
prior knowledge of conditions that might
be related to the event we will explore
this in detail when we take up an
example of online shopping further in
this tutorial understanding naive bayes
and machine learning like with any of
our other machine learning tools it's
important to understand where the naive
bayes fits in the hierarchy so under the
machine learning we have supervised
learning and there is other things like
unsupervised learning there's also
reward system this falls under the
supervised learning and then under the
supervisor's learning there's
classification there's also regression
but we're going to be in the
classification side and then under
classification is your naive bayes let's
go ahead and glance into where is naive
bayes use let's look at some of the use
scenarios for it as a classifier we use
it in face recognition is this cindy or
is it not cindy or whoever or it might
be used to identify parts of the face
that they then feed into another part of
the face recognition program this is the
eye this is the nose this is the mouth
weather prediction is it going to be
rainy or sunny medical recognition news
prediction it's also used in medical
diagnosis we might diagnose somebody as
either as high risk or not as high risk
for cancer or heart disease or other
ailments and news classification we look
at the google news and it says well is
this political or is this world news or
a lot of that's all done with a naive
bayes
naive bayes classifier now we already
went through a basic understanding with
the coins and the two heads and two
tails and head tail tail heads etc we're
going to do just a quick review on that
and remind you that the naive bayes
classifier is based on the bayes theorem
which gives a conditional probability of
event a given event b and that's where
the probability of a given b equals the
probability of b given a times
probability of a over probability of b
remember this is an algebraic function
so we can move these different entities
around we can multiply by the
probability of b so it goes to the left
hand side and then we could divide by
the probability of a given b and just as
easily come up with a new formula for
the probability of b to me staring at
these algebraic functions kind of gives
me a slight headache
it's a lot better to see if we can
actually understand how this data fits
together in a table and let's go ahead
and start applying it to some actual
data so you can see what that looks like
so we're going to start with the
shopping demo problem statement and
remember we're going to solve this first
in table form so you can see what the
math looks like and then we're going to
solve it in python and in here we want
to predict whether the person will
purchase a product are they going to buy
or don't buy very important if you're
running a business you want to know how
to maximize your profits or at least
maximize the purchase of the people
coming into your store and we're going
to look at a specific combination of
different variables in this case we're
going to look at the day the discount
and the free delivery and you can see
here under the day we want to know
whether it's on the weekday you know
somebody's working they come in after
work or maybe they don't work weekend
you can see the bright colors coming
down there celebrating not being in work
or holiday and did we offer a discount
that day yes or no did we offer free
delivery that day yes or no and from
this we want to know whether the person
is going to buy based on these traits so
we can maximize them and find out the
best system for getting somebody to come
in and purchase our goods and products
from our store now having a nice visual
is great but we do need to dig into the
data so let's go ahead and take a look
at the data set
we have a small sample data set of 30
rows we're showing you the first 15 of
those rows for this demo now the actual
data file you can request just type in
below under the comments on the youtube
video and we'll send you some more
information and send you that file as
you can see here the file is very simple
columns and rows we have the day the
discount the free delivery and did the
person purchase or not and then we have
under the day whether it was a weekday a
holiday was it the weekend this is a
pretty simple set of data and long
before computers people used to look at
this data and calculate this all by hand
so let's go ahead and walk through this
and see what that looks like when we put
that into tables also note in today's
world we're not usually looking at three
different variables in 30 rows nowadays
because we're able to collect data so
much we're usually looking at 27 30
variables across hundreds of rows the
first thing we want to do is we're going
to take this data and based on the data
set containing our three inputs day
discount and free delivery we're going
to go ahead and populate that to
frequency tables for each attribute so
we want to know if they had a discount
how many people
buy and did not buy did they have a
discount yes or no do we have a free
delivery yes or no on those dates how
many people made a purchase how many
people didn't and the same with the
three days of the week was it a weekday
a weekend a holiday and did they buy yes
or no as we dig in deeper to this table
for our bayes theorem let the event buy
ba now remember we looked at the coins i
said we really want to know what the
outcome is did the person buy or not and
that's usually event a is what you're
looking for and the independent
variables discount free delivery and day
bb so we'll call that probability of b
now let us calculate the likelihood
table for one of the variables let's
start with day which includes weekday
weekend and holiday and let us start by
summing all of our rows so we have the
weekday row and out of the weekdays
there's nine plus two so it's 11
weekdays there's eight weekend days and
11 holidays wow that's a lot of holidays
and then we want to sum up the total
number of days so we're looking at a
total of 30 days let's start pulling
some information from our chart and see
where that takes us and when we fill in
the chart on the right you can see that
9 out of 24 purchases are made on the
weekday 7 out of 24 purchases on the
weekend and 8 out of 24 purchases on a
holiday and out of all the people who
come in 24 out of 30 purchase you can
also see how many people do not purchase
on the weekdays two out of six didn't
purchase and so on and so on we can also
look at the totals and you'll see on the
right we put together some of the
formulas the probability of making a
purchase on the weekend comes out 11 out
of 30. so out of the 30 people who came
into the store throughout the weekend
weekday and holiday 11 of those
purchases were made on the weekday and
then you can also see the probability of
them not making a purchase and this is
done for doesn't matter which day of the
week so we call that probability of no
buy would be 6 over 30 or 0.2 so there's
a 20 percent chance that they're not
going to make a purchase no matter what
day of the week it is and finally we
look at the probability of b of a in
this case we're going to look at the
probability of the weekday and not
buying two of the no buys were done out
of the weekend out of the six people who
did not make purchases so when we look
at that probability of the weekday
without a purchase is going to be 0.33
or 33 percent
let's take a look at this at different
probabilities and based on this
likelihood table let's go ahead and
calculate conditional probabilities as
below the first three we just did the
probability of making a purchase on the
weekday is 11 out of 30 or roughly 36 or
37 percent 0.367 the probability of not
making a purchase at all doesn't matter
what day of the week is roughly 0.2 or
20 percent and the probability of a
weekday no purchase is roughly 2 out of
six so two out of six of our no
purchases were made on the weekday and
then finally we take our p of a b
if you look we've kept the symbols up
there we got p of probability of b
probability of a probability of b if a
we should remember that the probability
of a if b is equal to the first one
times the probability of no buys over
the probability of the weekday so we
could calculate it both off the table we
created we can also calculate this by
the formula and we get the 0.367
which equals or 0.33 times 0.2 over
0.367 which equals 0.179
or roughly 17 to 18 percent and that'd
be the probability of no purchase done
on the weekday and this is important
because we can look at this and say as
the probability of buying on the weekday
is more than the probability of not
buying on the weekday we can conclude
that customers will most likely buy the
product on a weekday now we've kept our
charts simple and we're only looking at
one aspect so you should be able to look
at the table and come up with the same
information or the same conclusion that
should be kind of intuitive at this
point next we can take the same setup we
have the frequency tables of all three
independent variables now we can
construct the likelihood tables for all
three of the variables we're working
with we can take our day like we did
before we have weekday weekend and
holiday we filled in this table and then
we can come in and also do that for the
discount yes or no did they buy yes or
no and we fill in that full table so now
we have our probabilities for
a discount and whether the discount
leads to a purchase or not and the
probability for free delivery does that
lead to a purchase or not and this is
where it starts getting really exciting
let us use these three likelihood tables
to calculate whether a customer will
purchase a product on a specific
combination of day discount and free
delivery or not purchase here let us
take a combination of these factors day
equals holiday discount equals yes free
delivery equals yes let's dig deeper
into the math and actually see what this
looks like and we're going to start with
looking for the probability of them not
purchasing on the following combinations
of days we're actually looking for the
probability of a equal no buy no
purchase and our probability of b we're
going to set equal to is it a holiday
did they get a discount yes and was it a
free delivery yes before we go further
let's look at the original equation the
probability of a if b equals the
probability of b given the condition a
and the probability times probability of
a over the probability of b occurring
now this is basic algebra so we can
multiply this information together so
when you see the probability of a given
b in this case the condition is b c and
d or the three different variables we're
looking at and when you see the
probability of b that would be the
conditions we're actually going to
multiply those three separate conditions
out probability of you'll see that in a
second in the formula times the full
probability of a over the full
probability of b so here we are back to
this and we're going to have let a equal
no purchase and we're looking for the
probability of b on the condition a
where a sets for three different things
remember that equals the probability of
a given the condition b
and in this case we just multiply those
three different variables together so we
have the probability of the discount
times the probability of free delivery
times the probability is a day equal a
holiday those are our three variables of
the probability of a if b and then that
is going to be multiplied by the
probability of them not making a
purchase and then we want to divide that
by the total probabilities and they're
multiplied together so we have the
probability of a discount the
probability of a free delivery and the
probability of it being on a holiday
when we plug those numbers in we see
that 1 out of 6 were no purchase on a
discounted day two out of six were a no
purchase on a free delivery day and
three out of six were a no purchase on a
holiday those are our three
probabilities of afb multiplied out and
then that has to be multiplied by the
probability of a no purchase and
remember the prop probability of a no
buy is across all the data so that's
where we get the 6 out of 30. we divide
that out by the probability of each
category over the total number so we get
the 20 out of 30 had a discount 23 out
of 30 had a yes for free delivery and 11
out of 30 we're on a holiday we plug all
those numbers in we get
0.178 so in our probability math we have
a 0.178 if it's a no buy for a holiday a
discount and a free delivery let's turn
that around and see what that looks like
if we have a purchase i promise this is
the last page of math before we dig into
the python script so here we're
calculating the probability of the
purchase using the same math we did to
find out if they didn't buy now we want
to know if they did buy and again we're
going to go by the day equals a holiday
discount equals yes free delivery equals
yes and let a equal buy now right about
now you might be asking why are we doing
both calculations why why would we want
to know the no buys and buys for the
same data going in well we're going to
show you that in just a moment but we
have to have both of those pieces of
information so that we can figure it out
as a percentage as opposed to a
probability equation and we'll get to
that normalization here in just a moment
let's go ahead and walk through this
calculation and as you can see here the
probability of a on the condition of b b
being all three categories did we have a
discount with a purchase do we have a
free delivery with a purchase and did we
is a day equal to holiday and when we
plug this all into that formula and
multiply it all out we get our
probability of a discount probability of
a free delivery probability of the day
being a holiday times the overall
probability of it being a purchase
divided by again multiplying the three
variables out the full probability of
there being a discount the full
probability of being a free delivery and
the full probability of there being a
day equal holiday and that's where we
get this 19 over 24 times 21 over 24
times 8 over 24 times the p of a 24 over
30 divided by the probability of the
discount the free delivery times the day
or 20 over 30 23 over 30 times 11 over
30 and that gives us our 0.986
so what are we going to do with these
two pieces of data we just generated
well let's go ahead and go over them we
have a probability of purchase equals
0.986 we have a probability of no
purchase equals 0.178
so finally we have a conditional
probabilities of purchase on this day
let us take that we're going to
normalize it and we're going to take
these probabilities and turn them into
percentages this is simply done by
taking the sum of probabilities which
equals 0.98686
plus 0.178 and that equals the 1.164
if we divide each probability by the sum
we get the percentage and so the
likelihood of a purchase is 84.71
and the likelihood of no purchase is
15.29
given these three different variables so
it's if it's on a holiday if it's a with
a discount and has free delivery then
there's an 84.71 percent chance that the
customer is going to come in and make a
purchase hooray they purchased our stuff
we're making money if you're owning a
shop that's like is the bottom line is
you want to make some money so you keep
your shop open and have a living now i
promised you that we were going to be
finishing up the math here with a few
pages so we're going to move on and
we're going to do two steps the first
step is i want you to understand
why you want to under why you want to
use the naive bayes what are the
advantages of naive bayes and then once
we understand those advantages we'll
just look at that briefly then we're
going to dive in and do some python
coding advantages of naive bayes
classifier so let's take a look at the
six advantages of the naive bayes
classifier and we're going to walk
around this lovely wheel looks like an
origami folded paper the first one is
very simple and easy to implement
certainly you could walk through the
tables and do this by hand you gotta be
a little careful because the notations
can get confusing you have all these
different probabilities and i certainly
mess those up as i put them on you know
is it on the top of the bottom got to
really pay close attention to that when
you put it into python it's really nice
because you don't have to worry about
any of that you let the python handle
that the python module but understanding
it you can put it on a table and you can
easily see how it works and it's a
simple algebraic function it needs less
training data so if you have smaller
amounts of data this is great powerful
tool for that handles both continuous
and discrete data it's highly scalable
with number of predictors and data
points so as you can see just keep
multiplying different probabilities in
there and you can cover not just three
different variables or sets you can now
expand this to even more categories
number five it's fast it can be used in
real time predictions this is so
important this is why it's used in a lot
of our predictions on online shopping
carts referrals spam filters is because
there's no time delay as it has to go
through and figure out a neural network
or one of the other mini setups where
you're doing classification and
certainly there's a lot of other tools
out there in the machine learning that
can handle these
but most of them are not as fast as a
naive bayes and then finally it's not
sensitive to irrelevant features so it
picks up on your different probabilities
and if you're short on date on one
probability you can kind of it
automatically adjust for that those
formulas are very automatic and so you
can still get a very solid
predictability even if you're missing
data or you have overlapping data for
two completely different areas we see
that a lot in doing census and studying
of people and habits where they might
have one study that covers one aspect
another one that overlaps and because
the two overlap they can then predict
the unknowns for the group that they
haven't done the second study on or vice
versa so it's very powerful in that it
is not sensitive to the irrelevant
features and in fact you can use it to
help predict features that aren't even
in there so now we're down to my
favorite part we're going to roll up our
sleeves and do some actual programming
we're going to do the use case text
classification now i would challenge you
to go back and send us a note on the
notes below underneath the video and
request the data for the shopping cart
so you can plug that into python code
and do that on your own time so you can
walk through it since we walk through
all the information on it but we're
going to do a python code doing text
classification very popular for doing
the naive bayes so we're going to use
our new tool to perform a text
classification of news headlines and
classified news into different topics
for a news website as you can see here
we have a nice image of the google news
and then related on the right sub groups
i'm not sure where they actually pulled
the actual data we're going to use from
it's one of the standard sets but
certainly this can be used on any of our
news headlines in classification so
let's see how it can be done using the
naive bayes classifier now we're at my
favorite part we're actually going to
write some python script roll up our
sleeves and we're going to start by
doing our imports these are very basic
imports including our news group and
we'll take a quick glance at the target
names then we're going to go ahead and
start training our data set and putting
it together we'll put together a nice
graph because it's always good to have a
graph to show what's going on and once
we've traded it and we've shown you a
graph of what's going on then we're
going to explore how to use it and see
what that looks like now i'm going to
open up my favorite editor or inline
editor for python you don't have to use
this you can use whatever your editor
that you like whatever interface ide you
want this just happens to be the
anaconda jupiter notebook and i'm going
to paste that first piece of code in
here so we can walk through it
let's make it a little bigger on the
screen so you have a nice view of what's
going on and we're using python 3 in
this case 3.5 so this would work in any
of your 3x
if you have it set up correctly it
should also work in a lot of the 2x you
just have to make sure all of the
versions of the modules match your
python version and in here you'll notice
the first line is your percentage matte
plot library inline now three of these
lines of code are all about plotting the
graph
this one lets the notebook notes as an
inline setup that we want the graphs to
show up on this page without it in a
notebook like this which is an explorer
interface it won't show up now a lot of
ides don't require that a lot of them
like on if i'm working on one of my
other setups it just has a pop-up and
the graph pops up on there so you have
that setup also but for this we want the
matplot library inline and then we're
going to import numpy as np that's
number python which has a lot of
different formulas in it that we use for
both of our sklearn module and we also
use it for any of the upper math
functions in python and it's very common
to see that as np numpy as np the next
two lines are all about our graphing
remember i said three of these were
about graphing well we need our map plot
library dot pi plot as plt and you'll
see that plt is a very common setup as
is the sns and just like the np and
we're gonna import seaborn as sns and
we're going to do the sns.set
now seaborn sits on top of pie plot and
it just makes a really nice heat map
it's really good for heat maps and if
you're not familiar with heat maps that
just means we give it a color scale the
term comes from the brighter red it is
the hotter it is in some form of data
and you can set it to whatever you want
and we'll see that later on so those
you'll see that those three lines of
code here are just importing the graph
function so we can graph it and as a
data science test you always want to
graph your data and have some kind of
visual it's really hard just to shove
numbers in front of people and they look
at it and it doesn't mean anything and
then from the sklearn.datasets
we're going to import the fetch 20 news
groups very common one for analyzing
tokenizing words and setting them up and
exploring how the words work and how do
you categorize different things when
you're dealing with documents and then
we set our data equal to fetch 20 news
groups so our data variable will have
the data in it and we're going to go
ahead and just print the target names
data.target names and let's see what
that looks like and you'll see here we
have alt atheism comp graphics comp osms
windows dot miscellaneous and it goes
all the way down to talk politics dot
miscellaneous talk religion dot
miscellaneous these are the categories
they've already assigned to this news
group and it's called fetch 20 because
you'll see there's i believe there's 20
different topics in here or 20 different
categories as we scroll down now we've
gone through the 20 different categories
and we're going to go ahead and start
defining all the categories and set up
our data so we're actually getting here
going to go ahead and get it get the
data all set up and take a look at our
data and let's move this over to our
jupyter notebook and let's see what this
code does
first we're going to set our categories
now if you noticed up here i could have
just as easily set this equal to
data.target underscore names because
it's the same thing but we want to kind
of spell it out for you so you can see
the different categories it kind of
makes it more visual so you can see what
your data is looking like in the
background once we've created the
categories
we're going to open up a train set so
this training set of data is going to go
into fetch 20 news groups and it's a
subset in there called train and
categories equals categories so we're
pulling out those categories that match
and then if you have a train set you
should also have the testing set we have
test equals fetch 20 news group subset
equals test and categories equals
categories let's go down one size so it
all fits on my screen there we go and
just so we can really see what's going
on let's see what happens when we print
out
one part of that data
so
it creates train and under train it
creates train dot data and we're just
going to look at data piece number five
and let's go ahead and run that and see
what that looks like and you can see
when i print train dot data number five
under train it prints out one of the
articles this is article number five you
can go through and read it on there and
we can also go in here and change this
to test which should look identical
because it's splitting the date up into
different groups train and test and
we'll see test number five is a
different article but it's another
article in here and maybe you're curious
and you want to see just how many
articles are in here we could do
length
of train dot data and if we run that
you'll see that the training data has 11
314 articles so we're not going to go
through all those articles that's a lot
of articles but we can look at one of
them just so you can see what kind of
information is coming out of it and what
we're looking at and we'll just look at
number five for today and here we have
it rewording the second amendment ids
vtt line 58 lions 58 in article
etc and you scroll all the way down and
see all the different parts to there now
we've looked at it and that's pretty
complicated when you look at one of
these articles to try to figure out how
do you weight this if you look down here
we have different words and maybe the
word from well from is probably in all
the articles so it's not going to have a
lot of meaning as far as trying to
figure out whether this article fits one
of the categories or not so trying to
figure out which category fits in based
on these words is where the challenge
comes in now that we've viewed our data
we're going to dive in and do the actual
predictions this is the actual naive
bayes and we're going to throw another
model at you or another module at you
here in just a second we can't go into
too much detail but it deals
specifically working with words and text
and what they call tokenizing those
words
so let's take this code and let's uh
skip on over to our jupiter notebook and
walk through it and here we are in our
jupiter notebook let's paste that in
there and i can run this code right off
the bat it's not actually going to
display anything yet but it has a lot
going on in here so the top we had the
print module from the earlier one i
didn't know why that was in there so
we're going to start by importing our
necessary packages and from the sklearn
features extraction dot text we're going
to import tf idf vectorizer i told you
we're going to throw a module at you we
can't go too much into the math behind
this or how it works you can look it up
the notation for the math is usually
tf.idf
and that's just a way of weighing the
words and it weighs the words based on
how many times they're used in a
document how many times or how many
documents are used in and it's a well
used formula it's been around for a
while it's a little confusing to put
this in here
but let's let her know that it just goes
in there and waits the different words
in the document for us that way we don't
have to wait if you put a weight on it
if you remember i was talking about that
up here earlier if these are all emails
they probably all have the word from in
them from probably has a very low weight
it has very little value in telling you
what this document's about same with
words like in an article in articles in
cost of
maybe cost might or were words like
criminal weapons destruction these might
have a heavier weight because they
describe a little bit more what the
article's doing well how do you figure
out all those weights in the different
articles that's what this module does
that's what the tf idf vectorizer is
going to do for us and then we're going
to import our sklearn.naive bayes and
that's our multinomial nb
multinomial
naive bayes pretty easy to understand
that where that comes from and then
finally we have the skylearn pipeline
import make pipeline now the make
pipeline is just a cool piece of code
because we're going to take the
information we get from the tf idf
vectorizer and we're going to pump that
into the multinomial nb
so a pipeline is just a way of
organizing how things flow it's used
commonly you probably already guess what
it is if you've done any businesses they
talk about the sales pipeline
if you're on a work crew or project
manager you have your pipeline of
information that's going through where
your projects and what has to be done in
what order that's all this pipeline is
we're going to take the tfid vectorizer
and then we're going to push that into
the multinomial nb now we've designated
that as the variable model we have our
pipeline model and we're going to take
that model and this is just so elegant
this is done in just a couple lines of
code
model.fit and we're going to fit the
data and first the train data and then
the train target
now the train data has the different
articles in it you can see the one we
were just looking at and the train dot
target is what category they already
categorized that that particular article
as and what's happening here is the
train data is going into the tf id
vectorizer so when you have one of these
articles that goes in there it weights
all the words in there so there's
thousands of words with different
weights on them i remember once running
a model on this and i literally had 2.4
million tokens go into this
so when you're doing like large document
bases you can have a huge number of
different words it then takes those
words gives them a weight and then based
on that weight based on the words and
the weights and then puts that into the
multinomial in b and once we go into our
naive bayes
we want to put the train target in there
so the train data that's been mapped to
the tfid vectorizer is now going through
the multinomial in b and then we're
telling it well these are the answers
these are the answers to the different
documents so this document that has all
these words with these different weights
from the first part is going to be
whatever category it comes out of maybe
it's the
talk show or the article on religion
miscellaneous once we fit that model we
can then take labels and we're going to
set that equal to model.predict most of
the sklearn used the term dot predict to
let us know that we've now trained the
model and now we want to get some
answers and we're going to put our test
data in there because our test data is
the stuff we held off to the side we
didn't train it on there and we don't
know what's going to come up out of it
and we just want to find out how good
our labels are do they match what they
should be now i've already run this
through there's no actual output to it
to show this is just setting it all up
this is just training our model creating
the labels so we can see how good it is
and then we move on to the next step to
find out what happened to do this we're
going to go ahead and create a confusion
matrix and a heat map so
the confusion matrix which is confusing
just by its very name is basically going
to ask how confused is our answer did it
get it correct or did it miss some
things in there or have some mis labels
and then we're going to put that on a
heat map so we'll have some nice colors
to look at to see how that plots out
let's go ahead and take this code and
see how that take a walk through it and
see what that looks like so back to our
jupiter notebook and put the code in
there and let's go ahead and run that
code
take it just a moment and remember we
had the inline that way my graph shows
up on the inline here
and let's walk through the code and then
we'll look at this and see what that
means so make it a little bit bigger
there we go no reason not to use the
whole screen too big so we have here
from sk learn metrics import confusion
matrix
and that's just going to generate a set
of data that says i the prediction was
such the actual truth was either agreed
with it or is something different and
it's going to add up those numbers so we
can take a look and just see how well it
worked and we're going to set a variable
mat equal to confusion matrix we have
our test target our test data that was
not part of the training
very important in data science we always
keep our test data separate
otherwise it's not a valid model if we
can't properly test it with new data and
this is the labels we created from that
test data these are the ones that we
predict it's going to be so we go in and
we create our sn heat map the sns is our
seaborn which sits on top of the pi plot
so we create a sns dot heat map we take
our confusion matrix and it's going to
be
mat dot t and do we have other
variables that go into the sns.heat map
we're not going to go into detail what
all the variables mean the annotation
equals true that's what tells it to put
the numbers here so you have the 166 the
one the zero zero zero one format d and
c bar equals false have to do with the
uh format if you take those out you'll
see that some things disappear and then
the x tick labels and the y tick labels
those are our target names and you can
see right here that's the alt atheism
comp graphics comp osms windows dot
miscellaneous and then finally we have
our plt dot x label remember the sns or
the seaborn sits on top of our matplot
library our plt and so we want to just
tell that x label equals a true is is
true the labels are true and then the y
label is prediction label so
we say a true this is what it actually
is and the prediction is what we
predicted and let's look at this graph
because that's probably a little
confusing the way i rattled through it
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
go ahead and flip back to the slides
because they have a black background
they put in there that helps it shine a
little bit better so you can see the
graph a little bit easier so in reading
this graph what we want to look at is
how the color scheme has come out and
you'll see a line right down the middle
diagonally from upper left to bottom
right what that is is if you look at the
labels we have our predicted label on
the left and our true label on the right
those are the numbers where the
prediction and the true come together
and this is what we want to see is we
want to see those lit up that's what
that heat map does as you can see that
it did a good job of finding those data
and you'll notice that there's a couple
of red spots on there where it missed
you know it's a little confused we talk
about talk religion miscellaneous versus
talk politics miscellaneous social
religion christian versus alt atheism it
mislabeled some of those and those are
very similar topics so you could
understand why it might mislabel them
but overall it did a pretty good job if
we're going to create these models we
want to go ahead and be able to use them
so let's see what that looks like to do
this let's go ahead and create a
definition a function to run and we're
going to call this function let me just
expand that just a notch here there we
go i like mine in big letters predict
categories we want to predict the
category
we're going to send it s a string
and then we're sending it train equals
train we have our training model and
then we had our pipeline model equals
model this way we don't have to resend
these variables each time the definition
knows that because i said train equals
train and i put the equal for model and
then we're going to set the prediction
equal to the model.predict s so it's
going to send whatever
string we send to it it's going to push
that string through the pipeline the
model pipeline it's going to go through
and tokenize it and put it through the
tf idf convert that into numbers and
weights for all the different documents
and words and then i'll put that through
our naive bayes and from it we'll go
ahead and get our prediction we're going
to predict what value it is and so we're
going to return train dot target names
predict of zero and remember that the
train dot target names that's just
categories i could have just as easily
put categories in there dot predict of
zero so we're taking the prediction
which is a number and we're converting
it to an actual category we're
converting it from i don't know what the
actual numbers are but let's say zero
equals alt atheism
so we're going to convert that 0 to the
word or one maybe it equals comp
graphics so we're going to convert
number one into comp graphics that's all
that is and then we got to go ahead and
and then we need to go ahead and run
this so i load that up and then once i
run that we can start doing some
predictions let me go ahead and type in
predict category
and let's just do predict category jesus
christ and it comes back and says it's
social religion christian that's pretty
good
now note i didn't put print on this one
the nice things about the jupiter
notebook editor and a lot of inline
editors is if you just put the name of
the variable out as returning the
variable train.target underscore names
it'll automatically print that for you
in your own id you might have to put in
print let's see where else we can take
this and maybe you're a space science
buff so how about sending
load to
international space station
and if we run that
we get science space
or maybe you're a
automobile buff and let's do
oh they're going to tell me audi is
better than bmw but i'm going to do bmw
is better
than an audi so maybe your car buff and
we run that and you'll see it says
recreational i'm assuming that's what
rec stands for autos so i did a pretty
good job labeling that one how about if
we have something like a caption running
through there president of india and if
we run that
it comes up and says talk politics
miscellaneous
so when we take our definition our
function and we run all these things
through kudos we made it we were able to
correctly classify text into different
groups based on which category they
belong to using the naive bayes
classifier now we did throw in the
pipeline the tf idf vectorizer we threw
in the graphs those are all things that
you don't necessarily have to know to
understand the naive bayes setup or
classifier but they're important to know
one of the main uses for the naive bayes
is with the tf idf tokenizer vectorizer
where tokenizes the word and has labels
and we use the pipeline because you need
to push all that data through and it
makes it really easy and fast you don't
have to know those to understand naive
bayes but they certainly help for
understanding the industry and data
science and we can see our categorizer
or naive bayes classifier we were able
to predict the category religion space
motorcycles autos politics and properly
classify all these different things we
pushed into our prediction and our
trained model hello and welcome to the
session on k-means clustering i'm mohan
kumar from simply learn so what is
k-means clustering
k-means clustering is an unsupervised
learning algorithm in this case you
don't have labeled data unlike in
supervised learning so you have a set of
data and you want to group them and as
the name suggests you want to put them
into clusters which means objects that
are similar in nature similar in
characteristics need to be put together
so that's what k means clustering is all
about the term k is basically is a
number so we need to tell the system how
many clusters we need to perform so if k
is equal to two there will be two
clusters if k is equal to three three
clusters and so on and so forth that's
what the k stands for and of course
there is a way of finding out what is
the best or optimum value of k for a
given data we will look at that so that
is k means clustering so
let's take an example k-means clustering
is used in many many scenarios but let's
take an example of cricket the game of
cricket let's say you received
data of a lot of players from maybe all
over the country or all over the world
and this data has information about the
runs scored by the people ordered by the
player and the wickets taken by the
player and based on this information we
need to cluster this data into two
clusters batsman and bowlers so this is
an interesting example let's see how we
can perform this so we have the data
which consists of primarily two
characteristics which is the runs and
the wickets so the bowlers basically
take wickets and the batsmen score runs
there will be of course a few bowlers
who can
score some runs and similarly there will
be some batsmen who will who would have
taken a few wickets but with this
information we want to cluster those
players into batsmen and bowlers so how
does this work let's say this is how the
data is so there are information there
is information on the y-axis about the
run scored and on the x axis about the
wickets taken by the players so if we do
a quick plot this is how it would look
and
when we do the clustering we need to
have the clusters like shown in the
third diagram rtms we need to have a
cluster which consists of people who
have scored high runs which is basically
the batsman and then we need a cluster
with people who have taken a lot of
wickets which is typically the bowlers
there may be a certain amount of overlap
but we will not talk about it right now
so with k-means clustering we will have
here that means k is equal to 2 and we
will have two clusters such as batsman
and bowlers so how does this work the
way it works is the first step in
k-means clustering is the allocation of
two centroids randomly so two points are
assigned as so-called centroids so in
this case we want two clusters which
means k is equal to two so two points
have been randomly assigned as centroids
keep in mind
these points can be anywhere there are
random points they are not initially
they are not really the centroids
centroid means it's a central point of a
given data set but in this case when it
starts off it's not really the center
end okay so these points though in our
presentation here we have shown them one
point closer to these data points and
another closer to these data points they
can be assigned randomly anywhere okay
so that's the first step the next step
is to determine the distance of each of
the data points
from each of the
randomly assigned centroids so for
example we take this point and find the
distance from this centroid and the
distance from this center right this
point is taken and the distance is found
from this centroid and the center and so
on and so forth so
for every point the distance is measured
from both the centroids and then
whichever distance is less that point is
assigned to that centroid so for example
in this case visually it is very obvious
that all these data points are assigned
to this centroid and all these data
points are assigned to this centroid and
that's what is represented here in blue
color and in this yellow color the next
step is to actually determine
the central point or the actual centroid
for these two clusters so we have this
one
initial cluster this one initial cluster
but as you can see these points are not
really the centroid centroid means it
should be the central position of this
data set central position of this data
set so that is what needs to be
determined as the next step so the
central point of the actual centroid is
determined and the original randomly
allocated centroid is repositioned to
the actual centroid of these new
clusters and this process is actually
repeated now what might happen is some
of these points may get reallocated in
our example that is not happening
probably but it may so happen that the
distance is found between each of these
data points once again with these
centroids and if there is if it is
required some points may be reallocated
we will see that in a later example but
for now we will keep it simple so this
process is continued till the centroid
repositioning stops and that is our
final cluster so this is our so after
iteration we come to this position this
situation where the centroid doesn't
need any more repositioning and that
means our algorithm has converged
convergence has occurred and we have the
cluster two clusters we have the
clusters with a centroid so this process
is
repeated the process of calculating the
distance and repositioning the centroid
is repeated till the repositioning stops
which means that the algorithm has
converged and we have the final cluster
with the data points and the centroids
so this is what you're going to learn
from this session we will talk about the
types of clustering what is k-means
clustering application of k-means
clustering k-means clustering is done
using distance measure so we will talk
about the common distance measures and
then we will talk about how k-means
clustering works and go into the details
of k-means clustering algorithm and then
we will end with a demo and a use case
for k-means clustering so let's begin
first of all what are the types of
clustering there are primarily two
categories of clustering hierarchical
clustering and then partitional
clustering and each of these categories
are further subdivided into
agglomerative and divisive clustering
and k-means and fuzzy c means clustering
let's take a quick look at
what each of these types of clustering
are
in hierarchical clustering the clusters
have a tree-like structure and
hierarchical clustering is further
divided into agglomerative and divisive
the glomerulative clustering is a
bottom-up approach we begin with each
element as a separate cluster and merge
them into successively larger clusters
so for example we have abcdef we start
by combining b and c form one cluster d
e and e form one more then we combine d
e and f one more bigger cluster and then
add bc to that and then finally a to it
compared to that divisive clustering or
divisive clustering is the top-down
approach we begin with the whole set and
proceed to divide it into successively
smaller clusters so we have abcdef we
first take that as a single cluster and
then break it down
into a b c d e and f
then we have partitional clustering
split into two subtypes k means
clustering and fuzzy c means in k means
clustering the objects are divided into
the number of clusters mentioned by the
number k that's where the k comes from
so if we say k is equal to 2 the objects
are divided into two clusters c1 and c2
and the way it is done is the features
or characteristics
are compared and all objects having
similar characteristics are clubbed
together so that's how k means
clustering is done we will see it in
more detail as we move forward and fuzzy
c means is very similar to k-means in
the sense that it clubs objects that
have similar characteristics together
but while in k-means clustering two
objects cannot belong to or any object a
single object cannot belong to two
different clusters in c means objects
can belong to more than one cluster so
that is the primary difference between
k-means and fuzzy c means
so what are some of the applications of
k-means clustering k-means clustering is
used in a variety of examples or variety
of business cases in real life
starting from academic performance
diagnostic systems search engines and
wireless sensor networks and many more
so let us take a little deeper look at
each of these examples academic
performance so based on the scores of
the students students are categorized
into a b c and so on clustering forms a
backbone of search engines when a search
is performed the search results need to
be grouped together the search engines
very often use clustering to do this
and similarly in case of wireless sensor
networks the clustering algorithm plays
the role of finding the cluster heads
which collects all the data in its
respective cluster so clustering
especially k means clustering uses
distance measure so let's take a look at
what is distance measure so while these
are the different types of clustering in
this video we will focus on k-means
clustering so distance measure tells
how similar some objects are so the
similarity is measured using what is
known as distance measure and what are
the various types of distance measures
there is euclidean distance there is
manhattan distance then we have squared
euclidean distance measure and cosine
distance measure these are some of the
distance measures supported by k-means
clustering let's take a look at each of
these
what is euclidean distance measure this
is nothing but the distance between two
points so we have learnt in high school
how to find the distance between two
points this is a little sophisticated
formula for that but we know a simpler
one is square root of y2 minus y1 whole
square plus x2 minus x1 whole square so
this is an extension of that formula so
that is the euclidean distance between
two points what is the squared euclidean
distance measure it's nothing but the
square of the euclidean distance as the
name suggests so instead of taking the
square root
we leave the square as it is and then we
have manhattan distance measure in case
of manhattan distance it is the sum of
the distances across the x-axis and the
y-axis
and note that we are taking the absolute
value so that the negative values don't
come into play so that is the manhattan
distance measure then we have cosine
distance measure in this case we take
the angle between the two vectors formed
by joining the points from the origin so
that is the cosine distance measure okay
so that was a quick overview about the
various distance measures that are
supported by k-means now let's go and
check how exactly k-means clustering
works
okay so this is how k-means clustering
works this is like a flowchart of the
whole process there is a starting point
and then we specify the number of
clusters that we want now there are a
couple of ways of doing this we can do
by trial and error so we specify a
certain number maybe k is equal to 3 or
4 or 5 to start with and then as we
progress we keep changing until we get
the best clusters or there is a
technique called elbow technique whereby
we can determine the value of k what
should be the best value of k how many
clusters should be formed so once we
have the value of k we specify that and
then the system will assign
that many centroids so it picks randomly
that to start with randomly that many
points that are considered to be the
centroids of these clusters and then it
measures the distance of each of the
data points from these centroids and
assigns those points to the
corresponding centroid from which the
distance is minimum so each data point
will be assigned to the centroid which
is closest to it and thereby we have k
number of initial clusters however this
is not the final clusters the next step
it does is
for the new groups for the clusters that
have been formed it calculates the main
position thereby calculates the new
centroid position the position of the
centroid moves compared to the randomly
allocated one so it's an iterative
process once again the distance of each
point is measured from this new centroid
point and if required the data points
are reallocated to the new centroids and
the mean position or the new centroid is
calculated once again if the centroid
moves then the iteration continues which
means the convergence has not happened
the clustering has not converged so as
long as there is a movement of the
centroid this iteration keeps happening
but once the centroid stops moving which
means that the cluster has converged or
the clustering process has converged
that will be the end result so now we
have the final position of the centroid
and the data points are allocated
accordingly to the closest centroid i
know it's a little difficult to
understand from this simple flowchart so
let's do a little bit of visualization
and see if we can explain it better
let's take an example if we have a data
set for a grocery shop so let's say we
have a data set for a grocery shop and
now we want to find out how many
clusters this has to be spread across so
how do we find the optimum number of
clusters there is a technique called the
elbow method so when these clusters are
formed there is a parameter called
within sum of squares and the lower this
value is the better the cluster is that
means
all these points are very close to each
other so we use this within sum of
squares as a measure to find the optimum
number of clusters that can be formed
for a given data set so we create
clusters or we let the system create
clusters of a variety of numbers maybe
of 10
10 clusters and for each value of k the
within ss is measured and the value of k
which has the least amount of within ss
or wss
that is taken as the optimum value of k
so this is the diagrammatic
representation so we have on the y axis
the within sum of squares or wss and on
the x axis we have the number of
clusters so as you can imagine if you
have k is equal to 1 which means all the
data points are in a single cluster the
within s value will be very high because
they are probably scattered all over the
moment you split it into two there will
be a drastic fall in the within ss value
that's what is represented here but then
as the value of k increases the decrease
the rate of decrease
will not be so high it will continue to
decrease but probably the rate of
decrease will not be high so that gives
us an idea so from here we get an idea
for example the optimum value of k
should be either 2 or 3 or at the most 4
but beyond that
increasing the number of clusters is not
dramatically changing the value in wss
because that pretty much gets stabilized
okay now that we have got the value of k
and let's assume that these are our
delivery points the next step is
basically
to assign two
centroids randomly so let's say c1 and
c2 are the centroids assigned randomly
now the distance of each
location from the centroid is measured
and each point is assigned to the
centroid which is closest to it so for
example
these points are very obvious that these
are closest to c1 whereas this point is
far away from c2 so these points will be
assigned which are close to c1 will be
assigned to c1 and these points or
locations which are close to c2 will be
assigned to c2 and then so this is the
how the initial grouping is done this is
part of c1 and this is part of c2 then
the next step is to calculate the actual
centroid of this data because remember
c1 and c2 are not the centroids they
have been
randomly assigned points and only thing
that has been done was the data points
which are closest to them have been
assigned
but now in this step the actual centroid
will be calculated which may be for each
of these data sets somewhere in the
middle so that's like the main point
that will be calculated and the centroid
will actually be positioned or
repositioned there
same with c2
so the new centroid for this group is c2
in this new position and c1 is in this
new position
once again the distance of each of the
data points is calculated from these
centroids now remember it's not
necessary that the distance still
remains the or each of these data points
still remain in the same group by
recalculating the distance it may be
possible that some points get
reallocated like so you see this
so this point earlier was closer to c2
because c2 was here
but after recalculating repositioning it
is observed that this is closer to c1
than c2 so this is the new grouping so
some points will be reassigned
and again the centroid will be
calculated and if the centroid doesn't
change so that is a repetitive process
iterative process and if the centroid
doesn't change once the centroid stops
changing that means the algorithm has
converged and this is our final cluster
with this as the centroid c1 and c2 as
the centroids these data points as a
part of each cluster so i hope this
helps in understanding the whole process
iterative process of k-means clustering
so let's take a look at
the k-means clustering algorithm let's
say we have x1 x2 x3 n number of points
as our inputs and we want to split this
into k clusters or we want to create k
clusters so the first step is to
randomly pick k points and call them
centroids they are not real centroids
because centroid is supposed to be a
center point but they are just called
centroids and we calculate the distance
of each and every input point from each
of the centroids so the distance of x1
from c1 from c2 c3 each of the distances
we calculate and then find out which
distance is the lowest and assign x1 to
that particular random centroid repeat
that process for x2 calculate its
distance from each of the centroids c1
c2 c3 up to ck and find which is the
lowest distance and assign x2 to that
particular centroid same with x 3 and so
on so that is the first round of
assignment that is done now we have k
groups because there are we have
assigned the value of k so there are k
centroids and so there are k groups all
these inputs have been split into k
groups however remember we pick the
centroids randomly so they are not real
centroids so now what we have to do we
have to calculate the actual centroids
for each of these groups which is like
the mean position which means that the
position of the randomly selected
centroids will now change
and they will be the main positions of
these newly formed k groups and once
that is done we once again repeat this
process of calculating the distance
right so this is what we are doing as a
part of step four we repeat step two
and three so we again calculate the
distance of x1
from
the centroid c1
c2 c3 and then c which is the lowest
value and assign x1 to that
calculate the distance of x2 from c1 c2
c3 or whatever
up to ck and find whichever is the
lowest distance and assign x2 to that
centroid and so on in this process there
may be some reassignment x1 pro was
probably assigned to cluster c2 and
after doing this calculation maybe now
x1 is assigned to c1 so that kind of
reallocation may happen so we repeat the
steps 2 and 3 till the position of the
centroids don't change or stop changing
and that's when we have convergence
so let's take a detailed look at it at
each of these steps so we randomly pick
k cluster centers we call them centroids
because they are not initially they are
not really the centroids so we let us
name them c1 c2 up to ck and then step
two we assign each data point to the
closest center so what we do we
calculate the distance of each x value
from each c value so the distance
between x1 c1 distance between x1 c2 x1
c3 and then we find which is the lowest
value right that's the minimum value we
find
and assign x1 to that particular
centroid then we go next to x2 find the
distance of x2 from c1 x2 from c2
x2 from c3 and so on up to ck and then
assign it to the point or to the
centroid which has the lowest value and
so on so that is step number two in step
number three we now find the actual
centroid for each group so what has
happened
as a part of step number two
we now have all the points all the data
points
grouped into k groups because we we
wanted to create k clusters right so we
have k groups each one may be having a
certain number of input values they need
not be equally distributed by the way
based on the distance we will have k
groups but remember the initial values
of the c1 c2 were not really the
centroids of these groups right we
assigned them randomly so now in step 3
we actually calculate the centroid of
each group which means the original
point which we thought was the centroid
will shift to the new position which is
the actual centroid for each of these
groups okay and we again calculate the
distance so we go back to step two which
is what we calculate again the distance
of each of these points from the newly
positioned centroids and if required we
reassign these points to the new
centroids so as i said earlier there may
be a reallocation so we now have a new
set or a new group we still have k
groups
but the number of items and the actual
assignment may be different from what
was in
step
two here okay so that might change then
we perform step three once again to find
the new centroid of this new group so we
have again a new set of clusters new
centroids and new assignments
we repeat this step two again once again
we find and then it is possible that
after iterating through three or four or
five times the centroid will stop moving
in the sense that when you calculate the
new value of the centroid that will be
same as the original value or there will
be very marginal change so that is when
we say convergence has occurred and that
is our final cluster that's the
formation of the final cluster
all right so let's see a couple of demos
of k-means clustering we will actually
see some live demos in python notebook
using pattern notebook but before that
let's find out what's the problem that
we are trying to solve the problem
statement is let's say walmart wants to
open a chain of stores across the state
of florida and
it wants to find the optimal store
locations now the issue here is if they
open too many stores close to each other
obviously the they will not make profit
but
if they if the stores are too far apart
then they will not have enough sales
so how do they optimize this now
for an organization like walmart which
is an e-commerce giant
they already have the addresses of their
customers in their database so they can
actually use this information or this
data and use k-means clustering to find
the optimal location now before we go
into the python notebook and show you
the live code
i wanted to take you through very
quickly a summary of
the code in the slides and then we will
go into the python notebook so in this
block we are basically
importing all the required libraries
like numpy
matplotlib and so on
and we are loading the data that is
available in the form of let's say the
addresses
for simplicity sake we will just take
them as some data points then the next
thing we do is quickly do a scatter plot
to see
how they are
related to each other with respect to
each other so in the scatter plot we see
that there are a few distinct
groups
already being formed so you can actually
get an idea about how the cluster would
look and how many clusters what is the
optimal number of clusters and then
starts the actual
k-means clustering process
so we will assign each of these points
to the centroids and then check whether
they are
the optimal distance which is the
shortest distance and assign each of the
points data points to the centroids and
then go through this iterative process
till the whole process converges and
finally we get an output like this so we
have four distinct clusters
and
which is if we can say that this is how
the population is probably distributed
across florida state and
the centroids are
like the location where the store should
be the optimum location where the store
should be so that's the way we determine
the best locations for the store and
that's how we can help walmart find the
best locations for the stores in florida
so now let's
take this into python notebook let's see
how this looks when we are running
running the code live all right so this
is the code for k-means clustering in
jupyter notebook we have a few examples
here which we will demonstrate how k
means clustering is used and even there
is a small implementation of k-means
clustering as well okay so let's get
started okay so this block is basically
importing the various libraries that are
required like matplotlib and numpy and
so on and so forth which would be used
as a part of the code then we are going
and creating blobs which are similar to
clusters now this is a very neat feature
which is available in scikit-learn make
blobs is a nice feature which creates
clusters of data sets so that's a
wonderful functionality that is readily
available for us to create some test
data kind of thing okay so that's
exactly what we are doing here we are
using make blobs and we can specify how
many clusters we want so centers we are
mentioning here so it will go ahead and
so we just mentioned four so it will go
ahead and create some test data for us
and this is how it looks as you can see
visually also we can figure out that
there are four distinct classes or
clusters in this data set
and that is what make blobs actually
provides
now from
here onwards we will basically
run the standard k-means functionality
that is readily available so we really
don't have to implement k-means itself
the k-means functionality or the
function is readily available you just
need to feed the data and will create
the clusters so this is the code for
that
we import k-means and then
we create an instance of k means and we
specify the value of k this n underscore
clusters is the value of k remember k
means in k means k is basically the
number of clusters that you want to
create and it is a integer value so this
is where we are specifying that so we
have k is equal to 4
and so that instance is created
we take that instance and as
with any other machine learning
functionality fit is what we use the
function or the method rather fit is
what we use to train the model here
there is no real training kind of thing
but that's the call okay so we are
calling fit and what we are doing here
we are just passing the data so x has
these values the data that has been
created
right so that is what we are passing
here
and
this will go ahead and create the
clusters
and then we are using
after doing uh fit we run the predict
which basically assigns for each of
these observations which cluster where
it belongs to all right so it will name
the clusters maybe this is cluster 1
this is 2 3 and so on or i will actually
start from 0 cluster 0 1 2 and 3 maybe
and then for each of the observations it
will assign based on which cluster it
belongs to it will assign a value so
that is stored in
y underscore k means when we call
predict that is what it does
and we can take a quick look at these
y underscore k means or with the cluster
numbers that have been assigned for each
observation so this is the cluster
number assigned for observation 1 maybe
this is for observation 2 observation 3
and so on so we have harmony about i
think 300 samples right so all the 300
samples there are 300 values here each
of them the cluster number is given and
the cluster number goes from 0 to 3. so
there are four clusters so the numbers
go from 0 1 2 3. so that's what is seen
here okay now so this was a quick
example of generating some dummy data
and then clustering that okay and this
can be applied if you have proper data
you can just load it up into x for
example here and then run the cable so
this is the central part of the k-means
clustering program example so you
basically create an instance and you
mention how many customers you want by
specifying this parameter and underscore
clusters and that is also the value of k
and then pass the data to get the values
now the next section of this code is the
implementation of a k-means now this is
kind of a rough implementation of the
k-means algorithm so we will just walk
you through i will walk you through the
code uh at each step what it is doing
and then we will see a couple of more
examples of how k means clustering
can be used in maybe some real life
examples real life use cases all right
so in this case here what we are doing
is basically implementing the k means
clustering and there is a function or a
library calculates for a given two pairs
of points it will calculate the the
distance between them and see which one
is the closest and so on so this is like
this is pretty much like what k means
does right so it calculates the distance
of each point or each data set from
predefined centroid and then based on
whichever is the lowest this particular
data point is assigned to that centroid
so that is basically available as a
standard function and we will be using
that here so as explained in the slides
the first step that is done in case of
k-means clustering is to randomly assign
some centroids so as a first step we
randomly allocate a couple of centroids
which we call here we are calling as
centers
and then we put this in a loop and we
take it through an iterative process
for each of the data points we first
find out using this function pairwise
distance argument for each of the points
we find out which one which center or
which randomly selected centroid is the
closest and accordingly we assign the
data or the data point to that
particular centroid or cluster and once
that is done for all the data points
we calculate the new centroid by finding
out the mean position which is the
center position right so we calculate
the new centroid and then we check if
the new centroid is the coordinates or
the position is the same as the previous
centroid
the positions we will compare
and if it is the same that means the
process has converged so remember we do
this process till the centroids or the
centroid doesn't move anymore right so
the centroid gets relocated each time
this reallocation is done so the moment
it doesn't change anymore the position
of the centroid doesn't change anymore
we know that convergence has occurred so
till then so you see here this is like
an infinite loop while true is an
infinite loop it only breaks when the
centers are the same the new center and
the old center positions are the same
and once that is done we return the
centers and the labels now of course as
explained this is not a very
sophisticated and advanced
implementation very basic implementation
because one of the flaws in this is that
sometimes what happens is the centroid
the position
will keep moving but in the change will
be very minor so in that case also with
that is actually convergence right so
for example the change is 0.0001 we can
consider that as convergence otherwise
what will happen is this will either
take forever or it will be never ending
so that's a small flaw here so that is
something additional checks may have to
be added here but again as mentioned
this is not the most sophisticated
implementation
this is like a kind of a rough
implementation of the k-means clustering
okay so if we execute this code this is
what we get as the output so this is the
definition of this particular function
and then we call that find underscore
clusters and we pass our data x and the
number of clusters which is four
and if we run that and plot it this is
the output that we get so this is of
course each cluster is represented by a
different color so we have a cluster in
green color yellow color and so on and
so forth and these big points here these
are the centroids this is the final
position of the centroids and as you can
see visually also this appears like a
kind of a center of all these points
here right similarly this is like the
center of all these points here and so
on so this is the example or this is an
example of an implementation of k-means
clustering and
next we will move on to see a couple of
examples of how k-means clustering is
used in maybe some real-life scenarios
or use cases in the next example or demo
we are going to see how we can use
k-means clustering to perform color
compression we will take a couple of
images so there will be two examples and
we will try to use k-means clustering to
compress the colors this is a common
situation
in image processing when you have an
image with millions of
colors but then you cannot render it on
some devices which may not have enough
memory so that is the
scenario where where something like this
can be used
so
before again we go into the python
notebook let's take a look at quickly
the the code
as usual we import the libraries and
then we import the image and
then we will flatten it so the reshaping
is basically we have the image
information is stored in the form of
pixels and if the image is like for
example 427 by 640 and it has three
colors so that's the overall dimension
of the of the initial image we just
reshape it and
then feed this to our algorithm and this
will then create clusters
of only 16 clusters so this this colors
there are millions of colors
and now we need to bring it down to 16
colors so we use k is equal to 16
and
this is how when we visualize this is
how it looks there are these are all
about 16 million possible colors the
input color space has 16 million
possible colors and we just
some compress it to 16 colors so this is
how it would look when we compress it to
16 colors and this is how the original
image looks and
after compression to 16 colors this is
how the new image looks as you can see
there is not a lot of
information that has been lost though
the image quality is definitely reduced
a little bit
so this is
an example which we are going to now see
in python notebook let's go into the
python node and once again as always we
will import some libraries and
load this image called flower.jpg
okay so let we load that and this is how
it looks this is the original image
which has i think 16 million colors and
this is the shape of this image which is
basically what is the
shape is nothing but the overall size
right so this is 427 pixel by 640 pixel
and then there are three layers which is
this three basically is for rgb which is
red green blue so color image will have
that right so that is the shape of this
now what we need to do is data let's
take a look at how data is looking so
let me just create a new cell and show
you
what is in data basically we have
captured this information
so data is what let me just show you
here
all right so
let's take a look at
china what are the values in china
and if we see here this is how the data
is stored this is nothing but the pixel
values okay so this is like a matrix
and each one has about for this 427 by
640 pixels all right so this is how it
looks now the issue here is these values
are large the numbers are a large so we
need to normalize them to between zero
and one right so that's why we will
basically create one more variable which
is data which will contain the values
between 0 and 1 and the way to do that
is divide by 255 so we divide china by
255 and we get the new values in data so
let's just run this piece of code and
this is the shape so we now have also
yeah what we have done is we changed
using reshape we converted into the
three-dimensional into a two-dimensional
data set and let us also take a look at
how
let me just insert
uh probably a cell here
and take a look at how data is looking
all right so this is how data is looking
and now you see this is
the values are between zero and one
right so if you earlier noticed in case
of china the values were large numbers
now everything is between zero and one
this is one of the things we need to do
all right so after that the next thing
that we need to do is to visualize this
and
we can take random set of maybe 10 000
points and plot it and check and see how
this looks let us just plot this
and so this is how the original the
color the pixel distribution is these
are two plots one is red against green
and another is red against blue and this
is the original distribution of the
color so then what we will do is we will
use k means clustering to create just 16
clusters for the various colors and then
apply that to the image now
what will happen is since the data is
large because there are millions of
colors using regular k means maybe a
little time consuming so there is
another version of k-means which is
called mini batch gaming so we will use
that which is which processes in the
overall concept remains the same but
this basically processes it in smaller
batches that's the only thing okay so
the results will pretty much be the same
so let's go ahead and execute this piece
of code and also visualize this so that
we can see that there are these this is
how the 16 colors
would look so this is red against green
and this is red against blue there is uh
quite a bit of similarity between this
original color schema and the new one
right so it doesn't look very very
completely different or anything like
that now we apply this the newly created
colors to the image and we can take a
look uh how this is looking now we can
compare both the images so this is our
original image and this is our new image
so as you can see there is not a lot of
information that has been
lost it pretty much looks like the
original image yes we can see that for
example here there is a little bit it
appears a little dullish compared to
this one right because we kind of took
off some of the finer details of the
color but
overall the high level information has
been maintained at the same time the
main advantage is that now this can be
this is an image which can be rendered
on a device which may not be that very
sophisticated now let's take one more
example with a different image in the
second example we will take an image of
the summer palace in china and we repeat
the same process this is a
high definition color image with
millions of colors and also
three dimensional
now we will reduce that to 16 colors
using k means clustering
and
we do the same process like before we
reshape it and then we cluster the
colors to 16
and then we render the image once again
and we will see that the color the
quality of the image
slightly deteriorates as you can see
here this has much finer details in this
which are probably missing here but then
that's the compromise because there are
some devices which may not be able to
handle
this kind of high density images
so let's run this chord in python
notebook all right so let's apply the
same technique for another picture which
is uh even more intricate and has
probably much complicated color schema
so this is the image now once again we
can take a look at the shape which is
427 by 640 by 3
and this is the new data would look
somewhat like this compared to the
flower image so we have some new values
here
and we will also bring this as you can
see the numbers are much big so we will
much bigger so we will now have to
scale them down to values between 0 and
1 and that is done by
dividing by 255 so let's go ahead and do
that
and reshape it okay so we get a
two-dimensional matrix
and we will then as a next step we will
go ahead and visualize this how it looks
does the 16 colors and this is basically
how it would look 16 million colors and
now we can
create the clusters
out of this the 16
k means clusters we will create so this
is how the distribution of the pixels
would look with 16 colors
and then we go ahead and
apply this
and visualize how it is looking for with
the new just the 16 color so once again
as you can see this looks much richer in
color but at the same time and this
probably doesn't have as we can see it
doesn't look as rich as this one but
nevertheless the information is not lost
the shape and all that stuff and this
can be also rendered on a slightly a
device which is probably not that
sophisticated okay so that's pretty much
it so we have seen two examples of how
color compression can be done uh using
k-means clustering
and we have also seen in the previous
examples of how to implement k-means the
code to roughly how to implement k-means
clustering and we use some sample data
using
blob to just execute the k-means
clustering in this video we are going to
talk about what time series forecasting
is and
this is a two-part series and in this
first video we will explain what is time
series analysis and in the second part
we will actually demonstrate it in r
studio so this is what we're going to
cover in this video
first of all why time series and then
we'll talk about what exactly is time
series data and then what are the
components of the time series data like
for example the trend seasonality and so
on and then we will explain what each of
these components are we'll also talk
about when we should not use time series
analysis
and
we will then explain what is
stationary data in terms of time series
what is the significance of stationary
data and typically time series data is
not stationary so how to make time
series data stationary and then we will
take you through an example of a car
sales
data and we will show you how to solve
the time series or how to perform the
time series analysis
manually without using the tool and then
we will do in the second part we will
actually use r and we will
do the same thing once again in r okay
so without any further delay let's get
started and so why exactly
do we need to do time series analysis
typically we would like to predict
something in the future and
it could be stock prices it could be the
sales or
anything that needs to be predicted into
the future that is when we
use time series analysis
so it is um as the name suggests it is
forecasting and typically when we say
predict it need not be into the future
in machine learning and data analysis
when we talk about predicting we are not
necessarily talking about the future but
in time series analysis we typically
predict the future so we have some past
data and we want to predict the future
that is when we perform time series
analysis so what are some of the
examples uh it could be daily stock
price the shares as we talk about or it
could be the interest rates weekly
interest rates or sales figures of a
company so these are some of the
examples where we use time series data
we have historical data which is
dependent on time and then based on that
we create a model to predict the future
so what exactly is uh time series so
time series data has time as one of the
components as the name suggests so in
this example let's say this is the stock
price data and
one of the components so there are two
columns here column b is
price and column a is basically the time
information in this case the time is a
day so that primarily the closing price
of a particular stock has been recorded
on a daily basis so this is the time
series data and the time interval is
obviously a day time series or time
intervals can be daily weekly hourly or
even sometimes there is something like a
sensor data it could be every few
milliseconds or microseconds as well so
the size of the time intervals can vary
but they are fixed so if i'm saying that
it is daily data then the interval is
fixed as uh daily if i'm saying this
data is an hourly data then it is the
data is captured every hour and so on so
the time intervals are fixed this
interval itself you can decide based on
what kind of data we are capturing so
this is a graphical representation the
previous one here we saw the table
representation and this is how the plot
the data so on the y-axis is let's say
the price or the the stock price and
x-axis is the time so against time if
you plot it this is how a time series
graph would look so as the name suggests
what is time series data time series
data is basically a sequence of data
that is recorded over a specific
intervals of time and based on the past
values so if we want to do an analysis
of time series past data we try to
forecast a future and
again as the name suggests it is time
series data which means that it is time
dependent so time is one of the
components of this data time series data
consists of primarily four components
one is the trend then we have the
seasonality then cyclicity and then last
but not least irregularity or the random
component sometimes is also referred to
as a random component so let's see what
each of these components are so what is
trend trend is overall
change or the pattern of the data which
means that the data may be let me just
uh pull up a pen and
show you so let's say you have a data
set somewhat like this a time series
data set somewhat like this all right
so what is the overall trend there is an
overall
trend which is upward trend as we call
it here right so it is not like it is
continuously increasing there are times
when it is dipping then there are times
when it is increasing then it is
decreasing and so on but overall over a
period of time from the time we start
recording to the time we end there is a
trend right there is an upward trend in
this case so the trend need not always
be upwards there could be a downward
trend as well so for example here there
is a downward trend right so this is
basically what is a trend overall
whether the data is increasing or
decreasing all right then we have the
next component which is seasonality what
is seasonality seasonality as the name
suggests once again changes
over a period of time and periodic
changes right so there is a certain
pattern
let's take the sales of warm clothes for
example so if we plot it along the
months so let's say january february
march april may june july and then let's
say it goes up to december okay so this
is our
december a d i will just mark it as t
and then you again have jan feb march
and then you get another december okay
and just for simplicity let's mark this
as decembers as the end of the year and
then one more december
okay so what will happen when if you're
talking about warm clothes what happens
the sales of warm clothes will increase
probably around december when it is cold
and then they will come down and then
again
around december again they will increase
and then the sales will come down and
then there will be again an increase and
then they will come down and then again
an increase and then they will come down
let's see this is the sales pattern so
you see here there is a trend as well
there is an upward trend right the sales
are increasing over let's say these are
multiple years this is for year one this
is for year two this is for year three
and so on so for multiple years overall
the trend there is an upward trend the
sales are increasing but it is not a
continuous increase right so there is a
certain pattern so what is happening
what is the pattern every
december the sales are increasing or
they are peaking for that particular
year right then there is a new year
again when december approaches the sales
are increasing again when december
approaches the sales are increasing and
so on and so forth so this is known as
seasonality so there is a certain
fluctuation
which is
which is periodic in nature so this is
known as seasonality then cyclicity what
is cyclicity now cyclicity is somewhat
similar to seasonality but here the
duration between two cycles is much
longer so seasonality typically is
referred to as an annual kind of a
sequence like for example we saw here so
it is pretty much like every year in the
month of december the sales are
increasing however cyclicity what
happens is first of all the duration is
pretty much not fixed and the duration
or the gap length of time between two
cycles can be much longer so recession
is an example so we had let's say
recession in 2001 or 2002 perhaps and
then we had one in 2008
and then we had probably in 2000 2012
and so on and so forth so it is not like
every year this happens probably so
there is usually when we say recession
there is a slump and then it recovers
and then there is a slump and then it
recovers and probably there is another
bigger slump and so on right so you see
here this is similar to seasonality but
first of all this length is much more
than a year
right that is number one and it is not
fixed as well it is not like every four
years or every six years that duration
is not fixed so the
duration can vary at the same time the
gap between two cycles is much longer
compared to
seasonality all right so then what is
irregularity irregularity is like the
random component of the time series data
so there is like you have part which is
the trend which tells whether the
overall it is increasing or decreasing
then you have cyclicity and seasonality
which is like kind of a specific pattern
right
then there is a cyclicity which is again
a pattern but at much longer intervals
plus there is a random component so
which is not really which cannot be
accounted for very easily right so there
will be a random component which can be
really random as the name suggests right
so that is the irregularity component so
these are the various components of time
series data yes there are conditions
where we cannot use time series analysis
right so is it can we do time series
analysis with any kind of data no not
really so what are the situations where
we are
we cannot do time series analysis so
there will be some data which is
collected over a period of time but it's
really not changing so
it will not really not make sense to
perform any time series analysis over it
right for example like this one so if we
take x as the time and y as the value of
whatever the output we are talking about
and if the y value is constant there is
really no analysis that you can do
leave alone time series analysis right
so that is one another possibility is
yes there is a change but it is changing
as per a very fixed function like a sine
wave or a cos wave again time series
analysis will not make sense in this
kind of a situation because there is a
definite pattern here there is a
definite function that the data is
following so it will not make sense to
do a time series analysis now before
performing any time series analysis
the data has to be stationary and
typically time series data is not
stationary so in which case you need to
make the data stationary before we apply
any models like arima model or any of
these right so what exactly is
stationary data and what is meant by
stationary data let us take a look first
of all what is non-stationary data time
series data if you recall from one of my
earlier slides we said that time series
data has the following four components
the trend seasonality cyclicity and
random random component or irregularity
right so if these components are present
in time series data it is non-stationary
which means that typically these
components will be present therefore
most of the time a time series data that
is collected raw data is non-stationary
data so it has to be changed to
stationary data before we apply any of
these algorithms all right so a
non-stationary time series data would
look like this which means like for
example here there is an upward trend
the seasonality component is there and
also the random component and so on so
if the data is not stationary then the
time series forecasting will be affected
so you cannot really perform a time
series forecasting on a non-stationary
data so how do we differentiate between
a stationary and a non-stationary time
series data typically or technically one
is of course you can do it visually in
non-stationary data the the data will be
more flattish seasonality will of course
be there but the trend will not be there
so the data may if we plot that it may
appear somewhat like this right it's a
horizontal line along the horizontal
line you will see compared to the
original data which was there was an
upward trend so it was changing somewhat
like this right so this is
non-stationary data and this is our
stationary data would look visually what
does this mean technically this means
that the stationarity of the data
depends on a few things what the mean
the variance and the covariance so these
are the three components on which the
stationarity of the data depends so
let's take a look at what each of these
are for stationary data the mean should
not be a function of time which means
that the mean should pretty much remain
constant over a period of time right so
there is there shouldn't be any change
so this is how the stationary data would
look and this is how a non-stationary
data would look as shown in the previous
slide as well so here the mean is
increasing that means there is an upward
trend okay so that is one part of it and
then the variance of the series should
not be also a function of time so the
variance also should be pretty much
common or
should be constant rather uh so this is
a
if we visually we take a look this is
how time series stationaries data would
look where the variance is not changing
here the variance is changing therefore
this is non-stationary and we cannot
apply type series forecasting on this
kind of data similarly the covariance
which is basically of the ith term and
the i plus m term should not be a
function of time as well so covariance
is nothing but not only the variance at
the i-th term but the relation between
the variance of the ith term and i plus
meth or the i plus nth term so as again
once again visually this is how it would
look if the covariance is also changing
with respect to time so these are the
three all three components should be
pretty much constant and that is when
you have stationary data and in order to
perform time series analysis the data
should be stationary okay so let's take
a look at uh the concept of moving
average or the method of moving average
and let's see how it works we'll do
simple calculations so let's say this is
our sample data we have the data for
three months uh january february march
the sales in hundreds of in thousands
rather not hundreds thousands of dollars
is given here and now we want to find
the moving average so how do we find the
moving average we call it as moving
average three so moving average three is
nothing but you take three of the values
or the readings add them up and uh
divide by three basically the way we
take a mean or average of the three
values so that is as simple as that so
that's the average first of all so what
is moving average moving averages if you
now have a series of data you keep
taking the three values the next three
values and then you take the average of
that and then the next three values and
so on and so forth so that is how you
take the moving average so let's take a
little more detailed example of car
sales so this is how we have the car
sales data for the entire year let's say
so
rather for four years so year one we
have for each quarter quarter one two
three four and then year two quarter one
to three four and so on and so forth so
this is how we have sales data of a
particular car let's say or a showroom
and
we want to forecast for year five so we
have the data for four years we now want
to focus for the fifth year let's see
how it works first of all if we plot the
data as it is uh taken the raw data this
is how it would look and uh what do you
think it is is it stationary no right
because there is a trend upward trend so
this is not a stationary data so we um
we need to later we will see how to make
it stationary but to start with just an
example we will not worry about it for
now we will just go ahead and manually
do the forecasting using what is known
as moving average method okay so we are
not applying any algorithm or anything
like that in the next video we will see
how to apply an algorithm how to make it
stationary and so on all right so
um here we see that all the
three or four components that we talked
about
are there there is a trend there is a
seasonality and then of course there is
some random component as well cyclicity
may not be it is possible that cyclicity
is not applicable in all the situations
for sales especially there may not be
unless you're taking a sales for maybe
20 30 years cyclicity may not come into
play so we will just consider uh
primarily the trend seasonality and
irregularity right so random it is also
known as random irregularity right so we
were calling the random or irregularity
component so these are the three main
components typically in this case we
will talk about so this is the trend
component and
we will see how to do these calculations
so let's take a look
re-draw the table
including the time code we will add
another column which is the time code
and
this is the column and we'll just number
it like 1 2 3 4 up to 16. the rest of
the data remains the same okay so we
will do the calculations now now let us
do the moving average calculations um or
ma4 as we call it for each year so we
take all the four quarters and we take
an average of that so if we add up these
four values and divide by four you get
the moving average of 3.4 so we start by
putting the value here so that will be
for the third quarter let's say one two
three the third quarter then we will go
on to the next one so we take the next
four values as you see here and take the
average of that which is the moving
average for the next quarter and so on
and so forth now if we just do the
moving average
it is not centered so what we do is we
basically add one more column and we
calculate the centered moving average as
shown here so here what we do is we take
the average of two values and then just
adding these values here so for example
the first value for the third quarter is
actually the average of the third and
the fourth quarter so we have 3.5 now it
gets centered so similarly the next
value would be 3.6 plus 3.9 divided by 2
so which is 3.7 and so on and so forth
okay so that is the centered moving
average this is done primarily to
smoothen the data so that there are not
too many rough edges so that is what we
do here so
if we visualize this data now this is
how it looks right so if we take the
centered moving average as you can see
there is a gradual increase if this was
not the case if we had not centered it
the changes would have been much sharper
so that is the basically the smoothening
that we are talking about now
let's go and or do the forecast for the
fifth year so in order to do the
forecast what we will do is we will take
the centered moving average as our
baseline and then start doing a few more
calculations that are required in order
to come up with the prediction so what
we are going to do is we are going to
use this multiplicity or multiplicative
model in this case and this is how it it
looks so we take the product of
seasonality and
the trend and the irregularity
components and we just multiply that and
in order to get that this product of
these two we have basically the actual
value divided by cma yt value divided by
cma will give you the predicted value of
yt is equal to the product of all three
components therefore st into it is equal
to yt by cma so this is like this is
equal to yt right so therefore if we
want st into y t the product of
seasonality and irregularity is equal to
yt by cma so that is how we will work it
out i also have an excel sheet of the
actual data so let me just pull that up
all right so this is how the data looks
in excel as you can see here year one
quarter one two three four year 2.01234
and so on and this is the sales data and
then this is the moving average as i
mentioned this is how we calculate and
this is the centered moving average so
this is the primary component that we
will start working with and then we will
calculate since we want the product of
sc into yt that is equal to yt by cma so
if you see these values are nothing but
the yt value divided by cma so in this
case it is 4 by 3.5 which is 1.14
similarly 4.5 by 3.7 1.2 and so on and
so forth so we take we have the product
s t into i t and then the next step is
to
calculate the average of
respective quarters so that is what we
are doing here average of respective
quarters and then we need to calculate
the deseasonalized values so in order to
get decisionalized value we need to
divide yt by st that was calculated so
for example here it is 2.8 by 0.9 so we
got the decisionalized value here and
then we get the trend and then we get
the predicted values so in order to get
the predicted value which is basically
we predict the values for known values
as well like for example here one
quarter one we know the value but now
that we have our model we predict
ourselves and see how close it is so we
predict it as 2.89 whereas the actual
value is 2.8 then we have 2.59 the
actual value is 2.1 and so on just to
see how our model works and then
continue that into the fifth year
because in fifth year we don't have a
reference value okay and if we plot this
we will come to know how well our
calculations are how well our manual
model in this case we did not really use
a model but we did on our own manually
so it will tell us the trend so for
example the predicted value is this gray
color here and you can see that it is
actually pretty much following the
actual value which is the blue color
right and the gray color is the
predicted value so the at wherever we
know the values up to year four we can
see that our predicted values are
following or pretty much very close to
the actual values and then
assume that it has understood the
pattern and it is predicting correctly
for the next one year the next four
quarters right so that is what we are
doing here so these four quarters we did
not have actual data but we have the
predicted values so let's go back and
see how this is working in this using
the slides so this is we already saw
this part and
i think it was easier to see in the
excel sheet so we calculated the st id
the product of st and i t using the
formula like here y by y t by c m a we
got that and then we got st which is
basically y t so this is a average of
the first quarters for all the four
years and
similarly this is the average of the
second quarter for all the four years
and so on so these values are repeating
these are they are calculated only once
they get repeated as you can see here
and
then we get the decisionalize
data and that is basically yt by st so
we calculated st here and we have yt so
yt by st will give you the
decisionalized data and
we have got rid of the seasonal and the
irregular components so far now what we
are left with is the trend and
before we
start the time series forecasting or
time series analysis as i mentioned
earlier we need to completely get rid of
the
non-stationary components so we are
still left with the trend component so
now let us also remove the trend
component in order to do that we have to
find the or we have to calculate the
intercept and slope of the data because
that is required to calculate the trend
and
how are we going to do that we will
actually use um what is known as a
regression tool or analytics tool that
is available in excel so you remember we
have our data in excel so let me take
you to the excel and
here we need to calculate the intercept
and the slope in order to do that we
have to use the regression mechanism and
in order to use the regression mechanism
we have to use the analytics tool that
comes with excel so how do you
activate this tool so this is how you
would need to activate the tool
from excel you need to go to options
and
in options there will be add-ins and in
add-ins you will have um analysis tool
back and you select this
and
you just say go it will open up a box
like this you say analysis tool pack and
you say okay and now when you come back
in to the regular view of excel in the
data tab you will see data analysis
activated so you need to go to file
options
and add-ins
and then
analysis tool pack typically since i've
already added it it is coming at the top
but it would come under inactive
application add-ins so when you're doing
it for the first time so don't use vba
you just say analysis tool pack there
are two options one with vba like this
one and one without vba so just use the
one without vba and then instead of just
saying okay just take care that you
click on this go and not just okay so
you say go then it will give you these
options only then you select just the
analysis tool pack and then you say okay
all right so
and then when you come back to the main
view you click on data okay so this is
your normal home view perhaps so you
need to come to data and here is where
you will see data analysis available to
you and then if you click on that there
are a bunch of possibilities what kind
of data analysis you want to do if there
are options are given right now we just
want to do regression because we want to
find the slope and the intercept so
select regression and you say ok
and you will get these options for input
y range and input x range input y range
is the value y t so you just
select this and you can select up to
here and press enter and input x range
you can for now you start with uh the
baseline or you can also start with the
d seasoned values so you can just click
on these and say okay
i have already calculated it so these
are the intercept and the coefficients
that we are getting for these values and
we will actually use that to calculate
our trend here right so which is in the
j column so our trend is equal to
intercept plus slope into the time code
so
the intercept is uh out here as we can
see in our slide as well so if you see
here this is our intercept and the lower
value is the slope we have calculated
here and it's shown in the slides as
well so intercept so the formula is
shown here so our trend is equal to
intercept plus slope into time code time
code is nothing but this one t column a
one two three four okay so that's how
you calculate the trend and that's how
you use the data analysis tool from
excel using these two we calculate the
predicted values and using this formula
which is basically trend is equal to
intercept plus slope into time code and
then we can go and plot it see how it is
looking and therefore so we see here
that the predicted values are pretty
close to the actual values and
therefore we can safely assume that our
calculations which are like our manual
model is working and hence we
go ahead and predict for the fifth year
so till four years we know the actual
value as well so we can compare our
model is performing and for the fifth
year we don't have reference values so
we can use our equations to calculate
the values or predict the values for the
fifth year and we can go ahead and
safely calculate those values and when
we plot for the fifth year as well the
predicted values we see that they are
pretty much they captured the pattern
and we can safely assume that the
predictions are fairly accurate as we
can also see from the graph in the excel
sheet that we have already seen okay so
let's go and plot it so this is how the
plot looks this is the cma or the
centered moving average the green color
and then the blue color is the actual
data red color is the predicted value
predicted by our hand crafted model okay
so remember we did not use any regular
forecasting model or any tool we have
done this manually and
the actual tool will be used in the next
video this is just to give you an idea
about how behind the scenes or under the
hood how forecasting works or time
series analysis how it is performed okay
so it looks like it has captured the
trend properly so up to here is the
known reference we have reference and
from here onwards is purely predicted
and
as i mentioned earlier we can safely
assume that the values are accurate and
predicted properly for the fifth year
let's go ahead and implement a time
series forecast in r so in this section
what are we going to do we are going to
use arima model there are different
models and algorithms for performing
time series forecasts so we will use
arima which is the most common one and
we will also talk about what is
autocorrelation and partial
autocorrelation and we will see that in
our studio as well and then we will take
you through a use case where we will
focus the air ticket sales for the
future and then we will end with the
model validation using the junk box text
okay so with that let's get started
first of all as i mentioned we will be
using the arima model to do the forecast
of this time series data so let us try
to understand what is arima model so
arima is actually an acronym it stands
for auto regressive integrated moving
average so that is what is arima model
and it is specified by three parameters
which is p d and q p stands for auto
regressive so let me just mark this so
there are three components here auto
regressive integrated moving average
okay so these three parameters
correspond to those three components so
the p stands for auto regressive d for
integrated and q for moving average so
let us see what exactly
this is so these three factors are p is
the number of autoregressive terms or ar
we will see that in a little bit and d
is how many
levels of differences that we need to do
or differentiation we need to do and q
is the number of lagged forecast errors
so we'll see what exactly each of these
are so ar is the number of order
regressive terms and which is basically
denoted by the p and then we have d
which is for the number of times it has
to be differentiated
and then we have q which is for
the moving average so what exactly a r
terms so in terms of the regression
model autoregressive components
refer to the prior values of the current
value what we mean by that is here when
we talk about time series data focus on
the fact that there is regression so
what exactly happens in regression we
try to do something like if it is simple
linear regression we do some equation
like y is equal to mx plus c where there
are actually there are two variables one
is the dependent variable and then there
is an independent variable let me just
complete this equation as well mx plus c
right so this is a normal regression
curve or a simple regression curve now
here we are talking about autoregression
or
regressive so auto regressive as the
name suggests is regression of itself so
which means that here you have only one
variable which is your maybe the cost of
the flights or whatever it is right and
the other variable is basically time
dependent and therefore the value at any
given time and that we will denote as y
t for example so there is no x here
there is only one variable and which is
y and we say y t which is basically the
predicted value at a time interval t for
example is dependent on the previous
value so for example there may be a one
and then y t minus one and then there
will be like plus a 2 and right left
plus a 2 and y t minus 2 and
all right and then plus a 3 into y t
minus 3 all right so basically here what
we are saying is there's only one
variable here but there is a regression
component so we are doing a regression
on itself so that's how the term auto
regression comes into play so only thing
is that it is dependent on the previous
time values so there is a lag let's say
this is the first lag second lag third
lag and so on so the current value which
is y t is dependent on the previous time
lag values so that is what is order
regression component so this is what is
shown here for example in this case
instead of y we are calling it as x so
that's the same and this is represented
by some equation of that sort depending
on how many lags we take so that is the
ar component and the term p
is basically determines how many lags we
are considering so that's the p4 now
what is d d is the degree of
differencing so here differencing is
like
for the non-seasonal differences right
so for example if you take the values
like this which are given for five four
six and so on and so forth if you take
the differencing of one after another
like for example five minus 4 or 4 minus
5 the next value with the previous value
so 4 minus 5. so this is known as the
first order differencing so the result
is minus 1. similarly 6 minus 4 is 2. 7
minus 6 is 1. so this is first order
differencing and uh here we call it as d
is equal to one okay and same way we can
have second order third order and so on
then the last one is q q is the actually
we call it moving average but in reality
it is actually the error of the model so
we also sometimes represent as e t all
right so now arima model works on the
assumption that the data is stationary
which means that the trend and
seasonality of the data has been removed
that is correct okay so this we have
discussed in the first part how what
exactly is stationary data and how do we
remove the non-stationary part of it now
in order to test whether the data is
stationary or not there are two
important components that are considered
one is the autocorrelation function and
the other is the partial autocorrelation
function so this is referred to as acf
and psef right so what is
autocorrelation and what is the
definition or the correlation is
basically the similarity between values
of a same variable across observations
as the name suggests now how do we
actually find the autocorrelation
function the value right so this is
basically done by plotting and
autocorrelation function also tells you
how correlated points are with each
other based on how many time steps they
are separated by and so on that is
basically the time lag that we were
talking about and it is also used to
determine how past and future data
points are related and the value of the
autocorrelation function can vary from
-1 to 1. so if we plot this is how it
would look autocorrelation function
would look somewhat like this and there
is actually a readily available function
in r so we will see that and you can use
that to plot your autocorrelation
function okay so that is acf and we will
see that in our r studio in a little bit
and similarly you have partial
autocorrelation function so partial
autocorrelation function is the degree
of association between two variables
while adjusting the effect of one or
more additional variables so this again
can be measured and it can also be
plotted and its value once again can go
from minus one to one and it gives the
partial correlation of time series with
its own lagged values so lag again we
have discussed in the previous couple of
slides this is how a psef plot would
look in our studio we will see that as
well and once we get into the r studio
and with that let's get into rstudio and
take a look at our use case before we go
into the code let's just quickly
understand what exactly is the objective
of this use case so we are going to
predict some values or forecast some
values and we have the data of the
airline ticket sales of the previous
years and now we will try to find the or
predict or forecast the values for the
future years all right so
we will basically
identify the time series components like
trend seasonality and
random behavior we will actually
visualize this in our studio and then we
will actually forecast the values based
on the past values or history data
historical data so these are the steps
that we follow we will see in our studio
in a little bit just quickly let's go
through what are the steps we load the
data and it is a time series data if we
try to find out what class it belongs to
the data is actually air passengers data
that is already comes pre-loaded with
rstudio so we will be using that and we
can take a look at the data and then
what is the starting point what is the
end point so these are all functions
that are really available we'll be using
and then what is the frequency is
basically frequency is 12 which is like
yearly data right so every month the
data has been collected so for each year
it is 12 and then we can check for many
missing values if there are any and then
we can take a look at the summary of the
data this is what we do in exploratory
data analysis and then we can plot the
data visualize the data how it is
looking and we will see how the data has
some trend seasonality and so on and so
forth all right then we can take a look
at the cycle of the data using the cycle
function and we can see that it is every
month that's the cycle end of every 12
months a new cycle begins so each month
of the year as
the data is available then we can do box
plots to see for each month how the data
is varying over the various 10 or 12
years that we will be looking at this
data and
from
exploratory data analysis we can
identify that there is a trend there is
a seasonality component and how the
seasonality component varies also we can
see from the box plots and we can
decompose the data we can use the
decomposed function rather to see the
various components like the seasonality
trend and the irregularity part okay so
we will see all of this in our studio
this is how they will look this is the
once you decompose and this is how you
will actually you can visualize the data
this is the actual data and this is the
trend as you can see it's going upwards
this is the seasonal component and this
is your random or irregularity right so
we call it irregularity or we can also
call it random as you can see here yes
so the data must have a constant
variance and mean which means that it is
stationary before we start any analysis
time series analysis and we thought so
basically if it is stationary only then
it is easy to model the data perform
time series analysis so we can then go
ahead and fit the model as
we discussed earlier we'll be using
arimo model there are some techniques to
find out what should be the parameter so
we will see that when we go into rstudio
so
the auto arima function basically tells
us what should be the parameters right
so these parameters are the p d and q
that we talked about that's what is
being shown here so if we use auto arima
it will basically take all possible
values of this pdq these parameters and
it will find out what is the best value
and then it will
recommend so that is the advantage of
using auto arima all right so like in
this case it will tell us what if we use
this parameter trace we set the
parameter trace is equal to true then it
will basically tell us what is the value
of this aic which has to be minimum so
the lower the value the better so for
each of these combinations of p d and q
it will give us the values here and then
it will recommend to us which is the
best model okay because whichever has
the lowest value of this aic it will
recommend that as your best pdq values
so once we have that we can see that we
will basically we can potentially get a
model or the equation model is nothing
but the equation and based on the
parameters that we get and we can do
some diagnostics we can do some plotting
to see how whether there is a plot for
the residuals so which shows the
stationarity and then we can also take a
look at the acf and pacf we can plot the
acf and psef and then we can do some
forecasting for the future here so in
this case we have up to 1960 and then we
can see how we can forecast for the next
10 years which is 1970 up to 1970. and
once we have done this can we validate
this model yes definitely we can
validate this model and
to validate the findings we use
jump box test and this is how you just
call box.test and then you pass these
parameters and you will get the values
that will be returned which will tell us
whether this how accurate this model is
how accurate the collections are so the
values of p are quite insignificant in
this case we will see that and that also
indicates that our model is free of
autocorrelation and that will basically
be it so let's go back and into our
rstudio and
go through these steps in real time so
we have to import this library forecast
package is not installed you have to go
here and install the forecast package
okay so that's the easy way to install
rather than so click on this install i
will not do it now because i have
already installed so the first time
that's only one time then after that you
just have to load it into memory and
then keep going so we will load this
data called air passengers so
by calling this data method and if you
see the the data passengers is loaded
here and if we check for the class it is
a time series data ts data so we can
check for the dates we can also view the
data in a little bit and start date is
1949 and january
and our end date is 1960 december
and the frequency is 12 which is like
collected monthly so
that is the frequency which is uh 12
here and then we check if there are any
missing values there are no missing
values and then we take a look at the
summary of the data this is all
exploratory data analysis and then if
you just display the data this is how it
looks
and then we need to decompose this data
so we will kind of store this in an
object yes data and then use that to
decompose and store the new values let
me just clear this for now and if we
decompose basically as we have seen in
the slides decomposing is breaking it
into the trend seasonality and irregular
or random components then you can go
ahead and plot it so when you plot it
you can see here let me zoom this this
is our original plot or observed value
as it is known as then we have
decomposed the three parts which is
basically the trend as you can see there
is a poor trend then the seasonal
component so this is a some regularly
occurring pattern and then there is a
random value which is basically you
cannot really give any equation or
function or anything like that so that's
what this plotting has done and then you
can actually plot them individually as
well so these are the individual plots
for the trend for the seasonal component
and the random component all right so
now let's take a look at the original
data and see how the trend is in a way
so if we do this linear regression line
it will show that it is going upwards
and we can also take a look at the cycle
that are there which is nothing but we
have a frequency of 12 right so the
cycles will display that it is january
february to december and then back to
january february and so on and so forth
and if we do box plots for the monthly
data you will see that for each of the
months right and over the 10 years that
the data that we have we will see that
there is a certain pattern right this is
also in a way to find the seasonality
component so
while january february sales are
relatively low around july august the
sales pick up so especially in july i
think the sales are the highest and this
seems to be happening pretty much every
year right so this is every year in july
there seems to be a peak in the sales
and then it goes down and slightly
higher in december and so on so that is
again part of our exploratory data
analysis and once again let's just plot
the data now as i said in order to fit
into an arima model we need the values
of pd and q now one way of doing it is
there are multiple ways actually of
doing it the earlier method of doing it
was you draw the autocorrelation
function plot and then partial
autocorrelation function plot and then
observe that and where does this change
and then identify what should be the
values of p and q and so on now r really
has a very beautiful
method which we can use to avoid all
that manual process that we used to do
earlier so what r will do is there is a
method called auto arima and if we just
call this auto arima method and it will
basically go and test the arima model
for all possible values of this
parameter pdq and then it will suggest
to you what should be the best model and
it will return that best model with the
right values of p d and q so you we as
data scientists don't have to do any
manual you know trial and error kind of
stuff okay so we got the model now and
this is the model it it has pdq values
are 2 1 1 the pdq and this is the
seasonal part of it so we can ignore it
for now and so if we want to actually
understand how this has returned these
values 2 1 1 as the best one there is
another functionality or feature where
we can use this trace function or trace
parameter so if you pass to auto arima
the trace parameter what it will do is
it will show you how it is doing this
calculation what is the value of the aic
basically asc is what you know defines
the accuracy of the model the lower the
better okay so for each combination of
pdq it will show us the value of aic so
let's run it before instead of me
talking so much let's run this if we run
auto arima with trace you see here there
is a red mark here that means it is
performing it's executing this and here
we see the display right so it starts
with certain values of pdq and then it
finds that value is too high so it
starts with a gain with some 0 1 1 0 and
so on and so forth and ultimately it
tells us okay this is our best model you
see here it says this is our best model
2 1 1. let's go back and see did we get
the same one yes we got the same one
when we ran without trace as well right
now y is 2 1 1 let us see where is 2 1 1
here is our 2 1 1 and if you compare the
values you see that 1 0 1 7 is pretty
much the lowest value and therefore it
is saying this is our best model all
other values are higher so that's how
you kind of
get your model and then now that you
have your model what you have to do you
need to predict the values right so
before that let us just do some tests of
these values so for that you install t
series again if you are doing it for the
first time you would rather use this
package and install and say t series and
install it and then you just use this
library function to load it into your
memory all right so now that we got our
model using auto arima let us go ahead
and forecast and also test the model and
also plot the acf and psef remember we
talked about this but we did not really
use it we don't have to use that but at
least we will visualize it and for some
of the stuff we may need this t series
library so if you are doing this for the
first time you may have to install it
and my recommendation is don't use it in
the code you go here and install t
series and i will not do it now because
i have already installed it but this is
a preferred method and once you install
it you just load it using this library's
function and then you can plot your
residuals and this is how the residuals
look and you can plot your acf and psef
okay so this is how your pacf looks and
this is how your acf looks for now there
is really nothing else we need to do
with acf and psef this is just to
visualize how that how it looks but as i
mentioned earlier we were actually using
these visualizations or these graphs to
identify the values of p d and q and how
that was done it's
out of scope of this video so we will
leave it at that and
then we will forecast for the next 10
years how do we focus that so we call
forecast and we pass the model and we
pass what is the level of accuracy that
you need which is 95 percent and for how
many periods right so basically we want
for 10 years which is like 10 into 12
time periods so that's what we are doing
here and now we can plot the forecast
value so you see this is the original
value up to i think 62 or whatever and
then it goes up to 72 this blue color is
the predicted value let's go and zoom it
up so that we can see it better so from
here onwards here for casting and you
can see that it looks like our model has
kind of learned the pattern and this
pattern looks very similar to what we
see in the actual data now how do we
test our
model so we can do what is known as a
box test and we pass our model here
residuals basically with different lags
and from those values here the p values
here we find that they are reasonably
low to p values which means our model is
fairly accurate with that note we have
reached to the end of this session
thanks to our training experts hope you
found this tutorial helpful if you have
any queries regarding this tutorial or
if you feel you have a suggestion for us
then please feel free to drop it down in
the comment section below and our
experts team will be happy to reach you
out this is ravi signing off until next
time
thank you
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here